WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO COVER
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING DATED
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
TODAY WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
MEMBER THAT WILL BE JOINING US-
IT PARTICIPATION REMOTELY
SENATOR WIENER. AND IN ROOM
FORTY TWO ZERO THREE WITH ME
WILL BE JOINING US SENATOR
JONES AND SENATOR PAN. WE ALSO
HAVE FOUR SEPARATE PANELS THAT
MAKE UP OUR AGENDA TODAY ALL OF
OUR WITNESS. WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY VIA ZOOM
OR CONFERENCE CALL. FOR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAZOR HAD FEATURED IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND MUTE.
POLICE SELECTOR MU BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOUR DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOUR READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS. WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FOUR SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
ONE THREE FIVE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO. THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE WILL BE HERE IN ALL
OF THE PANELS. OF WITNESSES ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. FOLLOWING EACH
PANEL COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL BE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE PANELIST.
AFTER ALL OF THE PANELS ARE
FINISHED WITH THEIR
PRESENTATIONS. WE WILL HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON THE
TOPICS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THAT DEVICE YOUR
WATCHING THE HEARING. ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LATIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS FOR
JUSTIN TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. TODAY'S HEARING IS
FOCUSED ON CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
YOUTH AND HOW THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IS IMPACTING
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR WE'RE
NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT A SYSTEM
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LIVES.
PRECIOUS YOUNG LIVES INCLUDING
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
AMONGST US. MANY FOSTER YOUTH
WERE ALREADY SUFFERING FROM
SOME OF THE WORST CHALLENGES
AND TRAGEDIES IMAGINABLE PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC. NOW THE
CORONAVIRUSES ADDING EVEN MORE
COMPLICATIONS. BURDENS AND
BARRIERS ALMOST EVERY ASPECT OF
DAILY LIFE HAS BEEN IMPACTED
AND FOSTER YOUTH OFTEN FACE
EVEN BIGGER HURDLES WITH FEW
RESOURCES TO OVERCOME THEM.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO. I COULD
NOT SLEEP AND I DECIDED TO GO
THROUGH THE DRIVE THRU AT A
LOCAL FAST FOOD RESTAURANT.
WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN A HELLO
AND THANK YOU. TURNED OUT TO BE
THIRTY MINUTE CONVERSATION WITH
THE FOSTER YOUTH. WITHOUT
ASKING OR WITHOUT KNOWING HIM
HE POURED HIS HEART HIS HEART
OUT TO ME. HE SPOKE AT LENGTH
OF THE CHALLENGES HE HAS FACED.
SPECIFICALLY LOSING HIS TEENAGE
BROTHER TO SUICIDE AND THE TOLL
IT TOOK ON HIS EDUCATION AND
WELL BEING. THIS YOUNG MAN
DESERVES AN OPPORTUNITY. HE
DESERVES TO BE HEARD HE LIKE
MANY OTHER YOUTH ACROSS
CALIFORNIA NEED US NOW MORE
THAN EVER. CALIFORNIA HAS THE
BEST EXPERTS IN THE FIELD SOME
THAT WILL BE JOINING US TODAY.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DEDICATED THEIR
CAREERS TO HELPING FOSTER YOUTH.
WE HAVE PASSIONATE LEADERS WHO
HELPED CREATE INNOVATIVE
LANDMARK LEGISLATION THAT SET
NATIONAL NEW STANDARDS FOR
FOSTER CARE PROGRAMS. BUT THE
SYSTEM IS STILL FRAGILE AND
THERE IS STILL MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE ESPECIALLY WITH CODED.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE HERE TODAY.
TO LEARN MORE FROM THOSE
INVOLVED INCLUDING FOSTER YOUTH
TO HEAR HOW THE PANDEMIC HAS
CHANGED AND CHALLENGED THE
SYSTEM. AND HOPEFULLY LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE WAYS THE
LEGISLATURE CAN HELP THOSE
AFFECTED. WE NEED TO TAKE A
STEP BACK AND MAKE SURE WE ARE
PROVIDING THE RIGHT TOOLS AND
RESOURCES NEEDED TO HELP
STABILIZE. PROTECT AND NURTURE
OFF OF FOSTER YOUTH. WE MUST
MAKE SURE CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
YOUTH ARE HEARD. IT'S MAKE SURE
THEY ARE SEEN WE MUST MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS. SOME OF THE STORIES
AREN'T ALWAYS EASY TO HEAR.
SOME MORE HEARTBREAKING. MANY
OF THESE YOUNG LIVES ARE UNDER
INTENSE PRESSURE AND FACE
UNIMAGINABLE CIRCUMSTANCES. THE
HEALTHCARE CRISIS THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS AND THE HOUSING CRISIS.
ALL ARE COLLIDING AND THEY'RE
HAVING AN EVEN GREATER IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. BUT WE CAN AND MUST
LISTEN SO THAT WE MAY HELP. AS
WE BEGIN THIS YEAR AND I WANT
TO SAY. A QUICK WORD DIRECTLY
TO ALL OF OUR FOSTER YOUTH
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WHO MAY BE
LISTENING TODAY. I WANT YOU TO
KNOW SOMETHING. I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT WE DO HEAR YOU WE DO
SEE YOU YOU ARE NOT ALONE WE'RE
WORKING TO PROVIDE SOLUTIONS
THAT WILL DIRECTLY IMPROVE YOUR
LIFE. WE WANT YOU TO SUCCEED
AND IT'S OUR JOB TO GIVE YOU
THE TOOLS GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT
YOU NEED TO HAVE YOUR OWN SHOT
AT THE AMERICAN DREAM. I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY. BUT BEFORE
I INTRODUCED THE FIRST PANEL I
WOULD LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO
OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR JONES
FOR AN OPENING COMMENT AND THEN
TO ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHO MAY LIKE TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU YOUR MURDER ACTUALLY DIDN'T
HAVE ANY PREPARE STATEMENTS FOR
OPENING BUT I AM- I DO
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS. ANNA LOOK
VERY MUCH FORWARD TO- THE
INFORMATION THEY'RE GOING TO BE
GATHERED TODAY SO THANK YOU
FOR. UP IN THIS MEETING
TOGETHER AND- I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO A ROBUST
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR NOW
BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH OUR
SPEAKERS I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW
PLEASE DIAL THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER 844-291-6364 WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE. FOUR SEVEN FIVE SEVEN ONE
THREE FIVE. SO WITH OUR FIRST
PANEL WE HAVE. AND JUST A
COUPLE OF A FEW REMINDERS AS A
MATTER OF HOUSEKEEPING I WOULD
LIKE TO REMIND OUR PANELISTS
THAT EACH PERSON HAS THREE TO
FIVE MINUTES TO SHOW THEIR
TESTIMONY FOLLOWING THE
CONCLUSION OF EACH PANEL I WILL
OPEN IT UP TO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OUR FIRST PANEL GOING
TO DISCUSS AN OVERVIEW OF THE
PANDEMIC'S IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. AND OUR FIRST SPEAKER
TODAY IS GREGORY ROSE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
MR ROSE IF YOU CAN PLEASE AND
MAKE YOURSELF. THANK YOU.
CHERTANOVO MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE SENATE STAFFERS
COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS- MY NAME
IS GREG ROSEN THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. AND I'M HAPPY TO BE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT TALK WITH YOU TODAY
ABOUT THIS VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC. I THINK THE THING THAT
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY
RESONATES WITH ALL OF US WHICH
IS THERE'S BEEN A LOT DONE AND
THEY'RE STILL CLEARLY MUCH MORE
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. I DO
WANT TO START BY RECOGNIZING
THAT THE WORK OF THE
LEGISLATURE. AND ARE MANY OF MY-
CALL. AND OTHER ON THIS. WHO
HAVE BEEN EITHER. RESPONSIBLE
FOR- JUST READ. THIS RESPONSE
OR HAVE HELPED US- DIRECTOR AND
HE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT OUR
APPROACH. WHAT I'D LIKE TO TALK
WITH YOU ABOUT IN MY THREE TO
FIVE MINUTES THIS MORE THIS
AFTERNOON HE IS. A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT THAT. HAS HAS BEEN
DOING AS RESPONSE THE- WHAT WE
DOES. AND CLEARLY WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE AREA. WHERE THERE ARE
AREAS THAT NEED ADDITIONAL
ATTENTION. LIKE TO JUST. ALSO
SAY THAT THE- EARLY ON STARTED
IN IN THE- ISSUED IN
NEIGHBORHOOD OF TWENTY PIECES
OF GUIDANCE TO THIS IS TO THAT
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. SOME OF
THAT RELATED TO THAT EXECUTIVE
ORDERS OF THAT THE GOVERNOR
OTHERS WITH FEDERAL
FLEXIBILITIES AND OTHERS WHERE
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED FLEXIBILITY
WITH ENCOURAGED ACTUALLY WANTED
TO PROVIDE- I IT'S THE FIELD
EIGHT SO THE GUY APPROACH
RESEARCH APPROACH. RISK
SIMILARLY ARE. MORGAN WHICH IS.
OVER TWENTY GUIDED IT'S A GUIDE
THROUGH- THROUGH- INFORMATION
NOTICES TO FOSTER FAMILY AGE.
AND TO OUR PROGRAM. IF I IF I
JUST ROUTE REMIND FOLKS A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHERE THINGS A
THAT EARLY EARLY AFTER OF THE
X. OR WE GOT TO REALLY JEALOUS.
AND. SUPPORTED OVER EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND FAMILY- WITH ACCESS
THE TO ONCE TO- IMPORTANT
RESEARCH AND- SHE. HELPLINE YOU
WAS A STAB IN THE DOLLARS FIVE
HUNDRED FAMILIES AND GETTING
THREE HUNDRED REFERRALS A WE TO
A REACHED. WE PROVIDED OVER
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND DAM- ARE AT
RISK OF ABUSE IN A R. AND
OVERBURDENED SH- DURING
ASSISTANCE REPEAT CARDS. WE
WORKED WITH- THAT FAMILY REESE
CENTER SAYS HE THROUGH EIGHTY
TWO LEAD A TO ALTER PER FOR
THREE AND FOUR SEVEN OTHER
REESE CENTER. A MILLION DOLLAR
A MONTH THAT REACH. IN SEVEN
THOUSAND FAMILIES WHO WERE
PROVIDED A HI GOOD AND SUPPORT
YOU CAN IN THE- EARLY- EARLIEST
OF THE- OF THE PANDEMIC. OVER
FOUR SIX. FIVE FAMILY AND
RELATIVES FOR SUPPORT THAT AND
IN THAT WORK AND SAME WAY. THAT
WORK ALSO SUPPORTED OVER TWENTY
HOW. RIGHT FAMILIES. OUR OUR
OFFICE THE ON IN PART WITH FOR
JONTRON WORK AND OVERSIGHT
HUNDRED- COMMUNITY BAY WORK
PROVIDED- TWELFTH SMARTPHONE
AND SIX EIGHT LAST SEARCHED TO
OLD FOSTER YOUTH AND FOUR
HUNDRED NAY THREE THE CHILL BE
THE AGES OF FIVE AND RECEIVE A
SMART ALL OF THIS IS A YOU KNOW
ISN'T GIVEN THE IMPORTANT THAT
THE RIVER ON DISTANCE LEARNING
VIRTUAL VISIT AND SOCIAL.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS WE
IT- TOGETHER WITH A LOT REESE
FROM YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE AGED
OUT OF OUR EXT FIVE CARES-
BETWEEN A AND ARE AND WE HAVE
I'M SORRY WHO WOULD HAVE H. OF
OUR FOSTER SYSTEM AT AGE ONE
AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
OUR COUNTY CALL TO SURE YOUNG
WHO WERE. WHO WERE ELIGIBLE
THESE BY- WHO MAY HAVE DROPPED
OFF OUR YOU GET BACK THE ON THE
FIND OF AND THE CASE SUPPORTS
THROUGH BUDGET OUR OFFICE OF
THE TRIBE OF THE CARE I STAYED
OPEN TWENTY ARE SORRY SEVEN
DAYS A- TWELVE HOUR A DAY TO
FROM ON OVER FOUR HUNDRED US
CALLS FOR FOSTER USED DEALING
WITH DIFFERENT OF THE. SPRING
TO NOW WE HAVE ISSUED SOME
GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT THROUGH
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO TEACHERS AND
OTHERS TO- WITH IDEAS ABOUT HOW
TO KEEP AN EYE ON AND SUPPORT
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING IN
FAMILIES THAT ARE. OVER
BURDENED BY. THE PANDEMIC THIS
SUBSEQUENT RECESSION AND OTHER
OTHER- BURDENS. WE ARE. WE ALSO
HAD ANOTHER SERVED AT THEIR
THERE IS. THERE IS APPROPRIATE
USE OF TECHNOLOGY AND THAT THAT
SOMETIMES FAMILY TIME OFTEN
KNOWN AS PARENTS AND SIBLING
VISITS CAN BE SUPPLEMENTED THAT
THE IN PERSON CAN BE
SUPPLEMENTED THROUGH THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY- WE'VE SEEN VIRTUAL
FAMILY DINNERS VIRTUAL TIME
VIRTUAL STORYTELLING ALL THAT
SEEMS TO SUPPLEMENT AND
SUPPORT- THE IMPORTANT I.
CONNECTION BETWEEN SIBLINGS AND
PARENTS- AND- IN THESE DAYS OF
SOCIAL DISTANCING. WE'VE
NOTICED AND OBSERVED THAT
FOSTER YOUTH. AND CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS ARE CREATE HAS.
RESILIENT AND STRONG AND YET
THEY SILL HAVE NEEDS CLEARLY
AS YOU NOTED EARLIER AND THEN I
GOT SUGGESTED THAT WE SPEND
SOME TIME ON TODAY THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE IN CARE DO YOU NEED
SUPPORT WHEN IT COMES TO STAY
CONNECTED TO THEIR THEIR THEIR
FAMILIES FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY.
WITH ME IT WAS SUPPORT FOR AT
EDUCATION AND JOBS. WE ARE.
MAINTAINING CONNECTIONS AND
THINKING THROUGH RECREATIONAL
ACTIVITIES AND IN THESE DAYS OF.
A RECENT SURVEY THAT WE GADGET
WITH OVER FIVE HUNDRED FOSTER
PARENTS RESOURCE FAMILIES IN
FOUR COUNTIES DEMONSTRATED THAT
OVER 82% OF THEMSELVES THAT
THEY WERE DOING GOOD OR VERY
GOOD RANGE AND YET THEY WERE
STILL NEEDS WORK THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN TERMS OF CHILD
CARE. SUPPORT YOUR DISTANCE
EDUCATION INCLUDING TUTORING
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THEIR CARE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT AS SO MANY OF HAD TO
DIG INTO THEIR OWN- RESOURCES
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL. SUPPORTS
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THEIR CARE. AND MANY
FAMILIES HAVE ACTUALLY HAVE HAD
THE NEED HAVE EXPRESSED NEEDS
FOR CONCRETE SERVICES GROCERIES
CLEANING SUPPLIES OTHER KINDS
OF THINGS. GIVEN THAT THE
NATURE OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS AND SUBSEQUENT RECESSION.
AS I MENTIONED WE ARE REALLY
RELY VERY DEEPLY ON ANSWER AND
ASKED ARE ARE ARE CARE GIVING
COMMUNITY TO. TO REALLY STRETCH
AND TO AND TO THINK OF THINGS
DIFFERENTLY AND TO SUPPORT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE IN CARE AND THAT
IT DOES AND BOTH. RESOURCE
FAMILIES RELATIVE CAREGIVERS
AND OUR RESIDENTIAL PROVIDERS
ALL HAVE HAVE DONE SO AND YET
THEY ALL STILL NEED. SOME LEVEL
OF SUPPORT ESPECIALLY AROUND
DISTANCE LEARNING AROUND SOCIAL
AND RECREATIONAL- CONNECTIONS.
I JUST LIKE TO ALSO NOTE IF YOU
KEEP OTHER. THINGS AS PART OF
MY TESTIMONY- DEBT CERTAINLY.
WHEN IT COMES TO REUNIFICATION
WITH FAMILIES- PARENTS AND
THEIR CHILDREN SERVICES ARE SO
OFTEN NOW JOHN THROUGH VIRTUAL
MEANS AND WE NEED TO THINK
THROUGH WHAT DOES IT MEAN. IN
TERMS OF SH PROVIDING THE
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES THAT THAT
FACT THAT PARENTS NEED IN ORDER
TO REUNIFY APPROPRIATELY AND I
THINK WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO.
ASK OUR SERVICE SECTOR TO
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE. THROUGH ITS
USE OF TECHNOLOGY AND TO THINK
ABOUT THAT THE PRUDENT AND
APPROPRIATE USE OF IN PERSON
AND FACE TO FACE CONTACTS WHEN
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL. WE
CERTAINLY HAS NOTICED THAT ARE.
THAT OUR PARENTS ARE INVOLVED
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
RECEIVING SERVICES AND ARE REAL
AND NEED TO ATTEND COURT NEED
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY EITHER-
THROUGH THEM. THROUGH THEIR OWN
PER TO GET IT TO THEM
PERSONALLY OR TO PROVIDE SPACES
FOR THEM TO OBTAIN THE SERVICES.
THE APPROPRIATE KINDS OF A
CLASSROOM OF COURSE FOR THAT
THEY NEED AND COURT SERVICES
WHICH WILL. WORK PARTICULARLY
HAVE SOME OF THAT- CONCERNED
ABOUT- WHAT THIS MEANS FOR
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED- YOUNG
PEOPLE IN CARE- AND OUT ON THE
STREETS WITH WITH GIVEN THE
LARGE NUMBER OF THE INCREASED
NUMBER OF YOUNG PEOPLE ONLINE
IN THE PREDATORY NATURE OF SO
MANY OF THE TRAFFICKERS THERE'S
SOME CONCERNED ABOUT. MAKING
SURE THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE I
CAN. SAY STATE AND AWAY FROM.
DESPITE THESE OF. OUR CLEARLY
GIVEN THE THAT STRESSES WE ALL
HAVE- CONCERNED ABOUT THE- THE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE- OUT ON
THE STREETS OR AWAY FROM HOME
WE MAY HAVE TO RELY ON SOME
KIND OF START SURVIVAL SEX AND
WITH THOSE I THINK I ALSO
CREATE A HEIGHTENED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EXPLOITATION
AND SO WE REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT. THESE YOU. CLEARLY. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER DESPITE THE
FACT THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A GREAT DEAL OF
TECHNOLOGY TO YOUNG PEOPLE IN
CARE- OUR WORK WITH- WITH IT
WITH THAT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND THEIR MOST
RECENT- CHANGING POLICY THAT-
THAT. WOULD ALLOW IDEATIONAL
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
SPENT ON INCREASED DATA PLANS
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO. ARE THE
BENEFICIARIES BENEFICIARIES UP
THOSE- OF THOSE RESOURCES IS
IMPORTANT SO. TO THAT THE FACT
THAT WE PROVIDED TECHNOLOGY IS
HELPFUL TOO. MANY PEOPLE STILL
NEED TECHNOLOGY AND THEN
THERE'S ACCESS TO DATA.
BROADBAND AND OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE THEY CONTINUED TO BE.
CONTINUE TO BE. WE ALSO NOTE
THAT I'M SURE WE'LL HEAR MORE
ABOUT THIS FROM OUR- FROM OUR
COUNTY COLLEAGUES BUT YOU KNOW
THE BALANCE BETWEEN. WORK FORCE
AT A SAFETY AND THE MULTI
TASKING OF THE CURRENT
WORKFORCE WHO ARE WHO ARE OFTEN
PARENTS AND IF THEY ARE NOT
THEY ARE OFTEN CARE GIVERS FOR
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS. THERE
NEEDED TO MAINTAIN SAFETY AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE
AS ESSENTIAL WORKERS THERE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO. ATTEND TO THE
NEEDS OF KIDS AND FAMILIES IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
TENSION. EXISTS ADD AT IN IN
THIS DAY AND AGE SIMILARLY THE
TENSION BETWEEN- ONGOING.
ACTIONS BETWEEN. SIBLINGS AND-
AND YOUNG PEOPLE AND IN NEED OF
THEIR CARE GIVERS TO ALSO
MAINTAIN. THE SAFETY OF THEIR
HOUSEHOLD IS AN ONGOING ISSUE
THAT I THINK WE TOGETHER NEED
TO. CHECK GRAPPLE WITH. I THINK
WE NEED TO STAY VIGILANT IN KKK%
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
RECENT SURGE IN OUR RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
FOLLOW THE THAT THAT THE
CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE
WE PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
AND RESOURCES TO- THROUGH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND OTHER
AND OTHER THINGS TO OUR CARE
GIVING- WORKFORCE AND FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THOSE. IN THOSE
PROGRAMS. AND MOST OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WE NEED TO ALL STAY
CONNECTED TOGETHER WE ALL ARE
ON IN IN THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE OUR COMMUNITY AND
ADVOCATES AND YOUNG PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE OF
PARENTS NEED TO STAY CONNECTED.
WE NEED TO HAVE ONGOING
COMMUNICATION WE NEED TO LISTEN
TO EACH OTHER AND WE NEED TO
JOINTLY PROBLEM SOLVED TO MAKE
OUR WAY THROUGH THIS. PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS IT SUBSEQUENT
RECESSION AND OTHER ISSUES THAT
ARE ARE ARE POPPING UP FROM
FROM THAT WITH THAT I DO THINK
I'LL CONCLUDE MY REMARKS AND
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION I APPRECIATE
THIS TIME JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
THE AFTERNOON WITH YOU ALL
YOU'RE- WITH THESE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR ROSE AT THIS
MOMENT WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH
OUR NEXT SPEAKER AND HOLD
QUESTIONS UP FOR THE END OF THE
PANEL- UP NEXT WE HAVE BOBBY
CABLE DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. MISTER GILBERT
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO MEET
YOURSELF AND BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOT
A CHAIR IN THE PERSON OF THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
SUBJECT AND- WHAT WAS THE MOST
DIFFICULT. MY THIRTY PLUS YEAR
CAREER BOND. PAST FEW MONTHS
AND I KNOW THAT THAT IS A
FEELING SHARED BY MANY
ADMINISTRATORS- YEAH BUT MUST
SAY THAT CDSS AND WOULD HAVE
BEEN THERE FOR US THROUGHOUT
THIS AND I WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR THAT. YOUR EFFORTS ALSO
ESPECIALLY A REALIGNMENT BACK
FILL THAT ALLOWED US TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE OUR-
YOUNG GOING PANDEMIC.
SIGNIFICANTLY COMPOUNDED
CHALLENGES WE FACE AS WE WORK
TO ENSURE THAT CHILDREN ARE
SAFE FAMILIES ARE STRONG.
COMMUNITIES ARE HELPING. WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED NUMEROUS
STRATEGIES INCLUDING ONGOING
ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND STAKEHOLDERS MANY
OF THEM ARE ON THIS CALL TODAY.
IN ORDER TO MEET THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES BOB ENDEMIC. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICIALS TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF GOOD
NINETEEN ANTHONY AND THE STAFF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES DURING
THIS PERIOD. WE'VE BEEN
DELIBERATE OUR CHRISTIAN
GAUGING THE COMMUNITY AND
INVESTING IN CRITICAL RESOURCES
TO IMPROVE CHAO WILL BE.
ACCORDING TO THE CHRISTIAN
COMMUNICATION AND OUTREACH TO
PARENTS USE. CAN SERVICE
PROVIDERS. IN LIGHT OF THE 50%
DECLINE IN CALLS INITIALLY
THROUGH OUR CHILD PROTECTION
HOTLINE- WE ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN
A ROBUST PUBLIC INFORMATION
CAMPAIGN CALLING ON RESIDENTS
TO HELP US PREVENT CHILD ABUSE
IN YOUR REPORT THE CONCERNS
THAT THEY MAY SEE. WE ALSO
EMBARKED ON THE EXPANSION OF
HOPE WANT YOUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE LA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION YES THE CHILD SAFETY
NET. FOR HOMEBOUND FAMILIES. WE
HAVE BEEN HASKELL. WITH TO ONE.
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR FAMILIES
TO SEEK HELP IT INCLUDES-
INCLUDING INCREASED SERVICES
PREVENTION AFTER CARE PROVIDERS.
SOURCE CENTERS IN KINSHIP
CENTERS. FROM OUR EXPERIENCE AT
THE TOP GAPS EXPERIENCED BY
CARE GIVERS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OR GROCERIES AND HOME SUPPLIES
CHILDCARE AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT
THE CURRENT ECONOMIC HIGHLIGHTS
THE IMPORTANCE OF THESE
PREVENTATIVE BEEN CRITICAL
RESOURCES FOR THIS WE REQUEST
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT. WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO MAINTAINING
CALMLY REUNIFICATION SIMPLY
BONDING FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
OUR FAMILIES DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. ARE STAFFED
WITH THE BEST MAJORITY OF THE
REQUIRED BUSINESS. TEMPLATE SO
TAKE FAMILY VISIT IN PERSON
WOULD SAY AND ABLE TO DO THAT
WITH. IN THE GUIDELINES ISSUED
BY PUBLIC HEALTH. WE CONTINUE
TO WORK SAUTEED ACCESS
TECHNOLOGY THAT ALLOWS OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES TO
MAINTAIN THEIR CONTACT WITH ONE
ANOTHER. WE CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
WITH THE SUPERIOR COURT ARE
JUSTICE PARTNERS ANOTHER COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN A FIVE AND
IMPLEMENT STRATEGIES TO REDUCE
THE COURTS BACKLOG CREATED BY
COULD NINETEEN. CELERY HEARINGS
AND VIRTUAL COURTROOM
ACCESSIBILITY MEASURES BEYOND.
BEING EMPLOYED ALSO INCLUDE
ADDRESSING TECHNOLOGICAL GAPS
EXPANDING OUR USE OF THE
STIPULATION PROCESS TO MOVE
CASES WHERE GREEN CAN BE
ACHIEVED. WE'VE ASKED FOR
SUPPORT IN THIS AREA IT
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT THE
STRATEGIES EMPLOYED THUS FAR.
THE NUMBER OF DCFS INVOLVED
CHILDREN AND YOUTH HAS
INCREASED BY ELEVEN POINT 4%
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF A
PANDEMIC IN L. A. COUNTY THAT
NEED TO MOVE FROM THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND CHILDREN INSERTED IN
THE GIVEN TIME TO THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND AT THIS POINT. ACTORS
ASSOCIATED WITH RECORD BACKLOG
INCLUDES LOWER CASE CLOSURE
RATES. WE HAVE BEEN SAYING THAT
DROPPED BY 50% BETWEEN APRIL
AND JUNE ALTHOUGH THE CLOSURE
RATES HAVE BEEN GOING BACK UP.
OVER THE LAST FIVE MONTHS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO RECOVERING
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THERE
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT MEET THE
NEEDS AND DEMANDS OF INCREASED
CASELOAD ANAHIT SERVICES ARE
CRUCIAL TO ENSURING THAT OUR
STAFF WERE ABLE TO DO THEIR
CRITICAL WORK. WITH REMARKS.
THE CFS IS IMPORTING A NUMBER
STRATEGIES TO SUPPORT PARENTS
AND CAREGIVERS WITH BALANCING
THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS. OF THEIR
CHILDREN IN THEIR OWN
OBLIGATIONS INCLUDING ENHANCING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH AYE FOSTER.
<c.cyan>0C MOBILE. THE SCHOOL</c>
DISTRICT IN L. A. COUNTY. ALSO
THE FAIR HEARINGS CARE GIVER
ENGAGING SCHOOL AND CHILD
LEARNING AND ACCESSING
AVAILABLE RESOURCE AND- WE ALSO
ARE FACILITATING ONE ON ONE
BEHAVIORAL SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN WITH HIGH RISK
BEHAVIORS. YEAH HERE'S THE CARE
GIVERS OF STUDENTS WITH HIGH
RISK BEHAVIORAL AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION NEEDS WE'RE TRYING TO
ASSIST WITH THE VIRTUAL PROCESS
AFTER LEARNING. THE CHALLENGES
THAT OUR ACCOUNT IN QUALITY
THROUGH ON THAT. THE
UNINTERRUPTED PROVISION OF
EDUCATIONAL HOUSING FINANCIAL
AN INDEPENDENT LIVING PROGRAM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS HAS BEEN
AND REMAINS ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL FOR OUR YOUTH AND OUR
YOUNG ADULTS. BECAUSE INCLUDING
THOSE WHO TURNED TWENTY ONE OR
OLDER DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
L. A. COUNTY THAT'S FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY PLUS YOU. WE
ARE CONTINUING TO ASK YOU FOR
ANY FUNDING AND SUPPORT FOR OUR
YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS BUT
SINCE THIS IS CRITICAL TO THEIR
HEALTHCARE ECONOMIC IMPACT. AND
BEING ABLE TO SURVIVE BECAUSE
OF IT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEMONSTRATED COMMITMENT TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. AS WE
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES POSED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND PREPARE FOR A
POTENTIAL TWENTY BMX. WE ASK
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
LEADERSHIP AND COLLECTIVE
EFFORT TO PROTECT OUR STAFF AND
SAFEGUARD THE SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN IN FAMILIES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MOVING ON
WALL. OUR NEXT SPEAKER SON JOB
A GUY OF THE DIRECTOR KINGS
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES EIGHT
AGENCY. IS STILL FREE TO AND
MEET YOURSELF AND BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M ONE OF THE DAY. KINGS
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME OF
THE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC ON
OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. AND I
WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT
OURS IS THAT REALLY WHAT THIS
AND THEN IT HAS PROVEN THAT OUR
SYSTEM AND OUR KIDS AND OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE. NON FRAGILE
AND RHETORICAL AND THERE'S MANY
MANY THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING
REALLY WELL. BUT I WANT TO
FOCUS MY MONEY AND MY FEW
MINUTES ON THREE AREAS WHERE I
DO THINK WE GENUINELY NEED
RECORD AND ARE THE AREAS WHERE
I YES- I'M- HAVING. SOME
CHALLENGES IN THE MONTHS TO
COME. HOPEFULLY NOT YEARS AGO.
TO THE FOR ONE OF THOSE IS THE
SUPPORT FOR. RESOURCE FAMILY.
WE ARE A- MEDIUM SIZED BUT ON
SMALLER OF THAT. SPECTRUM WE-
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE KIDS- IN. THEN AND THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO KIDS WHO ARE
IN PLACEMENT. AND OF THOSE 61%
OF OUR KIDS ARE IN REPORTS
FAMILY. AND WHILE OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS KINGS COUNTY HAS
WORKED REALLY HARD TO- GROW THE
NUMBER OF RECOURSE FAMILY.
SIMPLY BECAUSE IN OUR COUNTY WE
HAVE NO OTHER OPTION. THERE IS
NO FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY THERE
IN A GROUP HOME AND- EVEN IF WE
GET. RESERVE FAMILIES ARE A
MUCH BETTER PLACE THAN OPTION
THE REASON CREDIT MORE. AND
MORE CRITICAL NOW ASSEMBLY THAT
KIDS OUT OF THE- OUT OF THE
COUNTY OUT. OF THE STATE- HAVE.
HIGHER TELL AND- WITH THEIR
COMMUTE AND WITH FAMILIES. BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH A READERS
HOW MORE THAN HALF AWAY ARE
RELATIVE. IS THE- FOR THEIR ON
ONE CUSTOMER TIME TO BE GROWN
MAN TO GET ACROSS THE EVEN
OUTSIDE THE- CHALLENGING IT IS
NOW EVEN MORE SO WITH ALL OF
THAT PROCESS IS MOVING ONLINE
AND THE TO THE CAPACITY TO- TO
UNDERSTAND AND FOLLOW THAT.
REQUIRES AN ADDITIONAL ONE ON
ONE ATTENTION. AREA ABOUT 19%
DROP. IN APPLICATIONS AND YET
OUR SOCIAL WORKER TIME HER.
FAMILY TO GET THEM THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND ACTUALLY INCREASE
AND WE'RE STARTING TO BE A SLOW
BUILD A- BACK ON BECAUSE IT
JUST. IN THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
THINGS HAVE JUST GONE DOWN. THE
OTHER PIECE WHICH IS NEW-
INDEPENDENT IS THAT- OUR
EXISTING RESEARCH FAMILIES THAT
ARE NOT GOING TO WERE YOU
ACROSS THAT. NEED ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. RELATED TO. COULD AND
UNDERSTOOD THE OF THE HAVE
CHANGED- ONLINE COLIN HANLEY
PEOPLE NEEDING TO WORRIES ABOUT
EXPOSURE REQUIRES THAT ONE ON
ONE INTERVENTION AND IT REALLY
IS ONE THING THAT MAKES THE
MOST VETERANS. TO ARI ASSEMBLY
WHEN IT COMES TO THINGS A
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT. OUR KIDS
AND BELIEVING THAT THEY CAN
MANAGE. THROUGH THE INTERNET.
WE HAVE THAT WE HAVE OVER THE
PAST FEW WE AND THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY OUR OUR THEY ALLOCATE.
AND I THINK IN THAT TREND IS
ONLY GOING TO GROW- COULD NOT
FIGURING OUT HOW TO GROW THE
SUPPORT AND GROW THE SOCIAL
WORKER TIME PEOPLE ARE READY
FOR FAMILY IS REALLY ONE OF MY-
AND THE OTHER ONE IS B. R.
AUTHOR KAREN RESOURCE FUNDING
THAT. WE REALLY HAVE YOU IS AS
A ANYTHING FOR THE FAMILY
NEEDS- IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL I DO THINK THAT IS
THE KIND OF APPROACH WE NEED. I
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT EVERY FIRST
PARENT- NINE. THE SECOND AREA
WHERE WE'RE SEEING A NEED FOR
SOCIAL WORKER TIME WHICH BECOME
A- PATTERN OF THE NEEDS. IS IN
OUR EMERGENCY RESPONSE. THAT
WE'RE THE COUNTY THAT DID NOT
EXPERIENCE A 40% DROP AND
REFERRAL BUT WE DID EXPERIENCE.
SIX MONTH IN THE CURRENT YEAR
ON THE LOOK AT PAST SIX MONTHS
COMPARED TO THE SAME TIME LAST
YEAR. BUT PERCENT DROP IN
REFERRAL. HOWEVER WHEN I LOOK
AT THE- OUR ITALIAN WAIT OUT
VERSES ARE IMMEDIATE REFERRAL
TO DOCTOR DROP IS VERY
DIFFERENT WE ACTUALLY ARE
GETTING MORE CALLS- MEDIA CALL
CAROLINE PORCELAIN. AND THAT
SOCIAL WORKER TIME
INVESTIGATING AND THEN PERSONAL
WORK OR TIME IN CONNECTING
FAMILIES TO RESOURCES. IT IS A
LOT MORE- INTENT. BECAUSE THAT
SHOULD. AVAILABILITY WHERE OF
RESOURCES SUCH AS- ALL RIGHT
ALL OF THE RESOURCES ARE NOW
ONLINE FIGURING OUT HOW TO
ACCESS THE FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS ARE CLOSED OR THEIR
ONLINE THAT THAT SOCIAL WORKER
BEING INSIDE THE HOME AND
CONNECTING THE FAMILY IN A MORE
INTENSE THREE TO RESOURCES THAT
CHECKING IN ON THE FAMILY MORE
FREQUENTLY IS ACTUALLY EVEN OUR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAUSING A
YOU NEED MORE SOCIAL WORKER
TIME- CASE AND ONE THING THAT
REALLY ACROSS THE SYSTEM THAT
BAD IN. IN OF MY THIRD AREA OF
<c.cyan>OCUS IN OUR ONGOING CASELOAD</c>
PROBABLY ALL SIGNIFICANTLY IN
OUR ONGOING CASES WHEN WE LOOK
AT- AFFECTS NINE COMPARED TO
THE SAME TIME LAST YEAR I CASES
HAVE GROWN SLIGHTLY WHAT'S MORE
STRIKING THOUGH IS THAT OUR
FAMILY MILLION CASES AND
DROPPED 27% AND WE AND THAT HAS
BEEN OCCUPIED BY GROWTH IN
FAMILY REUNIFICATION CASES BY
18% AND THEN OUR IN OUR-
PERMANENTLY CASES THAT ARE
PENDING ADOPTION BY TWENTY
THREE PERCENT. BUT WHAT WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE IF THAT HAS AN
EFFECT. THEM ARE STAYING LONGER-
AND- THAT WE'RE GOING TO GROW
IN OUR AND AMOUNT OF TIME IT
ACTUALLY TAKE CRICKET WHERE THE
SERVICE SUCH AS HEALTH.
PARENTING CLASS ALL BEING ON
AND THERE'S JUST GENERALLY OF
THEM. BONTA TRANSFER L<c.cyan>G</c>
THAT SERVICES CAN BE LOOK LIKE
FAMILY NOT- ENGAGING AND
PROFESSIONAL WORKER TRULY WHICH
ONE IS THE CASE- ISRAEL TAKES
TIME FOLLOW UP IF AND HOLD A
PARENT TO THAT PROCESS AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW I CAN
HELP THEM MEET THESE CHALLENGES
BUT WE'RE ALREADY SEEING-
EXPANSION OF THE- BUT
UNIFICATION TIMELINE WHICH IS
GOING TO KEEP OUR CASES LONGER
IN EACH COMPONENT AND WILL
REQUIRE AND REALLY FOR THE
FAMILIES THAT. WE GO THROUGH
THAT FOR KIDS ACTUALLY- AND
FAMILIES COULD BE OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO NEED EACH ONE OF THESE.
CATEGORIES JUST OVERALL MORE.
MORE ONE ON TIME WITH GAME AND
IS TRULY WHAT HAS MADE
DIFFERENCE BOKAR- PLANNING FOR
THAT I IN A- TO CON IS TO BE
CRITICAL. AND IN THE FINAL
PIECE WHERE OUR SOCIAL WORKER
TIME CRITICAL NATIONAL IN A
SMALLER COUNTY. AS AS WE'VE
BROUGHT IN ALL THEM IN PERSON-
KEEP RECORD OF THAT AND
VISITATION AND AUGMENTED THEM I
FELT WITH THE ONLINE- AND ARE
TOLD THAT. IT IS JUST TAKING
MORE. TIME FOR K. IT- I WOULD
DEVOTE KIND OF. CHALLENGED THAT
WHEN HAVE GET BECAUSE THE
INCOME CONTACT THAT COULD
EXPOSURE IS A FACTOR AND THAT.
IMPACTING HOW ARE SOCIAL
WORKERS MANAGING THE REST OF
THEIR WORKLOAD FIGURING OUT HOW
TO NOT TAKE IT OUT OF THE PART
OF THE EQUATION THAT WE ARE
GOING TO QUARANTINE FAST. AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF OUR WORK- IS REALLY IN
FACTORING HOW WE NEED TO PASS-
IN THE FUTURE. I DO THINK ALL
OF THE CHALLENGE ARE MANAGEABLE
AND WE CERTAINLY HAVE DONE A
LOT TO HAVE IT IN A JAR DURING
THE PAST SIX MONTHS. I DO THINK
ASKING CONTINUE- IN THE COMING
YEAR AND AS NUMBERS ARE GROWING
THAT THE CHALLENGES ARE GOING
TO. BE A BIGGER STRUCTURES ON
OUR SYSTEM THE FIGURING OUT HOW
TO SUPPORT THAT AND- BUT
AUGMENTING. I APPRECIATE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SANDRA UP NEXT
WE HAVE A DAVID GREEN SOCIAL
WORKER THREE WILL D'ANGELO'S
COUNTY ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAVID GREEN AND I'VE
SERVED TWENTY YEARS AS A
CHILDREN'S SOCIAL WORKER WITH
LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
I'M ALSO THE ELECTED TREASURER
MY UNION SEIU LOCAL SEVENTY ONE
WHICH REPRESENTS NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS IN SUNNY CALIFORNIA I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE SK YOU
STATE COUNCIL. NINE MONTHS INTO
THAT COULD BE NINETEEN CAN
ENDEMIC I WISH I COULD SAY
WE'VE TURNED THE CORNER. ON
THIS TRAGEDY BUT THE NUMBERS
TELL A VERY DIFFERENT STORY.
SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS
LOCKDOWNS SCHOOL IN CORK
CLOSURES MASS UNEMPLOYMENT.
I'VE BEEN PUTTING IN CONTINUE
TO PUT CHILDREN AT INCREASED
RISK OF ABUSE NEGLECT. PANDEMIC
IS EXPOSED TO THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM IN THE JUVENILE COURTS.
HERE TO DEAL WITH THE DISASTER
OF THIS MAGNITUDE. INTERNUS
PRESSURE ON CHILDREN SOCIAL
WORKERS IN THE FAMILIES WE
SERVE I'LL GIVE YOU SOME
EXAMPLES. THE LOSS OF MANDATED
REPORTERS BUT SCHOOLS GOING
REMOTE AND AFTER SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES SUSPENDED CHURCHES
HOLDEN SERVICES ORIGINAL NON
EMERGENCY MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS
DELAYED AND FAMILY GATHERINGS
SOCIAL DISTANCE CHILDREN SOCIAL
WORKERS LOST THEIR BEST ALLIES
IN PREVENTING ABUSE.
TRADITIONALLY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT
HOTLINE RECEIVES ABOUT ELEVEN
THOUSAND CALLS PER MONTH WHEN
THE STATE SHUT DOWN IN MARCH
THERE ON MARCH THIRTEENTH THAT
NUMBER DROPPED BY 50% THAT IS A
NO WAY INDICATIVE OF THE NUMBER
OF INCIDENTS OF CHILD ABUSE
NEGLECT. REDUCED BY THAT AMOUNT
INSTEAD IT ONLY HAD TO DO WITH
MANDATE REPORTERS NO LONGER
HAVING THEIR EYES ON THESE
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. ON MARCH
THIRTEENTH WE LOST THE TEACHERS
DOCTORS CLERGY COMMUNITY
LEADERS ANOTHER MANDATE
REPORTERS WHO TRADITIONALLY
FLAG ABUSE. THE FAILURE TO
TREAT SOCIAL WORKERS AS FIRST
RESPONDERS ESSENTIAL WORKERS
WEATHER IS OBTAINING PP OR BE
ON A LIST FOR A POTENTIAL
FUTURE VACCINATION. SOCIAL
WORKERS BY THE FRONT LINE
KEEPING CHILDREN SAFE. STORE
DIRECTOR BY THE CABLE AND THEL. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ADVOCATE FOR LIFESAVING PP. THE
PRESSURE TO RESUME COLD IS IT'S
UNDER UNSAFE CONDITIONS. THE
FIRST THING SOCIAL WORKERS WANT
TO DO IS PROTECT KIDS FROM
ABUSE. THAT MEANS OPPOSITES BUT
THE LAST THING SOCIAL WORKERS
WANT TO DO IS PUT FAMILIES AT
RISK BY THEIR OWN ACTIONS.
THEIR SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES
IN THE UNITED STATES THE
REQUIRED SOCIAL WORKERS TO
RESUME HOME VISITS WITHOUT
PROPERTY P. WITHOUT PROPER
SCREENING TESTING PER CONTRACT
TRACING. OF CLIENTS OR STAFF.
MAY PROGRESS STILL HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO TO PROTECT OUR
WORKERS IN THE FAMILIES WE
SERVE INCLUDING. MAKING SURE
WORKPLACES AND OTHER FACILITIES
ARE CONFIGURED TO ALLOW PROPER
SOCIAL DISTANCING. ENSURE THAT
OUR CLIENTS IN THE FAMILIES WE
WORK WITH WEAR MASKS. BUT
THERE'S TRANSPARENCY
NOTIFICATION WHEN SOMEONE IN A
FACILITY TEST POSITIVE FOR
GROUP IN NINETEEN. YEAH SOCIAL%
WORKERS NEED EMPLOYERS TO
PROTECT THEM FROM KOBE AND HELP
THEM PROTECT THEIR CLIENTS FROM
CONTRACTING OR SPREADING COBIT.
THE COURTS IN TECHNOLOGY THE
PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED HOW
UNDERFUNDED AND TECHNOLOGICALLY
BACKWARDS THE JUVENILE COURTS
ARE COMPARED WITH CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL. CRIMINAL AND CIVIL
COUNTERPARTS. TONY KEPT
REMOVING CHILDREN FROM
HOUSEHOLDS WITH A DECENT LACK
WAS ALLEGED AFTER THE PANDEMIC
WAS DECLARED BUT THE PRESIDING
JUDGE CLOSE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
JUVENILE DEPENDENCY COURTS OR
MID MARCH THROUGH THE SUMMER.
DISCLOSURE STRANDED THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND CHILDREN IN L.
A. COUNTY CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
AND PUT THEM IN LEGAL LIMBO. TO
ATTENDED PARENTING CLASSES OR
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED
ADDICTION TREATMENT I HAD NO
WAY TO GET THEIR CHILDREN BACK.
GRANDPARENTS AND RELATIVES
WILLING TO CARE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN TAKEN FROM THE BIRTH
PARENTS IN PLACE TO GROUP FOR
GROUP HOMES AND FOSTER HOMES.
NO WAY TO BRING THE CHILDREN
BACK TO FAMILY HOMES. THIS
EPISODE PROMPTED CS W'S AND
OTHER CHILDREN ADVOCATES TO
IDENTIFY LOW AND NO COST WAYS
TO BREAK THE LOGJAM. KEEP
CHILDREN HELP CHILDREN GET
STATE SUPPORT OF HOMES. WE MUST
EXPLORE GREATER ELECTRONIC
FILING AND SERVING OF MOTIONS
WITNESS LISTS. COURT REPORTS
AND OTHER FILINGS WE MUST
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE YOUR
CONFERENCING MEETINGS TO
DEVELOP CONSENSUS ON STIPULATED
ORDERS FOR PRESENTATION TO
JUDGES OVER WEBEX. WHAT DO WE
NEED TO DO TO MOVE FORWARD AS A
MENTION OF THE OPS AT THE
OUTSET WHEN SCHOOLS FULLY
REOPENED WE ANTICIPATE A
DRAMATIC UPTICK IN THE NUMBER
OF CALLS. WE START WILL START
ONCE AGAIN RECEIVING FOR
MERCHANTS TO RESPONSE HOTLINE
STATEWIDE. WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED THAT THE NATURE OF
THE SEVERITY THESE CALLS WILL
BE MUCH MORE INTENSIVE. REQUIRE
MUCH MORE ENGAGEMENT AND AS A
RESULT OF NOT HAVING EYES ON
EACH OF LEARN FOR NEARLY A YEAR
MORE. BECAUSE OF THIS IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT THE STATE
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
COUNTIES- FRONTLINE SOCIAL
WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO THESE CALLS- AS YOU SEEN AND
OTHER CHILD WELFARE RENO'S.
COACH IS THE BEST MODEL TO
ENSURE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
ARE GETTING WHAT THEY NEED FOR
DETENTION. THAT MEANS NOT ONLY
FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL CHILD
WELFARE SOCIAL WORKERS BUT
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS HE ROLE IN
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS TO WORK
IN TEAMS WITH THESE KIDS. AND
THEIR FAMILIES. WE GET THESE
CALLS. OVER AGENCIES AND SOCIAL
WORKERS NEED TO BE TRAINED TO
HELP CLIENTS STOP THE SPREAD OF
THIS DEADLY DISEASE. AND
AGENCIES MUST INVEST IN TESTING
CLIENTS BEEN PERFORMING
CONTRACTOR USING WHEN THEY
LEARN AQUINAS BEEN INFECTED.
THERE'S A MAJOR NEED TO TRAIN
MANDATED REPORTERS AND THE
PUBLIC TO LOOK FOR ABUSE OUR
CURRENT SOCIAL DISTANCE VIDEO
CONFERENCE WORLD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER GREENE- AT THIS
MOMENT WE WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS- YOU
DON'T KNOW IT EARLIER THERE WAS
MENTION ABOUT- SUPPORT
SERVICES. AND THE NEED FOR OUR
SOCIAL CONNECTIONS AND
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES STROP
THAN EDUCATION- FOR MR ROSE-
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO KNOW WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES IN
TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT FOR FOSTER
YOUTH IN. THE WE COULD DO YOU
KNOW A BETTER JOB AND MAKING
SURE THAT. YOU KNOW THEY THEY
FIND A PATH TO SUCCESS. YES
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
YEAH I WOULD NOTE THAT. IT'S IT
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC CLEARLY
THERE WAS A CHALLENGE RELATED
TO- WORKING FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
GENERAL BUT ESPECIALLY OUR
FOSTER YOUTH. AND SO GIVEN THAT
A LOT. OF THAT PREPARATORY WORK
HAPPENS THROUGH THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING PROGRAMS AND SOME OTHERS
THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY BAD AND-
KIND OF CLASSROOM BASED I DO
THINK WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO.
OUR PARTNER AND WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO. OF ALL THAT FORMAT AND
I DO THINK THERE'S A
POTENTIALLY IN NEED TO DO SOME.
PARTNERING WITH WITH- WITH
LOCAL BUSINESSES AND OTHERS TO
MAKE SOME OF THESE
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE I THINK
IN THE SHORT TERM. IT ALSO
PREPARING YOUNG PEOPLE FOR-
FOR. THE WORKING WORLD IN
WHATEVER WAY WE CAN GIVEN THAT
THE LIMITATIONS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ARE ARE
IMPORTANT IN OUR PRIMARY A WAY
TO DO THAT WITH OUR COUNTY
COLLEAGUES IS THROUGH- THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING PROGRAM AND
SOME. AND SOME OF THE WORK
WE'VE BEEN DOING WITH-
REFERRALS. AND RESOURCES FOR
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. THANK YOU
AT CALLING DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL. AS
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH- ACTUALLY- SINCE MR ROSA
DR ROSENSTEIN WE HAVE YOU TO
ACT SO WE JUST HEARD TESTIMONY
FROM- MISTER GREEN ABOUT- THE
NEED FOR PP IN THE ROLE OF
SOCIAL WORKERS AND AS ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND SO FORTH AND I AND
I KNOW THAT SOME OF THIS
HAPPENS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
AND- BUT TO IN YOUR ROLE IS-
DEPUTY DIRECTOR DSF IT DOES
HARM SOCIAL SERVICES WHAT WHAT
KIND OF- CONVERSATIONS ARE YOU
HAVING WITH OTHER AGENCIES LIKE
THE CDPH AND SO FORTH ABOUT.
THE ROLE OF- SOCIAL WORKERS WHO
ARE DID YOU KNOW WHAT WORKING
WITH FOSTER YOUTH IN TERMS OF
WHAT KIND OF RESOURCES WE NEED
FOR THEM AND ALSO BE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE KIND OF EQUIPMENT
THEY NEED A COMMENT OF COURSE
PRIOR TO COVET THEY DIDN'T NEED
TO HAVE- SO WORDY FALL ON THAT
PRIORITY LIST AND SO FORTH AS
WE ARE TRYING TO GET MORE P. E.
OUT EVENTUALLY HOPEFULLY A
VACCINE BUT THAT'S STILL GOING
TO BE AWHILE EVEN DESPITE ALL
THE EXCITING NEWS WE'RE HEARING
AND- AND FRANKLY YOU KNOW WE'RE
RIGHT NOW I THINK THE GOVERNOR
JUST ANNOUNCED A FEW HOURS AGO
WERE YOU OVER TO ME CASES ARE
SKYROCKETING BEGINNING
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE IT'S GONE.
IN ORDER KEEP PEOPLE SAFE WE DO
HAVE TO LIMIT CONTACT I CAN SO
CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHAT- DSS IS
DOING TO HELP THE SYSTEM- THE
SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE FOSTER
CARE FAMILIES IN TERMS OF BEING
SURE THAT WE CAN KEEP STRUCTURE
THAT THE SUPPORT. AND ALSO THE
OVERSIGHT GOING. SURE THING YOU
SENATOR. THREE TO THE QUESTION
AROUND CONVERSATIONS WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS- FROMTHE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC UP ALL THE WAY
THROUGH LAST WEEK WE'VE BEEN
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH. THE
FOLKS AT DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
TRYING TO CONTINUALLY OF ALL OF
OUR OUR GUIDE IS BASED ON THE
CURRENT SCIENCE AND THE CURRENT
UNDERSTANDING OF. OF THE WORK
SO THAT WE CAN- HE- CAN SAVE.
AND ABANDON THE WORKFORCE-
STATES YOU. WITH RESPECT.
NOTING WITH RESPECT TO THE. THE
PP. IN THE WAY THAT IT IT IS
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH THAT AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL THROUGH ITS OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE
EMERGING DEMAND SERVICES WE'VE
HAD ACROSS SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR COUNTY
COLLEAGUES. THROUGHOUT THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS THE LAST NINE
MONTHS OR SO. YES THEY WERE
HAVING. DIFFICULTY IN OBTAINING
A COPY THAT WE WOULD WORK
THROUGH THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO GET THE KIND OF
CARE THAT IS THE DATE THAT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. SIMILARLY WITH
OUR- COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
DIVISION WE HAVE ALL OF OUR
REGIONAL OFFICES HAVE A PP
AVAILABLE AND ARE AND CAN MAKE
IT AVAILABLE TO. FOSTER PARENTS
AND RESIDENTIAL PROVIDERS
DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES
IF THERE IS A SPECIFIC OUTBREAK
OR- OR AT A HIGH LEVEL OF NEED
OFTEN THAT DEPARTMENTS- EP
DISTRIBUTION IS IT IS BILLS
THAT GAP INTEL GLOBAL PUBLIC
HEALTH IS ABLE TO DO SO. BUT
NONETHELESS WE ARE MEETING WITH
OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES- TWICE A
WEEK. ON A WHOLE HOST OF THINGS
INCLUDING ON MAKING SURE THAT
OUR- OUR GUIDANCE AND OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF. OUR OUR
GUIDANCE IS UP TO DATE AND OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR NEEDS
AND- IS ALSO A CURRENT IN. FOR
IT FOREMOST IN OUR MINDS- A PRE
THAT- SOME SAID. A SOMETIMES
GET THINGS LOST BETWEEN THE- IN
US ARE BE OF HOUSE. AND WE HAVE
NURSING HOMES AND SO FORTH AND-
WE NEED TO BE SURE AS- THAT-
OUR OUR FIRST TO USE AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE ARE BOTH BEING
KEPT SAFE BUT ALSO- THAT WERE
IDENTIFYING CASES OF. ABUSE AND
NEGLECT AND AS I THINK WAS
MENTIONED- UNFORTUNATELY THE
MANY THE PLACE POINTS OF
CONTACT ARE NOW REDUCED BECAUSE
WE'RE MOVING TO REMOTE BUT- WE
STILL NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE THIS WORK TO PROTECT THE-
FOSTER KIDS CENTER. OUR
CHILDREN GENERAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR OUR PANEL YOUR
QUESTION FROM. SENATOR JOHNS
THAT THANK YOU SIR TOTAL IS A
HI MISTER GREEN STILL BILLS
HE'S ON THE CALL. IF I'VE GOT A
COUPLE OF- CLARIFYING QUESTIONS
FOR MR GREEN IF HE'S ABLE TO
COME BACK ON MISTER GREENE- ONE
I AND ALL OF THE PANELISTS
YEAR- TESTAMENT IS VERY
COMPELLING AND ENLIGHTENING AND
I APPRECIATE THAT. MISTER
GREENE I WAS PARTICULARLY TAKEN
ABACK BY SOME OF THE STATISTICS
THAT YOU SHARED I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T LOSE. THAT
NARRATIVE BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN AND HOW THE
GOVERNMENT BALANCES ITS
REACTION TO- COVED NINETEEN AND
THEN THE CONDITION OF OUR
CHILDREN AT HOME. YOU MENTIONED
THAT THE TYPICAL MONTH THERE'S
A LEVIN THOUSAND CALLS- OF
REPORTING CHILD ABUSE IN IS
THAT JUSTIN IN YOUR COUNTY OR
IS THAT STATEWIDE. BUT THAT'S
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WOW OKAY AND
THEN AND THEN YOU SAID THAT THE
NEXT MONTH THE FIRST MONTH OF
THE OF THE COVE IN LOCK DOWN
THAT THAT NUMBER DROPPED IN
HALF. WHAT WHAT IT WHAT IT
CONTINUE DID STAY AT HALFORD
TODAY CONTINUE TO. DECLINE OR
WHERE TO GO FROM THERE. SO IT'S
FLUCTUATE A LITTLE BIT BUT THE
FIRST MONTH WAS THE MOST
DRAMATIC DROP RIGHT AFTER HIM.
SHUTDOWNS BEGAN OKAY AND YOU
KNOW AS I SAID IN MY TESTIMONY
IT WASN'T BECAUSE THERE'S LESS
ABUSE AND NEGLECT EXPRESS
THERE'S LESS MANDATED REPORTERS
LAST HIGHS ON THE CHILDREN. TO
REPORT THIS TPE OF ABUSE
NEGLECT BY ANI GREW 2100% IN
HIM THE SAME THING FROM SENEGAL
COUNTIES WELL. BUT YOU DON'T
HAVE- SO DID IT ARE YOU SAYING
THAT IT DID LEVEL OFF AT ABOUT
HALF OR THE NUMBER OF REPORTS
CONTINUED TO DO. THE NUMBER OF-
CALLS CONTINUED DECLINE BECAUSE
THERE'S. LESS AND LESS CONTACT
WITH THESE CHILDREN. CORRECT
OKAY- THANK YOU AND THEN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I'D LIKE FOR
YOU TO KIND OF EXPAND ON. I
COULDYOU MENTION IT AND THEN-
I DIDN'T QUITE. CATCH
EVERYTHING THAT OU'RE SAM I'M
A SOUND LIKE IT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT. YOU WERE SAYING. M.
A PARAPHRASE WHAT YOU SAID SO
REPEAT BACK TO YOU KNOW CLARIFY
TO ME WITH YOU KNOW THE MORE OF
THE STORIES. THERE ARE CHILDREN
THAT ARE THERE ARE QUALIFIED TO
GO BACK INTO INTO THEIR
FAMILY'S HOMES EITHER. THEIR
GRANDPARENTS OR- AUNTS UNCLES
ARE EXTENT OTHER EXTENDED
FAMILY BIT. BECAUSE OF THE
LOCKDOWNS ARE ABLE TO GET BACK
INTO THOSE HOMES IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. S. SO IT. SADLY
THE COURTS TO JUVENILE COURTS
WERE CLOSED FOR MANY MANY
MONTHS MORE THAN SIX MONTHS
WHICH CREATED A LOGJAM IN THE
COURT SYSTEM SO CHILDREN THAT
MAYBE WE'RE READY TO GO ALL
WERE ABLE TO THE HOME SO
THEY'RE PART OF A BACKLOG IT'S-
JUST SAID IN MY COMMENTS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN THIS KIND
OF LEGAL LIMBO SO THE COURTS
THE COURTS SOCIAL WORKERS OUR
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IS STILL
CATCHING UP WITH THESE CASES-
JUST BECAUSE THERE'S GONNA BE A
BACKLOG FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE SO JUST BECAUSE- THE
PARENTS HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
THEY CAN. TO HAVE THE CHILDREN
BACK IN THEIR HOMES OR EVEN-
FINALIZE ADOPTIONS. THAT THEY
DIDN'T STEP IN THIS KIND OF
LEGAL LIMBO FOR MONTHS NOR
STILL DIGGING HERSELF OUT- BUT
ESSENTIALLY IT'S PUT PERMANENCY
FOR A LOT OF OUR CHILDREN IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM ON
HOLD. BUT WE'RE WORKING ON IT.
WORKING OUT WITH THIS BACKLOG
DID YOU SAY THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND. YES AND THAT'S JUST
L. A. COUNTY. LAKE COUNTY. HERE
WE EXTRAPOLATE FOR THE INTO
STATE L. A. COUNTY IS ABOUT A
THIRD OF THE POPULATION
CALIFORNIA'S SO. YOU KNOW. WHAT
OF THE ORIGINAL GUESS THAT
THERE'S A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
IN THE SAME SITUATION. IT'S A
GREAT QUIT YOU KNOW I DON'T THE
NUMBERS FOR THE WHOLE STATE BUT
I KNOW FOR L. A. COUNTY THAT
IT'S YOU KNOW WE'RE ONE OF THE
LARGEST HOT WATER SYSTEM RIGHT.
IN THE COUNTRY SO IT'S A LOT OF
TIMES INDICATIVE OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING EITHER WOW
MR GREEN THAT'S A VERY TOUCHING
THAT'S A PRETTY POWERFUL.
STATISTIC IT'S CARE IT'S
TERRIFYING FOR ME BECAUSE IT
GOES AGAINST EVERYTHING WE
BELIEVE IN A SOCIAL RIGHT. IS
GIVING FAMILY SERVICES
REUNIFIED WITH THEIR FAMILIES
SO- YOU KNOW AS I SAID IN
LESSONS CAN WE'RE REALLY LUCKY
TO HAVE A DIRECTOR LIKE BY THE
CABLE WITH A GREAT BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. BUT IT'S-
BUTTERFLY WHICH ARE BY THE FACT
THAT THIS HAS ON CHILDREN- AND
THEIR THEIR PERMANENT SHE- YOU
KNOW GROWING UP AND HELP THE
SUPPORT OF SAFE HOMES. ONE MORE
QUESTION I'M SURE I'M SURE
WOMAN AND MR GREEN IF YOU'VE
GOT THE ANSWER TO THIS SORT OF
OPINION THE OTHER PANELISTS
HAVE THE ANSWER TO THIS OTHER.
IS ANYBODY KEEPING STATISTICS.
STATE OF THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
UNFORTUNATELY THAT HAVE- AND
LOOK I'M I'M GONNA BE VERY
BLUNT HERE AND THAT AND I
APOLOGIZE THAT I HAVE TO BE
BUT- I'M COMPELLED BY YOUR
TESTIMONY. IS ANYBODY TRACKING
HOW MANY CHILDREN ARE
UNFORTUNATELY HE- PASSING AWAY
BECAUSE OF ABUSE OR- EXTENSIVE
HOSPITALIZATIONS OR- IF YOU
KNOW EXTENSIVE TRAUMA OR INJURY.
IS ANYBODY TRACKING THAT SINCE
THE LOCKDOWN STARTED. I'M NOT
SURE IF THAT'S A QUESTION
DIRECTLY FROM YOUR WHAT IF YOU
GOT THE ANSWER YES IF YOU HAVE
THE ANSWER I'D LOVE TO HEAR TO
INFORM THE OTHER PANELISTS HAVE
IT THAT'S FINE TOO YEAH SO I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE THAT
NUMBER IN FRONT OF ME IT'S
RIGHT THE QUESTION I WOULD
WANNA GIVE EITHER OR ON SET OF
NUMBERS I DON'T HAVE THAT I
COULD CERTAINLY GET THAT
INFORMATION. AND GET THAT BACK
TO YOU BECAUSE I THINK IT'S-
REALLY. IMPORTANT QUESTION.
MISTER GREENE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF OUR- DOING ANY OTHER.
PANELISTS HAPPEN TO KNOW. DANCE
THAT QUESTION. HER EVEN RAISING.
GESTURES. A CENTER THE- FULL
ANSWER I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
HELD BY C. B. S. S. WE DO
TRACK- ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS
ALL OF THE CHILD DEATHS. IN THE
COUNTY- ALONG WITH INJURIES OF
CHILDREN- AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT- THROUGH THE END OF.
OCTOBER BUT WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN
A SLIGHT DECREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF CHILD DEATHS. THE THING THAT
IS VERY APPARENT TO ME I GET ON
THE WAR ON EVERY CHILD UNDER
EIGHTEEN THAT DIES IN OUR
COUNTY REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
WE'VE HAD. CONTACT WITH THEM.
WHAT IS COMING OUT. VERY
CLEARLY TO ME IS. A PATTERN BOB.
MORE OVERDOSES. BY BYE. THAT WE
SEEN AND- WE WATCH THAT VERY
CLOSELY- WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE SUICIDE RATE.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE STILL ANALYZING VERY
CLOSELY BUT IT'S PRETTY CLEAR.
THAT WE'RE SEEING- THE-
OVERDOSE NASCO ARE. AS AN AS A
AND YOU DRIVE A COME-
CORRELATION TO THE LOCKDOWNS
WITH THE INCREASE.
MISINTERPRETS CABLE MR CAN YOU
PLEASE ON IT MR CABLE THANK YOU.
YES THANK YOU I'M SORRY I LOST
THE QUESTION THEIR CENTER IF
YOU ASK ME ONE MORE TIME PLEASE
SURE YOU DRAW A CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE INCREASE IN
SUICIDES AND OVERDOSES TO THE
LOCKDOWNS. I THINK IT WOULD BE
PREMATURE FOR ME TO SAY THAT I
CAN TELL YOU THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH OUR MENTAL HEALTH
COLLEAGUES AND SOME OF OUR
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN THE
COMMUNITY. BUT TO LOOK AT THAT
ISSUE- I DON'T THINK IT'S
ACCIDENTAL BUT I DON'T HAVE.
GOOD STATISTICAL DATA TO BACK
THAT UP AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
THAT VERY CLOSELY OKAY SO MAYBE
THERE'S AN AYE AYE A CAUSATION
CORRELATION BUT THERE. YOU I DO
BELIEVE YOU SAID THAT THE
INCREASE IN OVERDOSE AND
SUICIDE DID INCREASE. ABOUT THE
SAME TIME THE LOCKDOWNS STARTED.
OKAY THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO
SAY LOOK THIS IS. THIS IS SOME
GUTSY TESTIMONY FROM SOME
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THIS AND I JUST WANNA
TELL THEM ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT. MISTER GREENE I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO RECEIVE ANY
STATISTICS OR ANY OF THE OTHER-
POSTED A TESTIFIED I'D BE HAPPY
TO RECEIVE ANY ADDITIONAL TO-
STATISTICS ARE TESTIMONY MR
GREEN IN PARTICULAR I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN A AND A RECAP OF
YOUR TESTIMONY- SO THAT I CAN
HAVE IT- AND I THINK MAYBE ALL
THIS YOU KNOW MAYBE SHOULD
RECEIVE THAT TOO SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND MR VICE CHAIR WE
ALSO HAVE IF YOU CAN WE HAVE A
COMMENT OR AN ANSWER POSSIBLY
TO SOME OF THE QUESTIONS YOU
GOT FROM. FROM GREG ROSE SO IF
YOU CAN MEET- MR ROSE. IS
SEEKING. APART YOU KNOW PRIVATE
ANY AND ANY ANSWERS THAT HE MAY
HAVE TO THE QUESTIONS A TENER.
S. TODAY GREAT THANK YOU. YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR WE
HAVE WE ARE RESPONSIBLE- THAT
APART THE DEPARTMENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR COLLECTING- ALL
OF THEIR INFORMATION ON
FATALITIES AND NEAR FATALITIES
AS A RESULT OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT. AS R CABLES DESCRIBED
WE ARE NOT SEEING A SPECIFIC-
SPIKE IN AND FATALITIES AT THIS
AT THIS POINT BUTIT SHOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THE THAT THE
FATALITY AND IT REQUIRES EITHER
THE CHILD WELFARE AGENCY THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR THE CORNER
TO ACTUALLY MAKE A DEFINITIVE-
STATEMENT THAT THE THAT THE
FATALITY. AT AT- AFTER AS A
RESULT OF ABUSE OR NEGLECT WITH
RESPECT TO NEAR FATALITIES I
THINK THAT WAS YOUR OTHER
pFATALITIES AND OTHER THE
RELATIONSHIP INTENTIONALLY WITH
THAT PANDEMIC. AGAIN THAT DATA
WE ARE WE ARE ARE ARE. COMES
INTO OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES AND
WE ARE PROCESSING. DATA I DON'T
HAVE THAT IN FRONT OF ME TOO
AND IT WILL BE HAPPY TO TALK
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF ABOUT
THIS IN IT BOTH THE FATALITIES
AND NEAR FATALITIES IN GREATER
DETAIL WITH THAT INFORMATION IN
FRONT OF US. IN. FRONT OF US
ALL THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
AND WE ALSO IF YOU COULD PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR SANDRA WHO
ALSO WANT TO COMMENT ON THE ON
THE QUESTIONS. HELLO. I CAN
HEAR ME I CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU- THAT WAS THE IRATE
HAND FROM EARLIER BUT I DO WANT
TO SAY THAT OUR CHALLENGES ARE
DIFFERENT THOUGH NOT EVERY
COUNTIES- COURT CLOSURES WERE-
EITHER WAY LA THE WORK. SO IN
KINGS COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE WE DID
NOT HAVE ACOURT ORDER AT ALL.
AND THEREFORE HAVE HAD NO
BACKLOG WE'RE EXPERIENCING-
INCREASING CASES FROM THE
STANDPOINT THAT JUST BASED ON
SERVICES BEING AVAILABLE AND
BEING ASKED. ARE THERE MORE
LIMITED- SO THEREFORE WE HAVE
DELAYS IN REUNIFICATION AND
WHERE EVEN ON THAT AND WITH NO
ACTUAL COURT IMPACT WE'RE
SEEING CASES REMAINING IN THE
I'M LONGER. AND I DO THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE ANY IMPACT
STATEWIDE THAT. THAT WILL
REALLY BE A SEPARATE ISSUE
COMPARE TO COUNTY WHO HAVE HAD
A CORD CLOSURE. IT AND
THEREFORE NOT HAVE ALL DATA
GALA TO CATCH UP ON THE BACK ON.
YOU KNOW WHEN BRIEFLY. ON THE
REFERRAL CALL AND HOTLINE CALLS
TO OUR COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE THE
NOT EXPERIENCE A 50% DROP. IN
THE 21% DROP. BUT THAT IS- WHEN
WE CAN COMPARE MONTH TO MONTH-
YEAR TO YEAR BECAUSE DURING
SUMMER MOST COUNTIES EXPERIENCE
THAT DECLINING CALL ANYWAY.
THAT THOSE CALLS HAVE THAT DOES
DROP OFF AND LEVELED OFF AND AS
A MATTER OF FACT IN SEPTEMBER
AND OCTOBER WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN
NOW AN INCREASED NUMBER OF
CALLS OVERALL. AND THEN MORE
TECHNICALLY COMPLETED WE'RE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN IMMEDIATE
CALL WHICH THEN MR GREEN POINT
BEING THE NEED FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS AN IMMEDIATE INTENSIVE
MORE EXPERIENCE LOCAL WORKERS
THAT INVESTIGATION R. AGAIN.
SOMETIME EVEN WHEN THEY ARE A
DROP OFF CALLED IF THE CALL
BETTER. THAT ARE HIGH OR LOWER
OFF NEED MONEY BUT DOES WE
DON'T HAVE- BEING. TO INVEST
THE ARE THE ONES ARE OFF MORE
THE WORKLOAD AND IMPACT OUR
KIDS REALLY. MUCH YOU GET INTO.
THE WEEDS OF ALL OF- NEEDLESS
TO SAY I WANNA SUPPORT AN ECHO
THAT OUR LEVEL OF SOCIAL
WORKERS SPECIALLY OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. AND INVESTIGATION IS
GOING TO. IN YA COME MONTHS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTION FROM
SENATOR PAN PLEAS FOR NO THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
ALL THE PRESENTERS- AND- ONE
THING I JUST WANT TO MAKE NOTE
CERTAINLY I APPRECIATE ALL THE
TESTIMONY THAT- COVETS BEEN
MAKE IT VERY DIFFICULT AND OF
COURSE- THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES
TO THAT- RIGHT NOW WE'VE HAD
OVER A MILLION CASES OF COATED
IN DE UM. IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT FACT- AND WAY TOO MANY-
DEATHS AS WELL AS WELL- FACT- I
THINK RIGHT NOW WE'RE AT
EIGHTEEN NUMBER EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE THAT'S A CO THAT
DIRECTLY IMPACT RESEARCH ON
ACCESS STATS SHOW THAT IT'S
EVEN PROBABLY EVEN LARGER THAN
THAT SO WE'RE PRETTY
UNDERCOUNTING THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS DIRECTLY RELATED
COLLUDED- BUT PERHAPS THIS IS A
JUST A BRIEF QUESTION FOR
MISTER- ROSE- WITH DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES- AND- YOU KNOW
WE'RE STRUGGLING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO- IN OUR BUDGET
PROCESS TO TRY TO PROVIDE. THE
FUNDING FOR THE P. E. AND
ACTUALLY THE OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS WE NEED TO DO WE TALK
ABOUT COURTS BEING CLOSED- AS
WELL- THE CAN YOU. SPEAK TO.
AVAIL OF BILL OF FEDERAL
FUNDING. TO HELP SUPPORT OUR-
SOCIAL SERVICE SYSTEM
PARTICULAR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM-
THAT- THAT SORT FOR THE STATE-
GIVEN THE OLD. LEASE WE HAD THE
CARES ACT BUT HE LACK OF
ACTIONS SUBSEQUENT TO THAT- BY
IN DC. S. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
I THINK. AND AS YOU NOTED THERE
THAT DAY CARES ACT WAS WAS- A
MODEST I SHOULD NOTE THAT THE
WHAT THE PART IS THAT THE
ELEMENT THAT STILL. THE FACT IS
THAT THAT THERE IS AN INCREASED
FEDERAL STATE SHARING RATIO THE
SO CALLED ASK MAP THAT THAT-
ALLOWS US TO CLAIM SLIGHTLY
MORE FEDERAL FORTY DOLLARS FOR
A AND B. WHAT ABOUT OTHERWISE
BEEN ABLE TO DO SHORT OF THAT.
THERE REALLY HASN'T BEEN AN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL RESOURCES
THEY PROVIDE SOME FLEXIBILITY
IN THE WAY WE WOULD GO ABOUT
THINGS AND SOME AND SOME OF US
FROM ALONE ALLOWANCE FOR- SOME
OF OUR TRADITIONAL BUSINESS SHE-
ROUTINES TO- TO. BE DELAYED
LITTLE BIT WHAT WHEN IT COMES
TO SOME OF OUR OUR PLANS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT BUT LARGELY.
WE HAVE NOT BEEN THE RECIPIENT
OF THE SYSTEM IS NOT IN THE
RECIPIENT THAT- AGREE DEAL OF
FEDERAL FUNDS- FOR THIS PURPOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
TESTIMONY IN THAT CERTAINLY I
HOPE ARE YOU CAN CALL ON OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS- PARTICULARLY-
I KNOW THAT THE- CURRENTLY THE
U. S. SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
HAS. NOT WANTED TO GIVE MORE
FUNDING TO LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS- I HOPE HE WILL
CHANGE HIS MIND- AND PERHAPS
PRIORITIZE GETTING FUNDING OUT
TO THE PEOPLE AT THIS POINT IN
TIME- EVEN THIS LAME DUCK
SESSION OF THE CONGRESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN- WE
ALSO HAVE ONE QUESTION THAT
QUESTION AND A COMMENT FROM A
SENATOR WIENER WHO IS ON OUR
CALL. ANY PLEASE A NEAT CENTER
WINNER. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR BEING
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING FIVE
TODAY I DO WANT TO START NO-
SOMEONE DRIVE FOCUS A LOT ON
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION- WE
CERTAINLY- DAMAGE CAUSED BY.
THE REQUIREMENT THAT WE-
SHELTER EMPLOYEES SECOND
AUTOMATIC TELLS SENATE ROTH-
BUT I ALSO AND I THINK. DR
PANEL- THIS WE NEED TO ALL
FOCUS ON. PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING
FROM CARBON NINETEEN I'M FIVE
HUNDRED BLOCK STATE KNEES-
MEASURES THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ELSE- DIED HAVE BEEN SOME
RADICALLY HIGHER IN OUR
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS ARE WOULD BE
YOUR WILD AND SO ON AND SO
FORTH SO WE ARE FACING A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC YOU'RE A LOSE LOSE.
OUT TO TRY TO STRIKE THE RIGHT
BALANCE ABOUT SORT WORKS
CONTINUALLY TRYING TO DO AND- I
KNOW THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. IS
NO EXCEPTION THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
YOUR- I AM VERY SPECIFIC. OF
LGBT. YEARS AUSTER SYSTEM. WE
KNOW WINDOWS ARE A- YOUR TIME
ARTICLE I THINK LAST WEEK ABOUT
THE NEW YORK SYSTEM WHICH I
THINK IS VERY SIMILAR. IN THE
SENSE TO THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
ALLOWS YOU TO CHOOSE ARE OVER
OVER REPRESENTED. BY THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM BECAUSE WORKERS
PAYCHECKS OUT OF HOMER RUNNING
AWAY OR- ANY OTHER NUMBER OF.
REASONS OR- LCDS ALSO BE TO
CHOOSE YOUR FOSTER YOU ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BECOME HOMELESS- ARE
MORE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE ALL
SORTS OF. CHALLENGES FOR
REASONS WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
TERMS OF OUR SOCIETAL AND
TRAGICALLY SOMETIMES. FACILITY
TO BE YOUNG PEOPLE AND SO WE-
REALLY NEED- LOOK OUT FOR THEM.
OPPOSITE FOR US YOUR NEED OUR
PHONE SINCE. BETTER HEALTH BE
TEACHER YOUR TASTE SPECIFIC.
CHALLENGES OF SOME DUE GET
ENOUGH. JOIN REMOTE LEARNING OR
THEIR OR WHATEVER YOU KNOW FOR
ALL THE REASONS THAT WE KNOW
ARE ALL MORE POSTS ALL MEMBERS
OF. OUR FOSTER IS THE QUESTION
THAT RAISES THE- YES THESE KIDS
WHO IF THEY ARE A- I'M SUPPORT-
HOME ENVIRONMENTS- BUT YOU
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THAT
TIME WHERE THEY'RE AWAY FROM
HOME. WITH THEIR TEACHERS WHO
MIGHT BE MORE SUPPORTER FOR
THEIR PEERS AND THEIR
CLASSMATES ARE JUST IN THE
WORLD AND ABLE TO INTERACT IN A
MORE SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT TO
BALANCE OUT ON THE HOSTILITY
THAT THEY MAY BE EXPERIENCED I
DON'T WANT TO CAST ASPERSIONS
SOMEBODY. FOSTER PARENTS AND
GENERAL EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL. AND THIS
STUFF INCREASE THE RISK OF
THESE ARE KIDS THEY'RE NOT
RECEIVE AS MUCH OF OUT OF HOME.
WORDS I GUESS I QUESTION AND IF
THE NEXT LISTENING YOU'RE
PREFERRED. WANT ONE COMES.
ADDRESS ALL ONE REJOICE. WHAT'S
OR ARE ALSO. FOSTER YOUTH. THE
SEARCH TIME. WHAT ANY OF THE
PANELISTS LIKE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION ON BOTH THE SENATE
WINNER. MR ROSE CAN YOU PLEASE
ON THE LINE. SURE THANK YOU
SENATOR- JUST BRIEFLY THE
DEPARTMENT HAS FOR SOME TIME
HAD FIRST LGBT ADVISORY GROUP
LATER- WE TRANSITIONED INTO
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND GENDER
IDENTITY EXPRESSION IN YOUR
GROUP AND SO WE AND WE RECENTLY
HOSTED. ELEVEN ARE THAT HAD
OVER FIVE HUNDRED ATTENDEES
WHERE WE TALKED ABOUT SOME OF
THE PARTICULAR- ISSUES RELATED
TO L. G. B. T. Q. YEAR IMPOSTER
CARE CLEARLY A ONE WEAPON ARE
DOES NOT MAKE A SERVICE SYSTEM
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY BY IT BUT
WE HAVE BEGUN TO. CHIU LOOK AT
THE SPECIFIC ISSUES RELATED TO
THIS POPULATION. WITH OUR NEWLY
FOUNDED OFFICE IN EQUITY WE
PLAN TO AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR COUNTY CALLING
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS AND OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO SEE HOW BASTRYKIN CONSERVE-
BUSINESS POPULATION I WOULD
ALSO JUST NOTE THAT. THAT THE-
FOSTER CARE BILL OF RIGHTS THAT
ARE- THAT HAVE WAS READ THAT
RECENTLY PASSED THERE WILL BE-
THERE'S A KIND OF A AN EVENT
TOMORROW KIND OF DONE BAILED
AND ALSO HAS A NUMBER OF
SPECIAL AND- A NUMBER OF.
CONDITIONS AND REQUIRE AND
REYES CAN CHANGE WITH AN AD
THAT FOCUSED ON APPROPRIATE-
TREATMENT SERVICES AND- FOR
LGBT. YOUNG PEOPLE AND SO. WE
HAD WE'VE HAD WE NEED TO MUCH
MORE THAN HALF. WE HAVE HAD A
NUMBER AND WE CONTINUED WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR AS I
MENTION OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES
AND OTHERS. THE SERVICE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY TO WORK
THROUGH THESE SPECIFIC ISSUES-
ANYWAY WE CAN'T. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ROSE. YOU KNOW I I'D
REALLY WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK OUR
PANELIST- FOR JOINING US TODAY
AND PROVIDING US WITH ALL THE
INFORMATION I MEAN I THINK WE
ALL LEARNED A LOT TODAY MORE
THAN THAN WHAT WE ALREADY KNEW
AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT OF
NEED AND- MUCH MORE. IN MANY
MORE WAYS THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO OUR FOSTER YOUTH-
YOU KNOW BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT TOP PANEL JUST. WANTED
TO. THROW AN IDEA OR THOUGHT
OUT- AND THAT BEING AT A YOU
KNOW LAST YEAR WORKED ON A BILL
THAT WOULD. SET SUICIDE
PREVENTION PLANS IT DIDN'T MAKE
ITS WAY THROUGH UNFORTUNATELY
BUT I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL. COULD
STILL BE. YOU KNOW CAN STILL BE
PUSH SO THAT. WE CAN REALLY
TAX. YOU KNOW BEGIN TO TACKLE
THE AT THE- THE RISE IN IN- YOU
KNOW OVERDOSES AS BEING PART OF
FOR. YOU KNOW SUICIDE
PREVENTION. AMONGST OUR YOUTH
BECAUSE YET CANDIDATES IT'S-
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT USE AND
THEIR YOU KNOW THEIR VOICES
NEED TO BE HEARD AND- AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR SPEAKING UP
TODAY. SO MOVING ON TO OUR
SECOND PANEL- WE'RE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT THE PANDEMIC'S
IMPACT ON OUR FOSTER YOUTH. AND
OUR FIRST SPEAKER IS LESLIE
START HIM- AND I APOLOGIZE IF I
MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CHILDREN'S
YOU AND BUYING. HI THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME- I'M LESLIE
HIGH MONTHLY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA
WE REPRESENT ALL OF THE
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE IN LOS
ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER.
SO OUR CURRENT CASELOAD IS
ABOUT THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
CHILDREN. BEFORE I. JUMP INTO
MY PREPARED COMMENTS I DID WANT
TO QUICKLY ADDRESS ONE COMMENT
THAT WAS MADE ON THE EARLIER
PANEL THEY GOT. A GOOD AMOUNT
OF ATTENTION AND WHILE I AGREE
WITH MR GREEN'S BOTTOM LINE
REGARDING THE IMPACT OF THE
DELAYS AND THE BACKLOG ON THE
FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE I DO
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT IN L. A.
COUNTY THE COURT DID NOT
COMPLETELY CLOSED. I WOULD HOPE
WE COMPLETELY CLOSED FOR TWO
DAYS. RATHER WE HAD ONLY A
VIRGIN SEE HEARINGS FOR. MOST
OF MARCH ALL OF APRIL ALL OF
MAY AND INTO JUNE TWENTY
SECOND. SO IS NOTA COMPLETE
CLOSURE COURT WAS IN SESSION
EVERY DAY IT WAS A REDUCED-
COURT CALENDAR BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE.
AND BECAUSE WE COULD NOT. THEY
ARE PRESIDING JUDGE DETERMINED
THAT WE COULD NOT SAFELY HAVE
IN PERSON HEARING SO THEY WERE
EIGHT COURT ROOMS THAT WERE
OUTSIDE WITH WEBEX IMMEDIATELY.
AND THOSE EIGHT COURTROOMS HELD
HEARINGS EVERY DAY- AND THAT IS
IN PART WHY WE SEE THE NUMBERS
THAT WERE TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS
OF MORE CASES OPENING THEN
CLOSING. AREN'T TYPICALLY IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED CASES A MONTH CLOSE AND
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED CASES A
MONTH OPEN. DURING MARCH APRIL
MAY AND JUNE ALMOST NO CASES
CLOSE. AND ABOUT THE SAME
NUMBER FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
OPENED- AS A RESULT AND AS
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD WE HAVE
FOUR THOUSAND MORE CHILDREN. IN
THE SYSTEM TODAY THAN WE DID-
WHEN THE PANDEMIC STARTED. AND
THE OTHER UNFORTUNATE IMPACT OF
THE CLOSURES WAS THIS VERY
SIGNIFICANT BACKLOG. AND THE
FACT THAT THE COURT MADE A
DECISION TO IMPOSE A SCHEDULE.
FOR HEARINGS THAT PUT MANY MANY%
HEARINGS ON THE WAY OUT INTO
JANUARY FEBRUARY AND MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- AND SO THAT
BACKLOG IS NOT GOING TO BE
COMPLETELY ELIMINATED- ANYTIME
SOON AND THE IMPACT ON FAMILIES
HAS BEEN PROFOUND. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT IF
THE CASE WAS SCHEDULED IN MARCH
FOR A REVIEW HEARING OR HEARING
WHERE PERHAPS A DECISION WAS
GOING TO BE MADE ABOUT
LIBERALIZING VISITATION OR
CHILD GOING HOME OR TERMINATING
REUNIFICATION BECAUSE THE
FAMILY HAD NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO
WHAT THEY NEEDED TO DO AND
MOVING INTO A PERMANENT PLAN.
IF THAT CASE WAS CONTINUED FROM
MARCH UNTIL. OCTOBER NOVEMBER
DECEMBER JANUARY THAT FAMILY
WAS THE LAST TIME THEY WERE IN
COURT WAS IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN SO WE DO HAVE THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THERE
THE COURT IS TRYING TO ADDRESS
THEM I'M NOT SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE COURT I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY- WHAT THE SITUATION HAS
BEEN. COBIZ CERTAINLY ALTERED
THE WAY THAT THE COURTS OPERATE
MAGNIFYING SOCIAL AND CLASS
BASED INEQUITIES AND SEVERELY
IMPACTING ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND
IMPEDING DUE PROCESS. WHILE
SOME HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
VIRTUAL HEARINGS IT'S MEANT
LESS TIME AWAY FROM WORK OR
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION TOP
CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN
ELIMINATED. IN SOME USED TO
MORE COMFORTABLE AND LESS
INTIMIDATED BY THE COURT
PROCESS WHEN THEY ARE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. MANY
OTHERS DO NOT HAVE RELIABLE
ACCESSTO THE INTERNET AND THE
NEEDED DEVICES IMPLICIT BIAS IS
MAGNIFIED AS THE PARTIES ACCESS
TO VIRTUAL HEARINGS IS OFTEN
DEPENDENT ON THE SOCIOECONOMIC
STATUS. LACK OF PARTICIPATION
MAY BE INTERPRETED AS LACK OF
INTEREST OR LACK OF COMMITMENT
TO REUNIFICATION. THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE EXTENDS BEYOND JUST
PHYSICAL ACCESS TO COMPUTERS
AND THE INTERNET. MEANINGFUL
ACCESS ALSO REQUIRES PRACTICAL
TECHNOLOGICAL KNOWLEDGE AND
FAMILIARITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
COURT VIRTUALLY. OUR ATTORNEYS
OFTEN HAVE TO SPEND A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME
HELPING A WITNESS LOG ON TO
TESTIFY. OR HELPING STRUGGLING
CAREGIVER OR CHILD UNDERSTAND
HOW TO CONNECT DOWNLOAD OR USE
WEBEX. IF IT TAKES TOO LONG THE
COURT MAY DECIDE THE WITNESS
SHE TESTIFIED BY TELEPHONE
WHICH RAISES OTHER ACCESS AND
YOU CRISIS ISSUES. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY HAPPENS QUITE
FREQUENTLY. ADDITIONALLY
OFTENTIMES PARTIES OR WITNESSES
MAY SAY THEY PREFERRED TO
TESTIFY BY TELEPHONE AGAIN
BECAUSE PERHAPS IT'S LESS
INTIMIDATING. BUT BUT THAT ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTS THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE EVIDENCE AND
THE ABILITY TO ASSESS THE
EVIDENCE. BURCHELL PROCEEDINGS
HAVE A PROFOUND IMPACT ON THE
QUALITY RELIABILITY AND
CREDIBILITY. OF EVIDENCE AND
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY. THE
INDICIA OF RELIABILITY THAT
COURTS RELY ON TO ASSESS
CREDIBILITY OR DRASTICALLY
IMPAIRED IMPERSONAL HEARINGS.
ARE PRACTICALLY ELIMINATED WHEN
PEOPLE TESTIFIED. TESTIFIED BY
PHONE. WITH REMOTE TEST IS AND
HOW TO IF THE- IN THE RUN WITH
ANOTHER PERSON WHO MAY BE. OR
EXERTING IN. OR WHETHER LACK OF
PRIVACY PREVENTS FULL
DISCLOSURE. AND MANAGING A TEAM
LIVING IN A GROUP HOME
TESTIFYING ABOUT SEXUAL ABUSE
BUT AFRAID WITH OTHER KIDS IN
THE GROUP HOME RIGHT OVER HERE
HIS TESTIMONY WHAT WOULD YOU BE
COMFORTABLE SHARING.
CONNECTIVITY IN SOUND QUALITY
VARIES IMPRISONS CHALLENGES TO
EVERYONE AS AUDIO MAY CUT OUT
THE MIDDLE OF AN ARGUMENT. WHEN
THE CONNECTION FAILS DURING THE
TRIAL WITNESS TESTIMONIES
DISRUPTED. DIFFICULT TO FOLLOW
AND PROBLEMATIC. YOUR TESTIMONY
OFTEN PRECLUDES NONVERBAL CUES
SUCH AS EYE CONTACT BODY
LANGUAGE THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO
DETERMINE CREDIBILITY DURABLE
KEEP CUES SUCH AS WITNESS TOWN
OR RESPONSIVENESS TO QUESTIONS
MAY ALSO BE JUST STARTED
WHENEVER IN VIRTUAL HEARINGS
AND IMPACTS CREDIBILITY. HE'S
ON THE PHONE HAVE A HARD TIME
FOLLOWING WHAT IS HAPPENING WE
DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT'S THE
JUDGE OR AN ATTORNEY TALKING.
CHILDREN ESPECIALLY ALREADY
FINE COURT HEARINGS TO BE
CONFUSING WHEN THEY'RE ON THE
PHONE OR VIRTUALLY IT IS IT IS
THAT MUCH MORE CONFUSING AND
HARD FOR THEM TO DISTINGUISH
FOR EXAMPLE THE SOCIAL WORKERS
SPACE FROM OTHER FACES ON THEIR
SCREENS. GIVEN THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT VIRTUAL HEARING SALUTE
WILL BE WITH US FOR QUITE SOME
TIME AND POSSIBLY IN SOME FORM
BEYOND THE END OF THE PANDEMIC.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
APPROPRIATE SPACES FOR VIRTUAL
TESTIMONY BE CREATED. PARTY
WITNESSES MUST BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY ALONGSIDE THEIR JOURNEY
FROM A SAFE PRIVATE LOCATION.
SOME ATTORNEYS ARE MAKING THEIR
OFFICES AVAILABLE FOR THIS
PURPOSE HOWEVER THIS IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE IT WAS AN
INAPPROPRIATE BURDEN ON THE
ATTORNEY. ESSENTIALLY TO BUILD
A VIRTUAL COURTHOUSE FOR THEIR
CLIENTS THAT SHOULD BE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. ATTORNEYS LIKE SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE UTILIZING
TECHNOLOGY TO CONDUCT VIRTUAL
VISITS AND VIRTUAL CLIENT
INTERVIEWS. HOWEVER WE'RE
FINDING. THAT ESPECIALLY OUR
YOUNG CHILDREN OR THOSE WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS HAVE A DIFFICULT
TIME ENGAGING OR STAYING
FOCUSED AGAIN THE LACK OF
PRIVACY IS A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN. ESPECIALLY CHALLENGING
AND OFTEN INAPPROPRIATE TO HAVE
SERIOUS IN DEPTH CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT ALLEGATIONS IN THE
PETITION OR THE SUBSTANCE OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON THE
TELEPHONE. AND FRANKLY I'M
SORRY IT'S ALSO IN IN IT'S ALSO
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TO BUILD
RAPPORT WITH CHILDREN WHO HAVE
BEEN LOST IN THE VIRTUAL WORLD.
FRANKLY LIKE MOST OF US YOU
THEY'RE ALSO TIRED OF TALKING
TO PEOPLE ON THE PHONE OR
VIRTUALLY AS THEY HAVE BEEN IN
SCHOOL WE'RE TALKING TO
THERAPISTS VIRTUALLY ARE ON
ZERO ALL DAY LONG. IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO REMEMBER
ALL OF THE ADULTS THAT ARE
TALKING TO THEM ON THE PHONE OR
VIDEO. CHILDREN'S ATTORNEYS AND
THIS LEGISLATURE HAVE WORKED
HARD TO ESTABLISH A STANDARD IN
CALIFORNIA THAT VALUE VALUES
THE IMPORTANCE OF CHILDREN
HAVING MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION
IN THE COURT HEARINGS ARE LIFE
CHANGING DECISIONS ARE MADE. IT
HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT STEP
BACKWARDS RECORDS TO MAKE SO
MANY DECISIONS WITHOUT THEIR
PRESENCE. BEST PRACTICES
REQUIRES SINCE EVER I NECESSARY
SENSE OF URGENCY. BY ALLOWING
CHILDREN TO LANGUISH WE'RE
UNINTENTIONALLY CAUSING HARM TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. I ALSO
WANT IN. RESPONSE TO A QUESTION
AND A COMMENT FROM DR CANCEL
THE EARLIER PANEL. WHERE HE
ASKED ABOUT ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND THEIR ACCESS TO BP AND THEN
THEIR FUTURE ACCESS TO
VACCINES. INTERESTINGLY IN
CALIFORNIA. ALTHOUGH ATTORNEYS
INDEPENDENCY COURTS ARE
CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL WORKERS
BASED ON THE GOVERNOR'S ORDER.
BECAUSE WE ARE FOR THE MOST
PART NOT GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES
WE DO NOT RECEIVE ANY OF THE
BENEFITS OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO OTHER SOCIAL
WORKERS. AND I WOULD ASK THAT
WE CONSIDER GOING FORWARD
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. ADDITIONAL ON. TV AND
DISTRIBUTION OF THE VACCINES
WHEN THEY OCCUR. JUST THE SAME
AS THE COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SOCIAL WORKERS WHO WORK FOR
THE ATTORNEYS ARE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY EVERY DAY. VISITING
CLIENTS EXPOSING THEMSELVES. TO
KOBE- WHEN WE HAVE DETERMINED
THAT. VIRTUAL CONVERSATION IS
NOT ADEQUATE TO ENSURE CLIENT
SAFETY WE ARE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY IN PEOPLE'S HOMES.
MEDIA FOLLOWING TO THE BEST OF
OUR ABILITY TO COPE WITH SAFETY
PROCEDURES. BUT STILL PUTTING
OURSELVES AT THE SAME LEVEL OF
RISK. AS A COUNTY SOCIAL WORKER
MIGHT. THE OTHER UP LAST THING
I WOULD LIKE TO COME ON.
REBATES TO THE IMPACT OF ALL
THESE SURVEYS AND THE IN OF A
OF IN PERSON CONTACT- WELL I
AGREE. WHOLEHEARTEDLY THAT WE
ALL HAVE TO DO OUR PART I'M IN
AS SENATOR LET ME PUT IT THAT
THIS IS A LOSE LOSE WE ARE
SEEING THAT IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN FOSTER CARE ARE
CARRYING MORE OF THE BURDEN OF
THAT LOSE LOSE. THAN THAN THOSE
OF US WHO ARE NOT IMPACTED BY
THE DEPENDENCY COURTS AND WHAT
I MEAN BY THAT IS I CAN MAKE
THE CHOICE TO SPEND TIME WITH
MY FAMILY I CAN DETERMINE AND-ASSESS THE ATTITUDE THAT THE
LEVEL OF RISK THAT I THINK YOU
SEE FOR APPROPRIATE FOR MY
FAMILY BASED ON OUR HEALTH
CONCERNS. I CAN MAKE A DECISION
TO GO OUT INTO MY NEIGHBORHOOD
PARK AND HAVE THE SOCIAL
DISTANCE. COUPLE CAUGHT. WITH A
FRIEND FOR MY YOU KNOW ACROSS.
THE PARK WHAT WHATEVER IT MIGHT
BE. BUT CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
IN FOSTER CARE DO NOT HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
THEMSELVES. AND THE LACK OF
PHYSICAL CONTACT. EVEN THOUGH
VIRTUAL CONTACT IS BETTER THAN
NOTHING IT DOES NOT REPLACE.
THE ESSENTIAL PHYSICAL CONTACT
ESPECIALLY FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
IN TERMS OF DEVELOPING
ATTACHMENT. TO THEIR PARENTS
WHO HOPE TO SOON BECOME THEIR
PRIMARY CARE GIVERS AGAIN. WE
ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED. ABOUT THE
LONG TERM IMPACT OF THAT. ON
SAFETY AND WELL BEING- AND
SIMPLY GIVING A FAMILY MORE
TIME TO RE UNIFY WILL NOT UNDO
THE DAMAGE THAT IS DONE. WHEN A
NEW MOTHER AND HER INFANT CHILD
CANNOT PHYSICALLY SPEND TIME
TOGETHER- AND CANNOT HAVE
REGULAR. ONGOING C. CITIES
CONTACT AND SO. WE ARE- I THINK
THAT THAT IS AN IMPORTANT AREA
THAT WE CAN'T SIMPLY JUST SAY
WAIT TILL THE PANDEMIC IS OVER
IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE.
CONSIDERED WITH PERHAPS A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT LANDS AND
WHETHER OR NOT SHE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO GATHER FOR HOLIDAY. OR
GATHER FOR A BUSINESS MEETING
BUT INSTEAD GATHERING TOGETHER.
TO SUSTAIN THE PARENT CHILD
BOND AND ATTACHMENT EXPECTED.
OTHER PANELISTS ON THIS ON THIS
GROUP WILL SPEAK TO SOME OF
THAT. IN MORE DETAIL SO I WILL
LEAVE. IT TO THEM AT THIS POINT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ARE WE WILL BE MOVING ON TO OUR
NEXT SPEAKER AND I JUST WANNA-
AT. ONCE AGAIN A PUT OUT THAT
WE- WANT TO TRY TO LIMIT AS
MUCH AS WE CAN TO THAT TIME
FRAME THAT WE SET IN PLACE AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE MEETING. I
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE.
ALLOWING TIME FOR EVERYONE.
EVERY SPEAKER OF EACH PANEL TO.
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. US WITH
INFORMATION. SO MOVING ON WE
HAVE JENNIFER RODRIGUEZ JD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
YOUTH LAWCENTER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- I WANNA START MADAM CHAIR
BY SAYING HOW GRATEFUL I AM
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO MAKE. A
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF EACH INDIVIDUAL YOU
THINK CARE AND PARTICULARLY TO
THOSE THAT ARE STRUGGLING THE
MOST- AS YOU SO BEAUTIFULLY
SAID THESE ARE HUGELY
CHALLENGING TIMES FOR US ALL.
SO MUCH MORE SO FOR THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE RELYING ON THE
GOVERNMENT TO PROTECT AND
PRIORITIZE THEIR NEEDS AND ALL
OF THIS FOR A AND DISTRESS- I'M
A LAWYER AND AN ADVOCATE BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY I'M SOMEONE
WHO GREW UP IN FOSTER CARE AND
I LIVED OFTEN CATASTROPHIC
IMPACT OF BIG AGENCIES
FORGETTING. WHAT SEEMED TO THEM
LIKE SMALL INDIVIDUAL PROBLEMS
AND CRISIS HAPPENED. SO WHEN I
START BY JUST SAYING THAT FOR
YOU CAN FOSTER CARE WE KNOW.
THAT WHAT HILLS TRAUMA WHAT
BUILDS RESILIENCE AND IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF
GROWING UP HEALTHY IS
RELATIONSHIPS. RELATIONSHIPS
CAN GET US THROUGH JUST ABOUT
ANYTHING. AND WITH THE PANDEMIC
THE UNIVERSE HAS DEFINITELY
DECIDED TO TEST THE LIMITS OF
WHAT JUST ABOUT ANYTHING
ACTUALLY MEANS- INSURING YOUTH
ARE LIVING IN ENVIRONMENTS
WHERE THEY RECEIVE THE
PARENTING BUT NURTURING THE
SENSE OF SAFETY AND WHATEVER
NORMALCY AS POSSIBLE DURING
THESE CHALLENGING TIMES. I JUST
HAVE TO BE A PRIORITY. DURING
COMBAT. I'M SENATOR WIENER
PARTICULARLY FOR THE YOUTH WHO
HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY LET DOWN
AND HURT THE MOST BY ADULTS AND
WHO FACE THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES NAVIGATING. THE
WORLD- OF THE PANDEMIC SO THAT
INCLUDES LGBTQ YOUTH YOU'D HAVE
EXPERIENCE COMMERCIAL SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION YOU HAVE BEEN
DUMPED FROM FOSTER CARE IN
JUVENILE JUSTICE WE REALLY HAVE
TO MAKE A RELATIONSHIP WORK FOR
THOSE YOUTH URGENT. I'M TO
BEGIN WITH I WANT TO JUST BE
REAL MOST OF THE CALL THAT
ISSUES THAT HAVE HAD THE
GREATEST IMPACT ON YOUTH AND
CHILD WELFARE ACTUALLY NOT NEW
ISSUES. THEY ARE PRE EXISTING
CRACKS AND FAULT LINES THAT.
SOMETIMES TURNED INTO CANYONS
THAT HAVE NOW BEEN AMPLIFIED SO
THAT WE CAN ALL SEE THEM. AND
HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO TURN INTO.
HUGE CHALLENGES FOR THE SYSTEM-
AS AN EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES FOR THE APPROXIMATELY
THREE THOUSAND CALIFORNIA USED
BETTER LANGUAGE IT LANGUISHING
IN CONGREGATE CARE AND
SHELTERS. THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
YEARS BLACK AND BROWN- DEPRIVED
OF PARENTING EXPERIENCING
HARMFUL CONDITIONS THAT
INTERFERE WITH THEIR HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT. THIS HUGE NEW RISK
A VIRUS OUTBREAK IN THEIR
FACILITIES IT'S JUST ONE MORE
DANGER- THAT RISK IS
PARTICULARLY ACUTE FOR
PROBATION SUPERVISED YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE A LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF WHOM ARE PLACED IN
CONGREGATE CARE. OR WHO HAVE
BEEN STUCK IN JUVENILE HALL
PENDING PLACEMENT WAITING FOR
PROBATION TO FULLY CONSIDER
RELEASE HOME OR A FAMILY PLACE
AN OPTION. AS A RECENT EXAMPLE
ALL OF THE IMPACT ON YOU F
CONGER CARE CPAS. ON OF OUT OF
CONGREGATE. EARLY IN THE
PENTOMIC DOZENS OF PROBATION
SUPERVISED. YOU FROM CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE PLACED AT CDSS
CERTIFIED LAKESIDE ACADEMY IN
MICHIGAN HAD TO BE BROUGHT HOME
ON AN EMERGENCY BASIS AFTER IN
MICHIGAN CHILD WAS KILLED BY A
STAFF MEMBER DURING A VIOLENT
RESTRAINT. PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
VIDEO FOOTAGE FROM APRIL TWENTY
NINTH SHOWS SIXTEEN YEAR OLD
CORNELIUS THROWING A SANDWICH
AND THEN BEING BRUTALLY AND
VIOLENTLY RESTRAINED BY
EMPLOYEES AND TELLY IS NEAR
DEATH THANK YOUNG MAN DIED A
SHORT TIME LATER. IN THE MONTH
BEFORE CORNELIUS IS THAT
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED A COMPLAINT
THAT LIKES AT LAKESIDE ACADEMY
HAD USED IMPROPER RESTRAINTS
AND THAT STAFF REGULARLY USE
PHYSICAL ABUSE AS PUNISHMENT.
DURING THE COURSE OF CDSS THIS
INVESTIGATION MICHIGAN
LICENSING SUBSTANTIATED TWO
COMPLAINTS RELATED TO EXCESSIVE
FORCE CDSS HOWEVER I FAILED TO
SUBSTANTIATE THE COMPLAINT.
THIS IS NOT AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT M. SIXTEEN OUT OF
STATE FACILITIES AND SEVEN
STATES THAT ARE CERTIFIED BY
CDSS AS MEETING CALIFORNIA
LICENSING STANDARDS FOR FOSTER
CARE. EVERY CERTIFIED OUT OF
STATE FACILITY HAS POLICIES
THAT VIOLATE CORE CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS THESE FACILITIES
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AND
FLAGRANT DISREGARD OF
CALIFORNIA'S CORPORATE CAPTION
FOR FOSTER CHILDREN THESE ARE
STILL BASIC LIKE PROHIBITING
THE OPERATION OF SECURE
FACILITIES REQUIRING A HOME
LIKE ENVIRONMENT- ENSURING THAT
YOUTH ARE FREE FROM ABUSE AND
CORPORAL PUNISHMENT ALLOWING
YOU TO COMMUNICATE PRIVATELY
WITH FAMILY FRIENDS ATTORNEY'S
CASE MANAGERS. GIVING YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE SOCIAL ACTIVITIES THAT YOU
ASKED ABOUT MADAM CHAIR IMPACT
OUR STATE HAS CONSISTENTLY
ALLOWED CALIFORNIA USED TO
REMAIN IN FACILITIES AFTER
OTHER STATES HAVE TAKEN ACTION
TO PROHIBIT THEIR USE. COVET
NINETEEN HAS RESULTED IN LESS
OVERSIGHT AND PROTECTION FOR
THESE UNITS WHO ARE FAR AWAY
FROM HOME FAMILY AND OTHER EYES
YOU CAN INSURE THEIR WELLBEING.
PROTECTING YOUNG PEOPLE DURING
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
REQUIRES CAREFUL PLANNING AND
STRICT ADHERENCE TO PREVENTION
PROTOCOLS THE SITUATION AT
LAKESIDE ACADEMY ILLUSTRATES
THE LACK OF CARE PROVIDED WITH
NEARLY. NO STRONGER OVERSIGHT.
SEVERAL THIS CARE FOR YOU HAVE
HAD CTHAT OUR DESPITE THE
INCREASED RISK DUE TO PET HIM
DOWN AND TRY RISK SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
RELAXATION OF IN PERSON
VISITATION REQUIREMENTS BY
AGENCY PERSONNEL THE SUSPENSION
OF THE ANNUAL LICENSING
INSPECTIONS AND THE METER
ACTION OF CALIFORNIA LICENSING
PERSONNEL TO PRIORITIZE ADULT
FACILITIES YOU'VE BEEN OUT OF
STATE GROUP HOMES ARE RECEIVING
LESS OVERSIGHT. RATHER THAN
MORE. LASTLY I WANT TO SAY THAT
WE HAVE TO BE PROACTIVE AND
CONSIDERING THE NEED TO REFORM
THE SAFETY NET FOR YOU TO ARE
AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE AND
LIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC AN
ECONOMY. TEN YEARS AGO MANY OF
THE PARTNERS WHO ARE ON THIS
SOON TODAY ADVOCATED
SUCCESSFULLY FOR THE PASSAGE OF
OUR CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TO ALLOW EXTENSION OF
FOSTER CARE TO AGE TWENTY ONE.
AS ONE OF THE FIRST STATES IN
THE NATION TO EXTEND FOSTER
CARE AFTER THE FEDERAL LAW WAS
ENACTED CALIFORNIA POLICYMAKERS
ADVOCATES AND YOU HAVE
COMMITTED THAT EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE WOULD BE TRANSFORMATIVE.
RATHER THAN THREE ADDITIONAL
YEARS OF PATCHWORK INEFFECTIVE
SERVICES THAT SIMPLY DELAYED
THE CONSEQUENCES OF A DIFFICULT
TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD THE
VISION WAS THAT EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE WOULD TRULY BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF YOUTH AND A RADICALLY
DIFFERENT WAY. NOW TEN YEARS
AFTER IMPLEMENTATION DURING THE
HISTORICALLY CHALLENGING A
BLEAK MOMENT FOR YOU. IT IS
TIME TO REEVALUATE CALIFORNIA'S
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE POLICY AND
IMPLEMENTATION- RECENT RESEARCH
IDENTIFIED THAT WERE FAILING IN
ONE OF THE COR GOALS AND
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE WHICH IS
ADDITIONAL TIME TO PRIORITIZE
THE LOVING SUPPORTIVE
RELATIONSHIPS FOR YOUTH THAT WE
NOW ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROTECTIVE FACTORS TO IMPROVING
YOUTH WELLNESS AND SUCCESS. IN
A MOMENT WHERE PANDEMIC THE
RESULTING ECONOMIC DEPRESSION
AND NATURAL DISASTERS POSE
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES TO THE
SAFETY NET OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
IT'S URGENT THAT WE ENGAGE IN A
DEEP ANALYSIS AROUND WHAT'S
WORKING AND WHAT'S FAILING AN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. IN ORDER
TO DEVELOP A NEW PLAN AND
SUPPORT NET THAT'S TRULY GOING
TO OFFER YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DEVELOP RESILIENCY AND SOME
FOUNDATION. TO THRIVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU JENNIFER UP NEXT
WE HAVE A MAKAYLA. JAMES
STATEWIDE LEGISLATIVE POLICY
COORDINATOR CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION'S. HELLO EVERYONE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US
ATTENDANCE HEARING TODAY- I'VE
MENTIONED MY NAME IS JAMES AND
I'M THE STATEWIDE POLICY
COORDINATOR AT CALIFORNIA YOU
CONNECTIONS AND SEE WHAT I SEE
AS A YOUTH LED ORGANIZATION
THAT STRIVES TO PROMOTE CHANGE
THROUGH THAT CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM THROUGH POLICY PRACTICE
AND LEGISLATIVE CHANGE. I WOULD
LIKE TO START THIS TAX MONEY BY
STAYING AT SCHOOL BUT NINETEEN
HAS OPERATED OUR DAY TO DAY
LIVES WITH ABSOLUTELY NO NOTICE
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN IS GETTING
AN INSIDE LOOK AT THE STRUGGLES
FOSTER YOUTH IN THIS COUNTRY
HAVE BEEN FACING FOR DECADES.
TODAY WE ALL HAVE LIMITED TO NO
ACCESS TO OUR FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO LIVE OUTSIDE OUR HOMES
TODAY WE ALL PATIENTLY WAIT FOR
GUIDANCE TO BE RELEASED THAT
ALLOWS US ACCESS TO NORMAL
ACTIVITIES. AND TODAY WE ALL
WORRY ABOUT WHAT THE FUTURE
WILL LOOK LIKE IN REGARDS TO
OUR HOUSING IN INCOME STABILITY
EVERY DAY FOR DECADES THESE
HAVE BEEN THE WORRIES IN THE
FOREFRONT OF THE MINDS OF
FOSTER YOU. NOW MORE THAN EVER
IT IS VITAL TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO ENSURE THE SAFETY AND
WELL BEING A FOSTER YOU ADDS
THE WAY SEE OUR MEMBERSHIP HAS
HIGHLIGHTED- TOP PRIORITY IS
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU TODAY. THE FIRST ONE
IS AROUND PLACEMENT STABILITY
SO IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AT
C. RIGHT C. PASSED- A BILL AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN THAT
PROMOTED PLACEMENT STABILITY.
AND- PROVIDED THAT. NOTE
SUPPORT DAYS IT. JIM SIMPLY. IN
THE HOME AND RIGHTS THE FRIENDS
THAT NEED FOR PRESERVATION
STRATEGIES TO TRY TO KEEP THAT
PLACEMENT INTACT. IN DURING THE
NINETEEN WE ARE SEEN THAT
FOURTEEN DAY NOTICES ARE NOT BE
AN ISSUE. WE STILL HAVE THE
STANDARD SEVEN DAY NOTICE WHICH
WAS THAT. GUIDELINES PREVIOUS
TO THAT LEGISLATION THAT ARE
STILL BEING A STUDENTS- EVEN
LASSEN SEVEN DAYS SO THERE'S
NO. TRANSITION PERIOD FOR THE
YOUNG PEOPLE AT THISTIME WHEN
THEY'RE FORCED TO LEAVE THEIR
HOMES. ANOTHER PRIORITY THAT
OUR MEMBERSHIP HAS BROUGHT UP
IS THE NEED FOR ASSISTANCE WITH
VIRTUAL LEARNING SO AS WE
TRANSITION TO RESUME PLATFORMS
IN THE EDUCATIONAL WORLD. AND
OFF CAMERA THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
RESOURCES OR ACCESS FOR
ADDITIONAL HELP RESPONSE TO
YOU. THAT OUR MEMBERSHIP IS
GREATLY COLLEEN FOR- IN REGARDS
TO THAT AS WELL JUST IN ACCESS
TO TECHNOLOGY AND THE NEED OF
LAPTOPS OR HOT SPOT ACCESS. SO
WE HAVE HEARD A LOT OF
CONVERSATION AROUND FOSTER
CLUBBING COUNTY IMPLEMENTATION.
OF DISTRIBUTION OF THESE
RESOURCES BUT YOUNG PEOPLE AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL ARE HAVING A
HARD TIME FINDING. THE POINT
PEOPLE ARE IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT CAN PROVIDE
THEM WITH THAT ACCESS. AND
THERE ISN'T. A HUGE OUT OF
REACH OF KNOWING WHERE TO GO OR
WHO TO CALL WHEN A YOUNG PERSON
IS IN NEED OF THAT. AND ALSO IN
THE FOSTER HOMES WE KNOW THAT
TRADITIONAL FOSTER HOMES
TYPICALLY HAVE MORE THAN ONE.
YOUNG PERSON IN THOSE HOUSES AT
A TIME AND SO HOT SPOTS GOING
OUT FREQUENTLY YOUNG PEOPLE
BEING DISCONNECTED FROM THEIR
SEEM COURSES AND THEIR
MEETINGS- HAS ALSO BEEN A HUGE.
BARRIER FOR SOME OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. THE LAST TIME I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TODAY GOING TO BE THE
CRIME. FOR NEXT THAT ARE
MEMBERSHIP BUILDING A AND
THAT'S AROUND. REDEFINING
MENTAL HEALTH SO THIS IS WHAT
THEY BELIEVE IS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR PRIORITY LIST
FOR THIS YEAR. AND BECAUSE OF
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
GUIDELINES THE LACK OF SOCIAL
INTERACTION IN THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO BIOLOGICAL FAMILY.
MENTAL HEALTH RIGHT NOW IS A
TOP PRIORITY A MORE THAN EVER-
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE ASKING
THIS QUESTION THAT WAS POSED
BEFORE KOBE BUT NOW IT'S JUST
EXACERBATED. AND THAT IS HOW
ARE WE HEARING FROM OUR TRAUMA
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES WITH THE EARLY
PERIOD SCREENING DETECTION AND
TREATMENT. THAT GUIDELINE
STATES THAT IS ON THE TREATMENT
IS HELPFUL IT SHOULD BE GIVEN
TO A YOUNG PERSON UNDER TWENTY
ONE THAT. FALLS UNDER MEDIKAL
IN CALIFORNIA WHAT WE'RE
RUNNING INTO IS THE NEED FOR A
DIAGNOSIS. IN ORDER. TO GET
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THOSE
SERVICES. THE PHARMACY YOUTH
EVEN THE CO. WE KNOW YOUNG ARE
ALL MISSED. AT A HIGHER RATE
THAN ARE NON FOSTER PEERS. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
OFTEN CARRYMULTIPLE DIAGNOSIS
IS AND SOMETIMES EVEN
CONFLICTING DIAGNOSES THAT.
THIS IS BECOMING EXTREMELY
PROBLEMATIC AND BECAUSE THEY
FALL DOWN TO THE SEMANTICS OF
NEEDING NOT DIAGNOSIS IN ORDER
TO BILL FOR SERVICES THAT WE-KNOW ARE LIFESAVING FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE IF WE WANT TO DECREASE
THE AMOUNT OF OVERDOSE AND
DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF SUICIDE
SIX SPECIALLY DURING THE TIME.
OF THIS PANDEMIC WHEN WE KNOW
THAT MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS ARE
SKYROCKETING. YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
CALLING FR AND- I REASON FOR
SERVICES TO BE BASED ON TRAUMA
AND LET'S LET'S FIND A WAY TO
LEAVE BILL TRAUMA OR SERVICES
WITHOUT NEEDING TO ATTACH SO
MANY MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSIS IS
THAT WE KNOW THE YOUNG PEOPLE
CARRIED THROUGHOUT THE
REMAINDER. REMAINDER OF THEIR
LIVES. AND THE LAST THING WE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT IS
NEED FOR ALTERNATIVE TREATMENTS
AND THIS TIME IT FEELING WHERE
WE- FIND THEIR NEW NORMAL AND
HOW DO WE WORK AROUND THE
BARRIERS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
OFTENTIMES SPACE AROUND
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT. WHEN
THEY'RE ASKING FOR THESE
ALTERNATIVE TREATMENT. AND NOW
I'M GONNA PASS IT OVER TO AN IT
TALKS CHRIS TO SHARE BY THEIR
EX. AROUND EDUCATIONAL
BARRIERS. TRANSITION OUTCOMES
IN PARENTING CHALLENGES DURING
THE TIME OF COPING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THREE OF THE TASHA'S
OF THE POSTER YOU CAN MEMBER
FOR CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
LONG BEACH CHAPTER. AND
CRISTINA TORRES FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH IN MEMBER CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION KERN COUNTY
CHAPTER WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS NATASHA SO
SAY AND I AM AN E. STATEWIDE
MEMBERSHIP COUNCIL CO CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION. AT
THE END OF FEBRUARY I TURNED
EIGHTEEN IN MY COUNTY WORKER
EXPLAINS ME THAT SINCE I'VE
AGED OUT I WOULD BE RECEIVING A
NEW COUNTY WORKER AND MY COURT
HEARINGS WILL BE HELD
SEPARATELY THAN FROM MY YOUNGER
SIBLINGS HOWEVER DUE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC MY
HEARINGS HAVE BEEN POSTPONED.
AND I'M SEEING THAT USE ARE NO
LONGER ABLE TO SPEAK DIRECTLY
TO THE JUDGE ANYMORE REGARDING
THEIR NEEDS AND WANTS. I'M
FINDING THAT RATHER THAN HAVING
TO ATTORNEY STEP UP AND DO
THEIR JOBS THEY'VE BEEN
SLACKING OFF AND SITTING ON
THINGS INSTEAD OF WRITING
REQUEST TO THE JUDGES. THEY
NEED TO BE MORE RESPONSIVE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
WONDERFUL TRANSITIONAL PERIOD
FOR MANY YEARS. THIS PAST YEAR
I GRADUATED FROM LONG BEACH
POLYTECHNIC HIGH SCHOOL IN
CURRENTLY I'M ATTENDING CAL
STATE LONG BEACH MAJORING IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. ACTS NAVIGATE
THE CONFUSING PROCESS OF
ENROLLMENT AND FINANCIAL AID BY
MYSELF. AS AT THIS TIME WE WERE
EXPERIENCING QUARANTINE. I HEAR
FROM MANY USE THAT THERE'S A
LACK OF COMMUNICATION COMING
FROM SOCIAL WORKERS AT THIS
TIME. IT IS ESPECIALLY
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING FOR
THOSE ONLY RECENTLY AGED OUT OF
THE SYSTEM LIKE MYSELF. AT THIS
POINT WE RECEIVE NEW WORKERS
WERE SUPPOSED TO HELP
SUPPORTERS NAVIGATE THROUGH
IOP. CHANGE SO HOUSING AND SO
JUST DUE TO THE PANDEMIC WE
HAVE TO MEET WITH ALL THESE NEW
PEOPLE OVER STUDENT WHICH MAY
NOT ALWAYS BE THE EASIEST FORM
OF COMMUNICATION. SO I'M SEEING
THAT IT'S THESE YOUTH- ARE NO
LONGER RECEIVING PHONE CALLS
ARE NOT BEING VISITED AND THEY
GO MONTHS AT A TIME. SIMPLY
ALONE IN THEIR DORMS. EVEN THE
PEOPLE ARE NOW WORKING FROM
HOME WORKERS NEED TO REMAIN
ENGAGED IN HANDS ON WITH THEIR
YOUTH ESPECIALLY AT THIS TIME.
ANOTHER BARRIER I'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING THAT CODE HAS HAD
AN IMPACT ON ITS IN REGARDS TO
MY EDUCATION. UNIVERSITIES ARE
NOT CORRECTLY TRAINING THEIR
FACULTY AND STAFF TO WORK
REMOTELY IN CLASS THERE'S
LITTLE TO NO INSTRUCTION NOW
THAT WE'VE CONDITION TO BEIG
VIRTUAL. THIS SEMESTER ONE OF
MY PROFESSORS PROFESSOR STATED
THAT THEY'VE BEEN HAVING
INTERNET PROBLEMS SO WE'VE ONLY
HAD ONE Z. MEETINGS ENTIRE
SEMESTER. PEOPLE AREN'T
GRASPING HOW IMPORTANT THIS
TIME IS FOR YOU MY EDUCATION IS
MY LIVELIHOOD AND MY FUTURE
DEPENDS ON THIS HOWEVER THEY
ARE FAILING US AND FOR THIS
REASON I BELIEVE THAT IT IS
REALLY DETRIMENTAL THAT
TOGETHER WE NEED TO DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS. TO DEAL WITH THE
BARRIERS THAT THE SPEND
AMERICANS CALLING FOR YOU.
THANK YOU EVERYONE. THANK YOU
NATASHA. AND WE HAVE A LOT. MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA TAURUS AND I
AM ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA
BASED CONNECTION BUT I'M ALSO
HE ADVOCATE FOR JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR USE AND I WOULD
LIKE TO TALK TO YOU GUYS ABOUT.
MY EXPERIENCE I AM A FORMER
PORTUGUESE- I HAD. I CURRENTLY
HAVE THREE KIDS I HAVE ONE WHO
IS IN SCHOOL RIGHT NOW AND I
HAD TO PUT OFF GOING TO
COLLEGE- SO I CAN. HELP HER
THROUGH HER CLASS- TEACHER WHAT
SHE NEEDS TO DO- IT'S A LITTLE
DIFFICULT BECAUSE SHE- HAD A
GREAT DOWN. LAST WEEK. SHE OR
WHAT WAS GOING ON OUR- IN THE
WORK WAY HE. LOOK AT THE TO SEE
HOW. TRANSITION FOR HER- YOU'LL
ALSO SHE'S NOT AROUND. EIGHT
OKAY. TRANSACTION. FOR MORE
CRISTINA SPEAKING INTO THE MIKE
FROM HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME
HEARING YOU SORRY ABOUT THAT. I
WAS CURRENTLY PREGNANT AT
FIFTEEN HOURS FOSTER CARE AND
IT WAS A TO CHANGES GOING FROM
A HOME IN TWO CARE HOME SHE AND-
AS PARENT EACH TO DO WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO FOR YOUR KIDS. AND
RIGHT NOW. WITH THIS. IT TO
DETER TIME FOR ARE YOU KIDS-
BECAUSE- THEY'RE SO USED TO
BEING AROUND THEIR FRIENDS AND-
THEIR TEACHERS AND THEY CAN'T
GET THAT ONE ON ONE ACCESS. AND
I WANT TO ONE HELP WITH- THEIR
TEACHER AND RIGHT NOW- MY
DAUGHTER IS HAVING A LITTLE
DIFFICULT TIME WITH THE
TRANSITION. OF SCHOOL. AND I
ACTUALLY HAD TO PUT ALL SCHOOL
I WAS CURRENTLY GOING TO
SCHOOL. FOR BUSINESS AND SOCIAL
WORK. AND SO I HAD TO THE- WAIT
A WHOLE I'M WAITING AND NEXT
SEMESTER. TO RE ENROLL INTO
COLLEGE- BUT IT'S BEEN A
DIFFICULT TIME AND I JUST THINK
THAT. IF THERE WERE SOME SOTOS
SOLUTIONS THAT WE CAN. HELP
WITH OUR YOUNGER GENERATIONS OF
THIS TRANSITION. FROMPHYSICAL
LEARNING TO THIS VIRTUAL
LEARNING- SO THAT IS MY
EXPERIENCE RIGHT NOW. THANK
THANK YOU CRISTINA- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU AND THE TASHA
AND THE REST OF THE PANEL OF
SPEAKERS OUT PROVIDING US WITH
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU DAHLE
DID IN THE INSIDE THE ALTAR
TODAY- AND MOST OF ALL THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES IT WILL DEFINITELY
BE HELPFUL TO ALL OF US AND I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO SPEAK UP AND TO
REACH OUT TO US WE WANT TO BE
THERE FOR YOU ARE GOING TO BE
THERE FOR YOU. AND SO. YOU
KNOW. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE AS WELL.
BUT THESE DO YOU KNOW THESE
EXPERIENCES ARE EXACTLY WHY WE
ARE HERE TODAY AND IT IS SO
NECESSARY FOR US TO HEAR FROM
YOU AND- AND DIRECTLY- YOU KNOW
THOSE THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THE
SYSTEM AND THE DECISIONS THAT
WE MAKE HERE SO THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN FOR YOUR ADVOCACY. I WANT
TO I WANT TO BRING- THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. IT AND SO ALL. ALL GO
HEAD AND- START WITH ASKING A
COUPLE QUESTIONS AND REALLY
AIMED AT NATASHA AND- CRISTINA
IF YOU'RE WILLING TO SHARE. DO
EITHER OF YOU HAVE A REQUEST OR
POLICY CHANGE A RECOMMENDATION
THAT WOULD HAVE IMPROVED YOUR
EXPERIENCE DURING THE PANDEMIC
OR COULD HELP I HAD YOU KNOW.
OTHER FOSTER YOUTH- DURING THIS
TIME. THIS IS. FOR THE-
NINETEEN FOR SURE YOU. BECAUSE
I KNOW THIS ISN'T- THIS IS IN A
REALLY HUGE CONVERSATION THAT
PEOPLE HAS TALKED ABOUT BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF FAR STRIP
OF WASHI- I AM. CURRENTLY I
KNOW ABOUT TWO PEOPLE THAT OUR
PARENTS IN THE SYSTEM AS OF
RIGHT NOW- I THINK THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE I WOULD.
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT WOULD BE
THERE CAN BE LIKE ANY POSSIBLE.
I'M TRYING TO FIND THE WORDS
RIGHT OUT OF COLLEGE I- MORE.
I'M SORRY. I WOULD SAY MORE
OPTIONS FOR OUR YOUNGER
GENERATIONS RIGHT NOW BECAUSE-
WITH OUR YOUNGER YOUTH ENTERING
SCHOOL- MAYBE BECAUSE I KNOW
SOME SCHOOLS ARE DOING IN
PERSON BUT THEY'RE ONLY FOR
LIKE TWO HOURS AND TO BE HONEST
I DON'T BELIEVE I DON'T THINK
THAT'S ENOUGH FOR OUR YOUTH
BECAUSE YOUNGER KIDS NEED. THAT
INTERACTION WITH PEOPLE THEIR
OWN AGE AND I CAN ALREADY SEE
THE AFFECTS THAT HAPPENING WITH
MY OWN DAUGHTER SO MAYBE IF WE
CAN HAVE SOME SORT OF DATE. DAY
IS TO WHERE THE KIDS CAN
INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER OF
COURSE WITH THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING GUIDELINES AND THE
MASK PROTECTIONS IN THE HAND
SANITIZING. I DON'T THINK IT
WOULD BE THAT DIFFICULT TO HAVE
ACTIVITIES FOR OUR FOR OUR
KIDS. TO BE ABLE TO INTERACT
WITH OTHER KIDS THEIR OWN AGE.
SHE. THANK YOU CRISTINA NATASHA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD TO. YES-
WELCOME THAT I EXPERIENCED
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WAS THAT I RECEIVED A
FOURTEEN DAY NOTICE FROM MY
FOSTER HOME AND SO I WAS
DISPLACED AND JUST DUE TO BEING
SUCH LAST MINUTE MY SOCIAL
WORKER SAID THAT THE ONLY PLACE
THAT THEY HAD OPENED FOR ME AND
MY YOUNGER SISTERS WOULD BE IN
A SHELTER AND SO MY OLDER
BROTHER FORTUNATELY HE HAD A
PLACE WE CAN STAY BECAUSE AS
YOU YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE YOU
WE DIDN'T WANT TO BE IN A
SHELTER BECAUSE- IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC THAT WAS LIKE A
GREAT HOT SPOT AND RATHER THAN
SUPPORTING US. IN ADDING
STABILITY IN THE MIDDLE OF
PANDEMIC WE RECEIVED A FOURTEEN
DAY NOTICE AND WE DIDN'T EVEN
HAVE THOSE FOR FOURTEEN DAYS
TO- FIGURE OUT OF PLACE SO.
MANY MAKING SURE THAT THE
POLICIES WE HAVE SET IN PLACE
ARE STILL BEING IMPLEMENTED
EVEN THOUGH THAT WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A LOT OF CHANGES
RIGHT NOW. IS IT THAT THIS TIME
IT IS. AT THIS TIME IS WHEN YOU
NEED. THE MOST SUPPORT NOT MORE
OBSTACLES IN THEIR PATH. THANK
YOU AYE YOU KNOW IT DEFINITELY-
I KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION AND JUST YOU KNOW
RIGHTFULLY SO AND WE WANT TO
MAKE THINGS RIGHT WE WANT TO
MAKE THINGS BETTER. AS FOR OUR
OTHER PANELISTS TODAY I WANT TO
KNOW- IF ANYONE HAD ANY COMMENT
REGARDING THAT IS THERE ANY
BEST PRACTICE OR CHANGE
RESULTING FROM THE PANDEMIC THE
YOU THINK HAS IMPROVED THE WAY
THE SYSTEM FUNCTIONS OR
SOMETHING HOPE WE CAN. KEEP
AFTER WE RETURN. BACK TO NORMAL
OR POST CODE. AND IF YOU. WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE A COMMENT
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. CAN YOU
PLEASE ON MUTE LESLIE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IJUST IN TERMS
OF THINGS THAT ARE WORKING WELL
THAT WE CAN KEEP- OUR
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN THAT WHILE
VIRTUAL CONTACT WITH CLIENTS IS
NOT A REPLACEMENT FOR IN PERSON
CONTACT THE ABILITY TO HAVE
MORE FREQUENT CONTACT IS A
POSITIVES AUGMENTATION SO FOR
C. L. C. M. AS AN EXAMPLE WE
INTEND. TO I'M INCREASE WHAT WE
EXPECT OF OUR STAFF IN TERMS OF
HOW FREQUENTLY THEY CONTACT
CLIENTS BY USING A COMBINATION%
OF VIRTUAL. AND IN PERSON
CONTACT ALTHOUGH CURRENTLY
BECAUSE OF THE INCREASED
CASELOADS- BECAUSE OF THE
BACKLOG AND INCREASED NUMBER OF
CLIENTS AND THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
THAT ARE OUT DUE TO COPE IT AND
OTHER THINGS LIKE THAT-
MAINTAINING THE BASELINE IS. IS
PROBABLY THE ALL OF THAT'S
REALISTIC- BUT I THINK THAT
THIS INCREASE CONTACT MORE
FREQUENT CONTACT IS NEVER A BAD
IDEA AND IS ALWAYS A BENEFIT
AND- NOW THAT. YOU HAVE DEVICES
BECAUSE OF DISTANCE LEARNING
BECAUSE OF SCHOOL IT IS UCH
EASIER TO HAVE THAT VIRTUAL
CONTACT AS A FACE TO FACE
RATHER THAN- TELEPHONE AND THAT
HAS DEFINITELY BEEN ADVANTAGES
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD CONTINUE
AND SIMILARLY. THE EASE OF
HAVING MORE FREQUENT PARENT
CONTACT- JR CHILLY AGAIN AS A
SUPPLEMENT TO IN PERSON CONTACT
NOT AS A REPLACEMENT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE THINK. IT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL GOING
FORWARD PERHAPS CHANGE
EXPECTATIONS. AND MINIMUM
EXPECTATIONS AROUND THAT. THANK
YOU WELL THANK YOU TO OUR
SECOND PANEL YOU KNOW AND WE
WILL BE MOVING FORWARD TO OUR
THIRD PANEL. I BUT YOU KNOW I
REALLY WANT TO JUST- BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO THE THIRD PANEL WANT
TO COMMENT ON THAT- YOU KNOW
WHAT BUT JENNIFER RODRIGUEZ
SAID EARLIER. AND SHE SAID.
SOMETHING ALONG THE LINES OF A
DEEP ANALYSIS THAT WE NEED THIS
IS THE TIME TO DO IT DEEP
ANALYSIS TO MAKE THINGS RIGHT.
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
PARAPHRASING AND NOT GETTING IT
EXACTLY RIGHT BUT- I THINK THAT
SHE'S. ABSOLUTELY SPOT ON- WE
NEED TO GET THINGS RIGHT WE
NEED TO. DO A DEEP ANALYSIS AND
SO I'M GRATEFUL FOR. OUR FOR
ALL OF OUR SPEAKERS UP PART OF
OUR SECOND PANEL THEY'RE ABLE
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TODAY. SO
MOVING ON A THIRD PANEL LET'S
START WITH- WHICH WE WILL
EXPLORE CORPORATE IMPACT ON
FAMILIES AND CARE GIVERS AND WE
WILL BEGIN WITH JULIA HANNIGAN
ATTORNEY AT LAW STAFF TORN.
STAFF ATTORNEY DEPENDENCY LEGAL
SERVICES. ONCE AGAIN I WANT TO
JUST REMIND FOLKS THREE TO FIVE
MINUTES FOR PER SPEAKER AN-
ANTI APPRECIATE. EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE. TODAY SO FIRST OF
ALL- I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING TIME ON
THIS ISSUE. I KNOW EVERYBODY ON
THIS CALL HAS BEEN WORKING SO
HARD OVER THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS AND IT IS REALLY.
IMPORTANT ALL TO FOCUS ON THE
THINGS THAT ARE WORKING BUT
MOST OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
GOING TO TALK ABOUT TODAY ARE
YOU THINGS ARE NOT WORKING. SO
I. WILL GET DEPENDENCY LEGAL
SERVICES WE REPRESENT PARENTS
AND KIDS IN. SEVEN COUNTIES IN
NORTHERN AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
I PERSONALLY AND THE PARENTS
TRADING SLUMP COUNTY. ALSO ON
OUR EXECUTIVE TEAM. AND WHAT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT TODAY IS
REUNIFICATION HOPEFUL BECAUSE
FRANKLY FOR OUR CURRENT CLIENTS.
THAT'S THE BALLGAME OF WELFARE
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING-
GAS WHAT THEY'RE FOCUS IS. HAS
TO COMMEND CHALLENGE FOR MONEY
AND. UNIFIED CHILDREN FOR
CHILDREN BE RETURNED TO THE-
TODAY JUST READ ABOUT THREE.
VISITATION WHICH ATTACHED ON A
NUMBER OUR SPEAKERS THE
SERVICES FOR PARENTS LOOKING
FOR TO KOBE AND THEN THE
TIMELINE SWITCHING OVER OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE ON THE THIS A WHILE.
WITH REGARDS TO. I DON'T WANT
TO SIMPLY. MORE COMMENTS FROM
OTHERS. BUT THE FIRST VISIT TO.
HOW BEEN PROVIDE. SHOULD BE
USED AS A SUPPLEMENT AND NOT
REPLACE FOR PERSON. FOR IN ALL
TOO MANY OF OUR SIXTEEN ABOUT
THE SAME. AS THE HIGH MONTHLY
OUT. THERE IS NO. THAT WE CAN
CREATE SIX ATTACHMENTS FOR
BABIES WHO ARE BEEN DETAINED
FROM THERE. WHOSE AGES SO. THAT
DOUBLES CAN. AND SO MANY OUR
CLIENTS ALL TO. THEY'VE BEEN
SENSE. WE ALSO. USURPATION AS A-
FOR OUR PARENTS TO THE SOUTH
HOW THE- WHAT OTHER ADDITION
SERVICES THEY NEED AND THE POTS
RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY HAVE
THEIR CHILDREN AND DOING MODELS
ASSUME HAS PROVED CHALLENGING
THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS AND
CERTAINLY IT'S TO BACK ON
FORWARD. IT A NEW YORK AREA TO
ALLOW OF OPTIONS. WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN IN AFTER CASE IS FOR A
GENERAL'S ABOUT. PERRANCE
RELATIONSHIPS THEIR CHILDREN
BEING BASED ON FIXING IN CALLS-
AND SO- WE DON'T FEEL LIKE
COURTS SOCIAL WORKERS MIND
COUNCIL ANYBODY'S ENOUGH FROM
YOU ABOUT PARENTS AND
RELATIONSHIP OF. RELATIONSHIPS
CHILDREN BASED ON THIS. CALL WE
ARE CONCERNED BECAUSE- ALL
NATURE OF THE IN THIS WHICH OFF
OURS ARE AND CODE PROTOCOL ARE
IN THE OFFICE OF WE WANT. OUR
CLIMB OF- ARE CLIENTS ARE GOING
TO VISITS USE THEY CAN ONLY
THEIR CHILDREN ONCE WE CANNOT
GIVE THEIR TO CARE THEY CANNOT
HAVE CHILD ON THE LAP IN A BOOK
CANNOT SHARE FOOD ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT MAKES- GOOD SOLID
BONDED FAMILY SIXTY AND IT'S
CREATING SOME PROBLEMS. SINCE
SINCE THE VERY. IT ON CREATING.
PROBLEM AND TRY TO ON IT'S A
TWO. WE HAVE FOR. SO WHAT WE
NEED IS. IN ARKANSAS. MORE
AGENCIES CAN HARM USE TO ENSURE
THAT FOR TO CAN HAPPEN AND WE
ARE NEED TO CREATE A LOT.
BETWEEN RESOURCE FAMILIES.
BIOLOGICAL PARENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
EVERYONE IN THE SAME SORT OF
COOKING POT. THAT WE CAN HAVE
CITY WITH AS FEW. AS POSSIBLE.
IT'S NOT GONNA BE POSSIBLE IN A
CASE. BUT WE NEED. TO WHAT DO
THE NUMBER. WHO ARE. VISITATION
IS THE TOBACCO. ALSO WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT SORT DOCTOR KLEIN.
AS IS TALKED ABOUT PREVIOUS. A
LOT OF OUR SERVICES FOR ON IN
THE IN MARCH AT FOR SOME OF OUR
FIND THAT'S FINE BUT SOME OF
OUR PARENTS. THIS ARE NOT
MEETING NEEDS FOR EXAMPLE IF A
PARENT HAS DO HANDS ON. THE
DIFFICULT TO DO WHATEVER SEEM
OUR PARENTS NEED TO DO MEETS
ROCK SERVICES AND TO HELP.
ATTENSITY WITH OLDER CHIU. C.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO DO
BACKSTOPS WHICH ARE INHERENTLY
SO HOW. OVERSEE AND IT'S TRUE
THAT OF THE OF TREATMENT IN
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT IN
OUR- THE FINANCE. ALL SUPPOSED
TO BE ALL. SETTINGS AND THOSE
ARE SO MUCH LARGER FACILITY
OVERSEEING WE DO HAVE. REALLY
STRUGGLING IN THIS THAT
PROVIDED. A ENDS AS A DOUBLE OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS MY THE
VARIABILITY OF SERVICE HAS. I
KNOW FOR STRUCTURE GET INTO IN
CASE IN THE TREATMENT BECAUSE
OF THAT'S FOR QUARANTINE FOR
BEFORE AND BECAUSE OFF THE. THE
SERVICES ARE GO UNDER.
FOURTEENTH DURING- BECAUSE OF
CONCERN. OUR CLIENTS SO EVEN
JUST GET BASICALLY INTO
INPATIENT. NOW SO THE LAST
EIGHT MONTHS REALLY BEEN. A
STRUGGLE FOR GETTING OUR
CLIENTS SERVICES. FINALLY THAT
TIME LINES. OURONE OF THE
THINGS THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
SUMMIT BECAUSE WE ARE PASSED
OUR SIX MONTH. INTO CO SO WE
ARE HAVING SO TO ME THE
TIMELINE ISSUES ARE TWOFOLD
WERE HAVING- ISSUES WITH SIX
ONE HEARINGS AND THEN ISSUES OF
THE EIGHTEEN MONTH TERM- FOR
CLIENTS WHO ARE FACING A SIX
MONTH HEARING RIGHT NOW- MOST
LIKELY HAVE HAD THEIR CHILDREN
DETAINED DURING CALLS- SO THEY
HAVE ONLY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ABSENCES DURING COOKING THE
ONLY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE WHATEVER GETS ITS WILL BE
ABLE TO COBBLE TOGETHER WHAT
ELSE WHATEVER SERVICES HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DE COUPLE COUPLE
TOGETHER FOR THEM. AND THEY'RE
EXPECTED TO MEET THE REGULAR
STANDARD STANDARDS SET OUT IN
MODERN INSTITUTIONS. TO MONEY.
AND IF NOT THERE ARE RISK OF
HAVING THEIR UNIFICATION
SERVICE TERMINATE. AND THEN
THEIR PARENTAL RIGHTS. A WHAT A
STATE- CAROL IS ACTUALLY LIAR
IN THE IS TERMINATED AT SIX
WILL OF ON THE HANDFUL STATES.
PAUL SAID FARM TEAM SERVICES AT
SIX MONTHS AND IF TO COVER
CRISIS IS REALLY HIGH. HOW DID
THE IT IS OUR CLIENTS IN
GENERAL BUT IT'S- NOW TO MAKE
SUBSTANTIVE PROGRESS IN THAT
SHORT OF TIME. AND OUR CLIENTS
AND THIS ALSO IS SOMETHING THAT
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS BE FAKE WE
KNOW THAT OUR TIMES CAN
SOMETIMES A PROBLEM WE GET OUT
NO FIFTEEN TWO WE WERE ASKED
MONTHS HAVE THOSE PROBLEMS SO
LET'S FIX THAT REALLY ALLOWS
FOR- SERVICES TO BE CONTINUED.
THANK YOU TO OUR CALL THE
RESTRICTION. DUE TO THE IMPACT
OF CODE ON UNIFICATION. WOULD
BE EIGHTEEN. EASY SOLUTION WHAT
WOULD HELP SO MANY POINTS.
ADDITIONALLY I THINK THE
EIGHTEEN MONTHS DATE WHICH IS
IN MOST CASES THE ABSOLUTE
DEADLINE WHICH HANDS ARE NEEDED
TO GET SOMETHING OUT OF BOSTON
CARE. FOR THE STOCK HEARING HAS
ALSO BEEN A PROBLEM FOR SO MANY
BEHIND WHO ARE FACING EIGHTEEN
UPDATE. THE LAST SIX MONTHS OF
SERVICES HAVE BEEN. IMPACTED
HOLDEN. AND SO WE ARE FACING A
SITUATION WHERE COURTS ARE
FEELING THE CANCER TIED IN WHAT
THEY HAVE TO TERMINATE SERVICES
TO COMPLY WITH BOTH CALIFORNIA
AND FEDERAL GUIDELINES DON'T
WANT TO BECAUSE COLIN HAS
REALLY IMPACTED A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PLACES AND SO WHAT I
THINK D. R. TREMENDOUSLY. TO
OUR COUNTIES ALSO CARRIES ON
STATE SUBURBAN SOME LEGISLATIVE
GUIDE ABOUT BIRDS CAN TAKE
COMMITTEE. ACCOUNT AND PROVIDE
OAKLEY. LEGAL STAND AND
GUIDELINES ABOUT. WHAT PERRANCE
COUNCIL NEEDS TO SHOW FOR TO
GET SERVICE EXTEND. WHITE
THINGS CAN CONSIDER WHICH
TYPICALLY BECAUSE ACTUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES TO REUNIFICATION
ATHLETES AMONG THE. WE HAVE
SOME SORT OF AGAIN TOGETHER
FRAME ABOUT WE TURN ARE MAKING
ARGUMENT THAT HE THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE ABOUT IT OUR
COUNTIES AROUND THE STATE IS.
THERE IS A HUGE JUST. IN THE
OUTCOMES THAT COMING AND SO FOR
A LOT OF US ARE GOING TO COURT
AND DAY MAKING THE ZERO FIFTEEN
REALLY AREN'T. AND WE'RE TRYING
TO GET TAX IN OUR- AND WITH OUR
AGENTS TO TRY TO MAKE THAT
DOING RIGHT BY OUR PARENTS
BY CONFLICT
MORE CLEAR WHAT. ARM FRAMEWORK-
WE ARE TRYING TO FIT SQUARE IN
HOLES IN TRYING TO FIT. OUR
CURRENT. IN THE CASE BUT IT
REALLY DOESN'T ADDRESS. OKAY SO
WE- HOPING SOME SORT OF ACTION
COULD BE TO- PROVIDE ABOUT HOW
TO DEAL WITH TIMELINE INC ALL
AGES BECAUSE FOR OUR CLIENTS-
UNIFICATION AND THE TYPE OF
SERVICES THAT. THE TIME THEY
GET TO GET THE EXACT HAVE BEEN
JUST COMPLETELY UP AND OKAY AND
HOW EVERYONE'S. COUNTY RECENT
GREATLY AND TOM. ONE IS THERE
ARE OUR CURRENT CLIENTS ASKING
ARE NOW BEING LEFT OUT IN THIS.
OF TREMENDOUS STRUGGLE FOR SOME.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SOME TOOL-
AT MOBILE A MOVE ON TO AND G.
SURE. VICE POLICY ADVOCACY
ALLIANCE WITH CHILDREN'S.
RIGHTS AND AT ONE AGAIN I JUST
WANT TO ADD YOU KNOW EMPHASIZED
THAT. YOU TO FIVE MINUTE- PER A
SPEAKER AND WE'RE JUST YOU KNOW
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HEAR FROM ALL OF THE PANELISTS
HERE TODAY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS TO
SHARE WITH YOU THE IMPACTS OF
IN NINETEEN IS HAVING OUR CARE
GIVERS. THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND CARE GIVERS IS NOT
LIMITED TIED RELATIVE. OR NON
RELATIVE CHILDREN BUT I WANT TO
FOCUS TODAY ON OUR RELATIVES
WHO CARE FOR OVER 40% OF OUR
STATE'S FOSTER CHILDREN. ARE
OFTEN CARING FOR MULTIPLE
CHILDREN BECAUSE RELATIVES ARE
MORE LIKELY TO TAKE AN ENTIRE
SIBLING GROUPS. THESE RELATIVES
DUE TO THEIR AGE AND OTHER
DISABLING CONDITIONS AREN'T
PARTICULAR RISK OF SUFFERING
THE MOST DAMAGING IMPACTS OF
KIND OF AND- THEY WERE ALSO
ALREADY LIKELY TO BE LIVING AT
OR BELOW THE POVERTY LINE EACH
FOR THE PANDEMIC AND ECONOMIC
CRISIS HAS. AND MANY HAVE
EXPERIENCED LOST WAGES AND
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. THESE CAREGIVERS AND
NOW JUGGLING BEING A RESOURCE
PARENT EDUCATOR THERAPIST THE
SOLICITOR VIRTUAL BUSINESS ALL
WHILE TRYING TO HOLD DOWN JOBS
KEEP IT ON THE TABLE AND A ROOF
OVER EVERYONE'S HAND. AS AN
EXAMPLE AMONG OUR CLIENTS IS
RELATIVE IS A RELATIVE MAYBE
SERRA WHO'S CARING FOR HER
COUSIN'S. FIVE SIBLINGS ALL WHO
HAVE SPECIALIZED. I PLACE
ORDERS WENT INTO EFFECT ALL
THAT SUPPORT HAS BEEN MOVED
ONLINE LEADING SIR TO SUPPORT
FIVE CHILDREN AS THEY TRY TO
ENGAGE IN VIRTUAL MODIFY THEIR
KEYS AND DISTANCE LEARNING.
LAST WEEK SHE REQUIRED SURGERY
FURTHER AGGRAVATES HER ABILITY
TO KEEP EVERYONE STABLE.
THERE'S BEEN NO INCREASE IN
FINANCIAL SUPPORT EVEN AS HER
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THREE
SCHOOL WHEN THE AUTOMATICALLY.
ANOTHER CLIENT ADRIAN HAS BEEN
CARING FOR THE YOUTH IN HER
CARE FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS
SINCE HE WAS JUST SEVEN MONTHS
OLD. ADRIN IS NOW HIS LEGAL
GUARDIAN AND HE HAS ADHD AND
REQUIRE SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES IT HAS NOT RECEIVED
ANY MDIFICATION TO AID.
EARNINGS IN ADDITION AS A
RESULT OF KIND OF IT ADRIN LOST
HER JOB AND BOTH OF HER
BROTHERS DIED THIS YEAR
INCLUDING THE BROTHER WHO WAS
SUPPORTING HER FINANCIALLY. HER
CAR'S BEEN REASONS ASTON SHE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
BECAUSE THE FOSTER CARE CASES
CLOSED EVEN LASSEN COURT
AVAILABLE TO HER. THESE ARE
JUST TWO OF HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF EXAMPLES OF THE
CHALLENGES ARE CARE GIVERS ARE
TRACING. THE STORIES ILLUSTRATE
WHAT I THINK IS AN OBVIOUS
POINT SUPPORTING CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE MEANS
SUPPORTING THEIR CAREGIVERS.
BUT I MAKE OBVIOUS STATEMENT
BECAUSE TODAY THERE'S BEEN VERY
LITTLE DIRECT SUPPORT PROVIDED
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE DRAMATIC
EXPANSION OF CARE GIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT KIND OF
IT HAS. LAYER UPON OUR FAMILIES.
THERE IS THERE BEEN A LOT
DANGEROUS TO THE- BUT LITTLE
ABOUT RESPOND HAS BEEN DRY
SUPPORT PARK GIVERS. DESPITE
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN
ON THE BULK OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY DIVIDED AMONG OUR
SCHOOLS. BECAUSE PROVIDERS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS. DESPITE OVER
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
TO SCHOOLS TO MITIGATE LEARNING
LOSS MANY DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE FAILING TO ACCOUNT
FOR THE SPECIALIZED NEEDS OF
THOSE YOU TO SIMPLY CANNOT
BENEFIT FROM EDUCATION SEVEN
EXCLUSIVELY VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT.
EVEN DURING HEARINGS ON PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS HAVE ALLOWED
FOR SMALL IN PERSON COHORT
INSTRUCTION MANY DISTRICTS HAVE
REFUSED TO OFFER ANY SMALL
COHORTS. THE RESULT IS YOU TO A
SPECIAL NEEDS ARE LANGUISHING
AT HOME UNABLE TO ENGAGE OR A
COMPUTER HAVING LOST MONTHS OF
SCHOOLING AND BASING MONTHS
MORE. SPECIFIC TO RESOURCE
FAMILIES THE INDIRECT SUPPORT
THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED BY
EXTENDING THE HOT LINES ARE
PROVIDING BINDING CONTINUALLY
RESOURCE CENTERS. HAS HELPED TO
ADDRESS PARTICULAR MOMENTS OF
CRISIS FOR THESE FAMILIES BUT
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN A RESPONSE
TO THE ONGOING FINANCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL BURDENS AND LAYERED
UPON OUR FAMILIES. THE ONLY
ADDITIONAL DIRECT FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THAT HAS BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE TO RESOURCE FAMILIES
HAS BEEN IN CASES WHERE THERE
HAS BEEN DIRECT EXPOSURE TO
WEAR DIAGNOSIS. FROM CURRENT
AND- I THINK I GREW ILLUSTRATE
THE END OF THE- TO EXTEND OUR-
THOSE. THAT HAVE STOPPED DIRECT.
ILLNESS TO ME DOES NOT WE MUST
DEVISE A MAC THAT ALLOWS FOR A
CARE INTO THAT'S IN OUR-
ALTHOUGH THERE'S BEEN MORE OVER
THE LAST YEARS TO DEVELOP IN IN
A TOOL AS A LOT OF CARE
PROTOCOL. TO IDENTIFY THE
HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE GIVING FOR
CHILDREN SPECIALIZED NEEDS THE
PROTOCOL THAT'S BEEN DEVELOPED
AND IS UNDER CONSIDERATION FOR
FULL IMPLEMENTATION WILL
DELIVER LITTLE ADDITIONAL
BENEFIT TO FAMILIES TWO YEARS
OF IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROTOCOL IN OUR FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES. I SHOWN THAT THE TOOL
IS WEIGHTED AND SCORED IN A WAY
THAT MAKES IT NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO GET ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO
FAMILIES AND IT'S NOT RELIABLE
AND IDENTIFYING CHILDREN WITH
HIGH TO NEEDS. IMPLEMENTING THE
TOOL THAT RESULTS IN FAST
EXTREMELY MINIMAL ADDITIONAL
FUNDS FOR FAMILIES IS OF LITTLE
VALUE IN THIS MOMENT OF CRISIS.
OUR FAMILIES DON'T NEED MORE
ASSESSMENTS ARE PROCESS BASED
UPON THEM THEY NEED. ACTUAL
SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE. FINALLY
I WANT TO BRIEFLY ABOUT OUR
OLDER YOU WE APPRECIATE THE-
SOME. THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDE
BY EXTENDING BENEFITS TO THOSE
NON MINOR DEPENDENTS HAVE
TURNED TWENTY ONE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THIS ACTION PREVENTED
HUNDREDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS DURING THIS
FISCAL YEAR. BUT IT ALSO MEANS
JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
LOOMS AS A CLASS AS THOUSANDS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE ARE SET TO LOSE
FUNDING ON THE VERY SAME DAY.
WITHOUT ADEQUATE TRANSITION
PLANNING THIS YEAR WE MAY HAVE
SIMPLY POSTPONED THE EXPERIENCE
OF HOMELESSNESS AS OPPOSED TO
HAVING PREVENTED IT. OUR CARE
GIVERS IN TRANSITION AGE YOUTH-
IN THE EYE OF THE STORM. WELL
WE CAN ALL HOPE FOR SOME LEVEL
RETURNED TO NORMAL IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BACKDATE WHATEVER IT
MAY BE IS MONTHS IN THE FUTURE
MEANWHILE OUR FAMILIES ARE
DEALING WITH THE STRESSORS IN
REAL TIME WE MUST RESPOND WITH
AN IMMEDIATE INCREASE SUPPORTS.
THAT ACCOUNT FOR ALL THE
DIFFERENT WAYS IT IS IMPACTING
OUR CARE GIVERS NOT
IMPLEMENTATION OF A TOOL THAT
PROVIDES ONLY THEORETICAL
SUPPORT. THEY ALSO NEED TO
INCREASE RESPITE SERVICES AND
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES THAT ALLOW CHILDREN
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS TO ACTUALLY
BENEFIT FROM THEIR LEARNING.
THROUGH SMALL IN PERSON COHORT
INSTRUCTION AND IN PERSON
TUTORING. AND WE NEED
THOUGHTFUL TRANSITION PLANNING
TO ENSURE THAT FORMER NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS HAVE A SEAMLESS
TRANSITION ONCE THE EXTENT AND
FUNDING ENDS. INCREASING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THE CARD AT THESE
CRITICAL ISSUES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANGIE AND- OUR NEXT
SPEAKER IS DOROTHY DANIELS
RESOURCE PARENT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR-
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE WITH YOU A CARE GIVERS
PERSPECTIVE ONE THAT LIVES IN
THE TRENCHES EVERY DAY BUT IT'S
THE LOVING TRENCH AND WE LOVE
AND CARING FOR THE CHILDREN IN
OUR HOME WE HAVE SIX CHILDREN
SO I GAVE BIRTH TO SIX. SIX
LEFT OUR HOME AND WE FILLED IT
WITH SIX MORE AFTER THIRTY
YEARS OF FOSTERING WE HAVE
FOSTERED OVER A HUNDRED
CHILDREN IN OUR YEARS AND THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME THAT I'VE
EVER SEEN CARE GIVERS IN SUCH
NEED- BECAUSE OF THAT NEED. MY
HUSBAND AND I STARTED A GROUP
CALLED FOSTERING UNITY IT IS
SIMPLY. A GROUP THAT SUPPORTS
CARE GIVERS BY CARE GIVERS- WE
ARE PARTNERED WITH AMERICORPS.
WE HIRED SIX FULL TIME SO UP
CARE SERVICE PARTNERS WHO GO
OUT EVERY SINGLE DAY AND TAKE
CARE OF CARE GIVERS SO THAT
THEY DON'T QUIT. THEY KEEP
TAKING PLACEMENTS. IT MEANS
DON'T HAVE. TO TAKE A- DAY- THE
CHANGING PLACEMENT IT'S NOT
FAIR BUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
SUPPORT THE CARE GIVERS SO THAT
THEY CAN DO THE BEST JOB THEY
CAN. IN MY HOME I HAVE FOUR
TEENAGERS SO I HAVE A WELL PRE
TEEN AND TEENS I HAVE A NINE
YEAR OLD. ELEVEN YEAR OLD A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD FIFTEEN. AND
THEN WE ALWAYS HAVE AN EXTRA
TWO SPACES FOR TO INFANTS WHO
NEED TO LEARN AND BE- A CARED
FOR LOVED AND FORMAT THAT
IMPORTANT ATTACHMENT. GIVERS
NEED TO FEEL HEARD THEY NEED TO
FEEL SUPPORTED AND THEY NEED TO
FEEL VALUED. WE ARE COUNTING ON
THESE CARE GIVERS TO DO
EVERYTHING FOR THE SYSTEM I'VE
HEARD COUNTLESS PROFESSIONALS
AND I HAVE A WONDERFUL
RELATIONSHIP WITH GREG ROSEN.
ON CDSS AND BOBBY KEGEL IT DCFS
THEY ARE OUR PARTNERS
ESPECIALLY IN FOSTERING UNITY
BUT WE NEED TO DO BETTER AT
CARING FOR OUR CARE GIVERS. WE
HAVE NO MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
FOR CAREGIVERS WE DO NOW
BECAUSE OF THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
HARBOR UCLA MEN AT A CALL
CENTER WE ARE NOW ABLE TO
PROVIDE FREE MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT FOR CAREGIVERS WHO ARE
GOING THROUGH THE SAME
STRESSORS. THAT EVERYONE ELSE
IS GOING THROUGH. I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT DISTANCE LEARNING-
MY FOUR LITTLE ONES THAT I
HAVE- ARE ALL SPECIAL NEEDS
KIDDOS SO THEY CAME HOME I
DON'T KNOW FOR COMPUTERS I
DIDN'T HAVE FORCE THAT THEY HAD
FOUND IN MY WIFI IS SPOTTY AT
BEST. BUT I NEEDED ALL OF A
SUDDEN DISTANCE LEARN. I'M NOT
I'M- I'M EXPERIENCED HOME
SCHOOLER UNLIKE. A LOT OF OUR
CARE GIVERS. AND IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT EVEN FOR ME SO I HAVE
A LITTLE ONE WHO OBVIOUSLY HAS
TRAUMA EXPERIENCES. AND I CAN
FOR SIX YEARS WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF ADOPTING WHICH OF
COURSE HAS BEEN POSTPONED- AND-
HE'S ON HIS. DISTANCE LEARNING
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS
TEACHERS SAYING IN HIS IN A
SPECIAL DAY CLASS SO THERE'S
ONLY TWELVE OF THEM. AND HIS
TEACHER HOLDS UP A STACK OF
PAPERS AN INCH THICK AND SHE
SAYS OKAY. GRABBED THE
WORKSHEET WITH THE BIRD ON IT.
AND THROUGH THESE PAPERS TRYING
TO FIND. THE ONE WORKSHEET WITH
A BIRD. AND ALL THE OTHER ARE
FOR THE BIRD IN THERE HALFWAY
THROUGH THE WORKSHEET AND NOW
HE'S SAYING I'VE GOT A
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL I HATE THIS.
NINE YEARS OLD HE NEEDS THIS
TRAUMA. HE DOES. WE NEED TO DO
BETTER THESE KIDS DON'T HAVE
ART THEY DON'T HAVE MUSIC THEY
CAN GO OUT WITH THEIR PEERS
THEY HAVE NO WAY TO RELEASE
THIS TENSION OTHER THAN THE
CHARACTER EVER WE WANT TO
SUPPORT THE CHILDREN BUT WHO IS
NOW DOING SO MANY JOBS THAT
THEY'RE TAXED. WRAPAROUND
SERVICES I HAVE FOUR OR STEPS
OF WRAPAROUND SERVICES. TO MY
CHILDREN MAGICALLY GOT WELL AS
SOON AS CODES STARTING IN MARCH
MID MARCH OH MY GOSH THERE WELL
SO THEY CLOSE THE CASE. I HAD
TO RE OPEN ROCKET RAP TEAMS. SO
NOW INSTEAD OF THE OLD TEAM
THAT WE NEW IN PERSON WE HAVE
FOR VIRTUAL TEAMS THEY ALSO
EACH HAVE ATTORNEYS. AND EACH
HAVE- INVESTIGATORS THEY EACH
HAVE AGAINST THERAPISTS AND IN
MY HOME WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
FOUR PEOPLE THAT WANT TO GET ON
OUR VIRTUAL SOON EACH DAY ALONG
WITH THEIR DISTANCE LEARNING.
IT'S NOT WORKING. WE NEED TO DO
BETTER. WRAPPING AROUND OUR
CARE GIVERS WE NEED TO DO
BETTER IF WE WANT THEM TO WRAP
THEIR ARMS AROUND THEIR KIDS
THEN WE NEED TO WRAP AROUNDS
AROUND THEM AND I'M SO TIRED OF
HEARING ABOUT POLICIES AND THIS
THIS AGENCY NEEDS TO TALK TO
THE AGENCY AND WE'RE WAITING TO
HEAR FROM YOU KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF BAD
AND DCFS IS WAITING TO HEAR
FROM CSS AND CSS NEEDS TO HEAR
BACK FROM CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF THAT. MEANWHILE DON'T GET TO
TELL THEIR CHILDREN THAT WERE
WAITING FOR THE MAMMALS WE HAVE
TO GET UP EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
TURN ON THOSE COMPUTERS AND DO
THE WORK. AND CARE FOR CHILD.
IN SUCH TREMENDOUS MEET. MOST
OF THE STATE OF OUR LIVES TO DO
THIS RIGHT WE'RE NOT DOING THIS
FOR ANY OTHER REASON THAN JUST
SIMPLY GIVE BACK. SO WE NEED TO
DO BETTER CARING FOR CAREGIVERS.
VISITATIONS THIS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUESTHAT I'M HEARING
FROM CARE GIVERS AND I'VE HEARD
A LOT ABOUT VISITATIONS TODAY
AND I DO AGREE WITH YOU THAT WE
ALL WANT REDUCE RESEARCH- OF
REUNIFICATION. THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE HERE FOR RIGHT TO BLAME
FAMILIES I WASN'T HERE TO A
DOCTOR EVEN THOUGH WE'RE NOT
GOING TO LIE I WASN'T HERE TO.
BE A GUARDIAN BUT I GOT A
GUARDIANSHIP OF TWO. BUT WHEN
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE WE'RE HERE.
BUT WHEN THERE IS FAMILY OUR
GOAL IS TO REUNIFY BUT NOT AT
THE RISK OF THE CARE GIVERS AND
THE FRAGILE CHILDREN IN THEIR
CARE. WE HAVE CARE GIVERS THAT
ARE DOING. VISITATIONS IN
PERSON. AT AN ABANDONED MALL IN
THE CAR. BECAUSE COVE IT HAS
PRESENTED US WITH NO OTHER
OPTION. THEY'RE NOT GIVEN PP
I'M SORRY BUT IT'S JUST NOT
GETTING DOWN TO THE CARE GIVERS
PARENTS ARE COMING WITH. OUT
THE PROPER CARE- THE PROTECTION
WE NEED TO DO BETTER AT GETTING
PROTECTION FOR THE PARENTS AND
AN EDUCATION ON HOW TO SOCIAL
DISTANCE I DON'T WANT MY
PARENTS NOT TO BE ABLE TO HIDE
THEIR ELEVEN MONTH OLD MY
GOODNESS THAT'S NOT WHAT I DO
WHAT I'M DOING THIS FOR. BUT I
DON'T WANT THAT ELEVEN MONTH
OLD TO GET SOMETHING BECAUSE
THE PARENT HAPPENS TO BE
HOMELESS AND I DON'T KNOW WHO
SHE'S BEEN AROUND. AND I'M
BRINGING THAT BACK TO MY
FRAGILE CHILDREN BECAUSE I HAVE
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN
HERE. WE NEED TO BE AWARE THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE PROTOCOLS VERY
VERY CLEAR FOR CARE GIVERS AND
WHAT IT IS THAT YOU NEED. TO DO
ON ANY GIVEN VISITATION. YOUR
DIVERSE CONCERNS THEY'RE JUST
FRUSTRATED THEY'RE FRUSTRATED.
WE NEED A SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS
THE VERY PEOPLE THAT ARE YOUR
FRONTLINE WE ARE YOUR- FIRST
RESPONDERS I HAVE A WONDERFUL
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS WE HAVE. WE HAVE THIS
THIS THIS COMMUNITY GROUP THAT
TRULY SUPPORT EACH OTHER. BUT
WE NEED TO DO BETTER AT GETTING
ALL OF THE SERVICES DOWN TO THE
CARE GIVERS THEMSELVES. WE HAVE
TO TURN ON THE COMPUTER EVERY
DAY FOR DISTANCE LEARNING. YOU
CAN TALK ABOUT IT WE DO IT.
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN ON HOLD
SINCE MARCH. THEY NEED TIME TO
ALLOW THEM TO GROW. LEARNING
STOCKTON MARCH THERE ARE
MOTIONAL GROWTH STOPPED IN
MARCH. IT'S TIME TO STOP
WAITING FOR EACH OTHER'S
AGENCIES IT'S TIME TO TALK
BUILD COMMUNITY REACH OUT TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE US AND LIKE SO MANY OTHERS
AND LET'S SERVE THESE KIDS BY
SUPPORTING THEIR CAREGIVERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR MY HOME
MY SIX CHILDREN. AND IN THE END
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR MUCH
DOROTHY ARAMBULA APPRECIATE
YOUR- YOUR VOICE TODAY AND- WE
HAVE ONE MORE SPEAKER AT ITS
PART OF THE THIRD PANEL- WE
HAVE MARY JO MERE WHO'S A
RESOURCE PARENT MENTOR FOR SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND PRESIDENT. OF
THE SAN DIEGO FOSTER PARENT
ASSOCIATION. WELCOME THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON US SENATOR PER
DOLLAR WEN NINE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HEALTH SERVICE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK- LIKE I SAID I I'VE
BEEN FOSTERING I AM THE FOX
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW BUT I'VE
BEENFOSTERING TO LIKE ALMOST
NINETEEN YEARS AND I'M GONNA
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE EMERGENCY
CHILDCARE FUNDING- WHEN I
STARTED I TOOK TWIN BOYS TEN
YEARS OLD NEVER LIVED TOGETHER-
DAY CARE WAS GIVEN RIGHT AWAY
LIKE I GOT IT RIGHT AWAY THERE
TWENTY SIX NOW THEY'RE MY BOYS
ANYWAYS- ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT THE BRAKES WENT ON TO
TAKE CARE FOR FOSTER HOMES. AND
THERE WAS NO DAY CARE I AM A
SINGLE PARENT AND I HAVE- IT
EVERYTHING. IN MY POWER TO KEEP
MY KIDS IN DAYCARE. AND THEN I
EVEN TAKE ABLE. THAT COULDN'T
GET DAY CARE AND I PAID OUT OF
POCKET TO MAKE SURE THEY HAD
IT. THEN I WANT TO SAY. TWO AND
A HALF YEARS AGO REGIS CAME
ALONG. AND BEFORE BRIDGES I DID
STOP TAKING CHILDREN FOR AWHILE
BECAUSE IT REALLY GOT
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE WHEN WE
DIDN'T PUT OUR NAME ON THE LIST
FOR CHILD CARE IT WOULD TAKE A
YEAR. AND BY THAT TIME THEY
WOULD CALL US AND SAY HEY
THEY'RE AVAILABLE NOW BUT THAT
KID ALREADY MOVED ON SO LIKE IT
PROBABLY ONE ON SOMEBODY ELSE'S
LIST AND WAITED. FOR DAYCARE
WALL- THEY CALLED MY HOUSE SO
BECAUSE MY HOUSE GOT THE CALL
IT DOESN'T TRANSFER TO THE
OTHER HOUSE SO BASICALLY THE
KIDS STARTED OVER WAITING FOR
DAY CARE WHICH THEY DO NEED
THAT INTERACTION THE SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS IS STREAMING
STREAMING IMPORTANT- THEN ONE
WHEN BRIDGES CAME ALONG. I GOT
A NEW BORN AGAIN AND SHE DIDN'T
GO HOME. AND THEN MOM AND DAD
HAD ANOTHER CHILD. SO HERE
COMES NUMBER TWO. AMBERGRIS
STEPPED RIGHT UP HELP ME OUT
AND THEN OF COURSE MY PARENTS
DIDN'T STOP THERE THEY HAD
ANOTHER CHILD. AND I'M HOME
THAT DOES NOT TAKE MULTIPLE
CHILDREN. I TOOK THE CHILDREN
BECAUSE THEIR SAME MOM SAME.
DAD WANTED TO KEEP GOING
TOGETHER. AND BRIDGES HOW ME
WITH THE PROCESS. SO LET ME
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT THE ACCESS
TO CHILD CARE IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR THE RESOURCE
PARENTS AND EMERGENCY CARE. I
BRIDGES PROGRAM KNOWN AS
BRIDGES IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
IT'S A KEY SUCCESSFUL PLACEMENT
FOR THE KIDDOS AND RESOURCE.
REGIS IS CURRENTLY AVAILABLE IN
FORTY FIVE COUNTIES WITH A
BUDGET OF FOUR POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS AS FOUR
THOUSAND CHILDREN REPRESENTED
ROUGHLY TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED FAMILIES. WHICH WERE
SERVED TO THE BRIDGES PROGRAM
WHICH IS YOUR EMERGENCY FUNDING
WE CALL IT BRIDGES IN SAN
DIEGO. LAST YEAR THE FISCAL
YEAR 6% OF THE CHILDREN JUST
UNDER THREE HUNDRED HOW TO STOP
RECEIVING BRIDGES VOUCHERS
BECAUSE- THEY HAD THE TWELVE
MONTH STATUTORY CAP. IN SAN
DIEGO YOU ARE YOU WERE ABLE TO
MOVE CHILD CHILDREN QUICKLY
ALONG- TERM CARE. BUT WITH COVE
IT IT'S IMPACTING THE
TRANSITION TIME AND OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE HAVING ISSUES
WITH THE LOSS OF CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND WHETHER THEY'RE
CLOSED FIRMLY ORDER THAT YET
THEY RE OPEN. IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR YOU GUYS ALLEN. ELEVATE THE
NEED FOR MORE FUNDING FOR
BRIDGES WHILE THE EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGES IS AN OPTION
OPTIONAL PROGRAM CHILD CARE IS
NEEDED STATEWIDE AND JUST SO
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A PROGRAM OR A
LIKE A GROUP HOME BUT IT'S%
POLANSKI. THEY TAKE CHILDREN
THERE BECAUSE THE CHILD IS AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION THAT THE
PARENT WHATEVER'S HAPPENED TO
ON THE CHILD HAS TO GO THERE
BEFORE THE INCOME TO HOME OR
HOST LEADING TO COME STRAIGHT
HOME. IF THAT'S THE CASE THE
SENATE POLANSKI WAITING FOR A
HOME BECAUSE THE CHILD CARE IS
AVAILABLE SO IT'S REALLY REALLY
IT'S AT. THE VERY SPECIAL
PROGRAM THAT YOU GUYS FUND- IN
SAN DIEGO AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR THE COUNTY JUST
EXPANDED THE BRIDGES PROGRAM.
TO BE AVAILABLE. FOR CHILDREN
SIX TO TWELVE YEARS OLD. SO THE
TIMING WAS. BECAUSE OF COVERAGE
AND IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
KIDS ARE ALSO SCHOOL AGE. SO IF
OUR DIGGERS ARE OPEN THEN IT
HELPED A LITTLE BIT. CHALLENGES
WITH NEW SOCIAL WORKERS THEIR
TRAINING AND SOME OF THE LACK
OF KNOWLEDGE. ABOUT THE BRIDGES
OR PROBLEMS. SO WE'RE
CONSTANTLY LAKE TRYING TO IT
SOUNDS FUNNY BUT THAT FOSTER
HOMESACTUALLY CALL THE SOCIAL
WORKERS AND EXPLAIN HOW TO GET
THE REFERRAL BECAUSE- WE NEED
THE REFERRAL BUT THEY MIGHT BE
NEW SO THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO
DO IT- SHARES WE ALSO. I WANT
TO ALSO SHARE WITH YOU THE
RECORDS OF KEEPING THE SIBLING
SETS TOGETHER. AND OUT AND- OUT
OF THE COUNTY ISSUES. SOME OF
THE STUFF- I ACTUALLY WENT ON
MY FACEBOOK PAGE WE HAVE A
FACEBOOK PAGE STRICTLY FOR
FOSTER HOMES. AND I ASK MY
FOSTER HOMES WHAT IT MEANT TO
THEM TO HAVE BRIDGES SO I HAVE
JUST THERE THERE'S THREE LITTLE
COMMENTS- KELSEY SHE SAYS THAT
SHE- SHE USES BRIDGES. I WAS IT
WAS HUGE AND HELPFUL FOR US.
THE ASSISTED WITH FINDING A
PLACEMENT THE FUNDING IS
IMPORTANT BUT THE- PLACEMENT OF
BABIES. WERE IT WAS EVEN MORE
SO. EVERY PLACE I CALLED TO
FIND A DAYCARE FOR A SIX WEEK
OLD TOLD ME THAT I SHOULD NOT
SHOULD HAVE. PUT IN ON PUT
THEIR NAME ON THE LIST WHEN I
WAS PREGNANT WHEN SHE WASN'T
PREGNANT BECAUSE THERE FOSTER.
RIDGES FOUND PLACEMENT FOR. OUR
SIX WEEK OLD TWINS. WE MAY HAVE
NOT TAKEN THAT PLACEMENT BUT WE
DID TAKE IT- WITHOUT BRIDGES
THOUGH- WE WOULD HAVE HAD TO
USE ALL OF OUR FMLA. AND I
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
TAKE A NEW PLACEMENT. IF YOU-
NEED MORE DETAIL SHOULD BE MORE
HAPPY TO SPEAK UP. ANOTHER
PERSON WENDY. SHE SAYS I'D LOVE
TO HAVE A FOR THE- IN CANNELLA
INCREASE THE A LIMIT. IN LIGHT
OF COBIT WE HAVE HAD TEAMS WHO
COULDN'T BE HOME ALONE BUT
COULDN'T GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE-
OF KOBE. AND WITH US WORKING
FULL TIME IT WAS SO HARD. WE
WERE TURNED DOWN BY BRIDGES
BECAUSE- THEY DON'T COVER THE
OLDER IDS AND I ASKED HER HOW
OLD WERE THE KIDS SHE SAID
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN. WHICH IS
PRETTY TRUE IN AND IF YOU HAD A
FOSTER KID THIS THIRTEEN OR
FOURTEEN THEY'RE PRETTY MUCH
LIKE A NINE YEAR OLD. THEY THEY
DON'T KNOW ALL THEIR BOUNDARIES
OR SAFETIES AND THAT'S WHAT
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT WHEN SHE
SAYS THEY GOTTA BE SUPERVISED-
AND THEN THERE'S EMILY SHE
SAYS. I'M SINGLE AND BECAME A
FOSTER PARENT THIS YEAR I
BENEFITTED FROM THE BRIDGES
PROGRAM. THEY HELP ME FIND DAY
CARE FOR THE TWO LITTLE ONES
PLACED WITH ME WITHIN TWO
WEEKS. THEY ALSO HELP ME FIND A
LONG TERM DAY CARE OPTIONS AND
A BACKUP OPTION IT COVERT. I
COULD NOT HAVE. AND COULD NOT
HAVE AND WOULD NOT HAVE BECOME
A FOSTER PARENT. WITHOUT THIS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR.
SO GOING FORWARD I WOULD LIKE
AYE I KNOW BUDGETS. MAY BE
TOUGH BUT IF- YOU WOULD. IF YOU
WERE TO MAKE AN INVESTMENT
ANYWHERE- NEXT YEAR I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER INCREASING
THE FUNDING. FOR THE EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGES PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU-
DOROTHEA JUST YOU KNOW ONCE
AGAIN WANT TO THANK ALL THE-
SPEAKERS AS PART OF THE THIRD
PANEL- BUT I ALSO WANNA THINK
MERIT JOE AND DOROTHY FOR
SHARING THEIR PERSONAL%
EXPERIENCES. JUST LIKE NATASHA
AND CRISTINA STORIES LIKE YOURS.
RIGHT THE REASON WHY WE'RE
HERE- AND- YOU DON'T THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE SO AT
THIS MOMENT I'M GOING TO BRING
THE CONVERSATION BACK TO-
MEMBERS AND- MOBILE. I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
MOMENT FOR THIS BATTLE BUT- NOT
SURE IF. ANY OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR QUESTIONS LIKE
TIED TO THIS COMMITTEE. PANEL
AND I DON'T SEE ANY. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO OUR THIRD
PANEL ARE FOR YOUR TIME TODAY-
AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL BE
MOVING BACK TO OUR WE WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD WITH OUR FOURTH
PANEL. FOR FINAL PANEL FOCUSED
ON THE PANDEMIC'S IMPACT ON
CERTAIN SUBPOPULATIONS FROM
WITHIN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. IN PARTICULAR NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS AND THOSE YOUTH WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED EXPLOITATION.
OUR FIRST SPEAKER HERE TODAY IS
AMBER DAVIES MSW FOOT SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF CLINICAL PROGRAMS
SAVING INNOCENCE. WELCOME AMBER
AND FEEL FREE TO. BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU- MY
NAME IS AMBER DAVIES I AM A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
IN THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
CLINICAL PROGRAMS AT THE END OF
INNOCENCE HERE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I'M ALSO A FOSTER
PARENT SO I DEEPLY AND
PERSONALLY UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUES BEING RAISED HERE- I
CURRENTLY OVERSEE THE TEAM
ADVOCATES YOU ARE RESPONDING TO
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED
CHILDREN OUR YOUNGEST CLIENT IS
NINE YEARS OLD AND THE OLDEST
IS TWENTY FOUR. WE WERE GOOD
MEMBERS OF OUR PROFESSIONAL
TEAM TO RESPOND TO CRISIS CALLS
ALONGSIDE BOND FOR SENATE
SOCIAL WORKERS. WE RESPONDED
TWO HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN CRISIS
CALLS FOR USE IDENTIFIED AS
BEING SLOW. BUT IT ALREADY IN
TWENTY TWENTY- WHICH IS
COMPARABLE TO PREVIOUS YEARS.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE
LIMITED BY THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES AND NOTICED A LOWER
NUMBER OF CRISIS CALLED. POLICE
WERE CALLED OUT TO RESPOND TO
RIGHTS IN OTHER MORE URGENT
CONCERNS. SO WE WERE NOT
RECEIVING THE SAME NUMBER OF
SADDAM'S FORCES CENTER PROTOCOL
CALLS WHEN ALL THAT WENT DOWN.
SH WE ARE SERVED TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE YEARS WHO ARE
AT RISK AND IDENTIFIED AS
EXPLOITED US US SO FAR IN
TWENTY TWENTY- WITH GENEROUS
DONORS AND SOME UNDERSERVED.
FUNDS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP
STEP IN QUICKLY TO ALLOW OUT OF
STATE USED TO RETURN HOME. WHEN
THEY WERE NOT COUNTY FOUND
ACCEPTABLE QUICK ENOUGH TO
ENSURE THAT A YOUTH RETURNS
HOME. SO THE IDEA IS THAT WHEN
WE ENCOUNTER USE WHO'S FROM OUT
OF STATE. THERE'S USUALLY A
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME BEFORE
THEY WILL RUN AGAIN AND SO IF
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
QUICKLY RELOCATE THEM. WE LIKE
TO DO THAT- AND THAT'S USUALLY
WHERE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
WILL ASK US TO HELP. IN THAT
WAY. THEIR CONTINUES TO BE OUT
OF STATE AND OUT OF COUNTY
YOUTH TRAFFICKED WITHIN LOS
ANGELES AND WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THEM OR ENSURE
ALONGSIDE DCFS THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO RETURN SAFELY HOME. SH
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH AND HAVE
SEEN DURING THE PANDEMIC A
MAJOR HOUSING SHORTAGE. FOR
FEAR OF SHELTERS. SURE AND-
HELLO OF THE JUST A- CABARET- I
MADE USE ASK FOR HOTELS ABOUT
AS WELL AS AIRBNB TYPE AS STAYS
FOR MANY OF OUR OVER EACH YOU.
AS AN AGENT WE HAVE ISSUED MORE
BASIC NEEDS SUCH AS FOOD ACROSS
CLOTHES AND SHE THAT OTHER TIME
IN RECENT MEMORY. IN THIS
PANDEMIC. WE CURRENTLY ARE
PROVIDING OUR PARENT
EMPOWERMENT PROGRAM VIRTUALLY
WHICH IS SUPPORTING PARENTS
WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
EXPLOITED AND- WHAT WE'VE BEEN
UNABLE TO FACILITATE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS IN JUVENILE HALL
FACILITIES WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT MANY EXCITED YOU ARE NOT
BEING IDENTIFIED AS THAT WAS
ONE OF THE MAJOR WAYS THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO HELP YOU
UNDERSTAND THEIR EXPLOITATION.
SO IN GOING INTO SOME OF THE
JUVENILE HALLS EXPLAINING TO
THEM SOME OF THE CONVENTIONS
THAT- ASPECTS OF EXPLOITATION
DAY WERE ABLE TO THAN TO SELF
IDENTIFY AND DISCLOSE THAT THEY
WERE BEING EXPLOITED AND THAT
HAS NOT BEEN AN OPTION. IN THE
BEGINNING WE RECOGNIZED A LARGE
NUMBER IF YOU TWO ARE
CONSIDERED MISSING OR RUNAWAY
AND WE KNEW THAT IF YOU CAN USE
INITIALLY WERE STAYING WITH
EITHER TRAFFICKERS ARE BUYERS.
THE YOUTH WHO WERE ABLE TO BE
WITH EITHER BIOLOGICAL OR
FOSTER FAMILIES SEEM TO BE MORE
STABLE OF THOSE WHO ARE IN CARE
FACILITIES FOR LESS STABLE
MEETING FREQUENTLY ETCETERA.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO BE
QUARANTINED WITH STRANGERS AND
STRUGGLE WITH BEING TRIGGERED.
OR BEING STUCK IN A FACILITY.
WE CURRENTLY CAN TO MEET WITH
YOU THREE TO FACE. ONE ONE OF
THE- WITH MASS AND SOCIALLY
DISTANT. BUT OFTEN IT'S A
COMBINATION OF FACE TO FACE AND
VIRTUAL. MANY OF YOU HAVE
STATED THAT THEY PREFER IN
PERSON MEETING WITH THE
ADVOCATES AND STRUGGLED IN THE
BEGINNING WITH VIRTUAL
PLATFORMS. WE WERE ABLE TO
ASSIST YOU WITH GETTING LAPTOPS
AND CELLPHONES THROUGH I FOSTER
AND OTHER PROGRAMS WHICH
GREATLY HELP TO CONTINUE
MEETING OUR EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
AND VIRTUAL MEETINGS THAT ARE
ADVOCATES. HOWEVER MANY USERS
CONTINUED TO STRUGGLE WITH
ENGAGING OVER. THE TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS SH WE HAVE SEEN MANY
LIMITATIONS IN TERMS OF CARE
FACILITIES BEING ABLE TO MANAGE
CARE AND SUPPORTIVE
RELATIONSHIPS FOR SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED YOU. WE HAVE THE FOR
PERSONS ON A PART OF. INCLUDES
COUNT AND ONE SUCH CALL WAS FOR
IT USED WITH HISTORY OF FOSTER
CARE WHO IS BEING EXPLOITED.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIND HER
SHE WAS ABLE TO MEET WITH THE
ADVOCATE BUT WHEN IT CAME TIME
TO FIND A PLACE FOR TO STAY FOR
THE NIGHT. DUE TO SOME OF THE
TEMPORARY SHELTER SHELTER CARE
FACILITIES BEING EXPOSED TO
CONVINCE THAT THEY WERE SHUT
DOWN TEMPORARILY OR THEY WERE
AT CAPACITY BECAUSE OF THAT.
SHE WAS OFFERED TO SPEND THE
NIGHT ON THE FLOOR OF THE
OFFICE OF DECSS BUT SHE TOLD
HER ADVOCATE SHE KNEW HOW SHE
GOT HERSELF A HOTEL ROOM. WHICH
WAS VERY DISAPPOINTING AND
FRUSTRATING FOR ALL OF US.
THERE WERE SEVERAL NIGHTS WHEN
THIS OCCURRED HOWEVER- THERE
WERE MISSED OPPORTUNITIES TO
MEET YOUR SPECIFIC NEEDS AND WE
FOUND THAT THE TEAM. AND
SITUATIONS ARE ADVOCATES
EXPERIENCE LIMITS IN ACCESSING
USE AND A CARE FACILITY-
BECAUSE THEY WERE REFUSED TO.
BE ALLOWED TO VISIT AND COME IN
AND MEET WITH THEM DUE TO STAFF
LIMITATIONS. STATING THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
STERILIZE THE AREAS AFTER THE
VISIT EVEN IF THEY WERE
OFFERING TO MEET OUTSIDE. YOU
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING AND MANY ARE
NEEDING EXTRA SUPPORT AS MANY
WERE ALREADY BEHIND IN THEIR
EDUCATION. MANY USERS HAD JOBS
AND THOSE ARE THE ONES ARE
IMPACTED. AND SO THEN THEY
LACKED FUNDS THEY LACKED FOOD
ACCESS IN ACCESS TO OTHER
RESOURCES. SO THEY WERE CALLING
US. AND YOU CAN KEEP AND CARE
SUPPORTERS. SEEKING SUPPORT TO
PAY BILLS ETCETERA. SEVERAL
EXPECTS EXPRESSED TO ME
PERSONALLY THAT THEY WERE
TEMPTED TO RETURN TO LIFE DUE
TO THEIR LACK OF RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT. MANY HAVE BEEN AFRAID
TO ACCESS THEIR NEEDED MEDICAL
CARE AND IF CALLED UPON TO KIDS
TO MEET THEM AT CLINICS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
SUPPORT AND ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
MEDICAL CARE. IN ADDITION THE
LACK OF SOCIAL IN SUPPORT OF
CONNECTION CONTINUES TO IMPACT
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH. A
TECHNOLOGIES ARE CABLE
STATEMENTS CENTER PANDEMIC
STARTED WE'VE EXPERIENCE FOR
CURRENT OR FORMER CLIENT
DESTITUTE OVERDOSE INTO TO.
BESIDES THE DISCONNECTION
EITHER FEELING AND REPORTING IS
TREMENDOUS WE'RE SEEING THE
NEEDS FOR FOOD CLOTHING AND
SHELTER IN HIGH NUMBERS. AND IN
AN EFFORT TO PROVIDE MORE
CONNECTION WE ALSO PLAN TO
PROVIDE. US VIRTUAL SUPPORT
GROUPS AS SURVIVORS NAVIGATE
HOLIDAYS GET. DISCONNECTED FROM
ANY OF THEIR SUPPORT. IT'S AN
WHENEVER POSSIBLE- THAT THE
SYSTEMS I USE ACCESS THEIR
SUPPORT PEOPLE SOCIAL WORKER
PROBATION. AND WATER GOALS HAVE
BEEN ADJUSTED OF THEIR GOALS
ARE DEPENDENT ON ATTAINING
VINYL RECORDS JUST CALIFORNIA
ID IN ORDER TO OBTAIN JOBS OR
FIND EXTRA. GT'S I'M ALSO
PERSONALLY. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ADOPT SOME OF OUR CURRENT
EVENTS TO HELP CREATE
CONNECTION BUT WE BELIEVE IT'S
A POOR SUBSTITUTE FOR THE FACE
TO FACE AN IN PERSON CONNECTION
ON THE CENTRAL FOR HEALING. IF
OUR ROLE IS TO HELP STABILIZE
YOU TO HELP THEM REACH THEIR
GOALS. THE CHALLENGE IS HOW
ORDER GIVEN THAT MANY OF THE
EXTERNAL THINGS SURGERY ANON
AND UNSTABLE IN THEIR
ENVIRONMENT. SHE HAS HEARD
PREVIOUSLY TODAY MANY OF THE
ALTERNATIVE CHARACTERS HAS
STRUGGLED WITH YOU. STAY FOR A
LONG YOUTH INTO THEIR HOMES OR
FACILITIES. BASED ON THE RISK
TAKING BEHAVIOR. WE CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR YOUTH AND WORK
WITH THEM ON HARM REDUCTION
STRATEGIES- WE HAVE BEEN UNABLE
TO MEET WITH YOU THAT YOU KNOW
HOW FACILITIES TO SUPPORT THEM.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE AT
INCREASED RISK FOR SUICIDE AND
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
WITH THE LACK OF OUTSIDE
SUPPORT. FOR CHILDREN WHO.
INTERPERSONAL SUGGEST SUCH AS
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS HEALING
ALSO HAPPENS THROUGH
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WILL EVER
SINCE THAT. WE CONTINUE TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THE LACK OF CONNECTION AS WELL
AS THE NEEDS OF YOUR CAR
CURRENTLY HEALING ANY. SUPPORT
OF THE PROTESTS AND DEMOCRATS
ON. THE TEAM OF PROVIDERS WE
OURSELVES HAVE STRUGGLE TO KNOW
HOW TO SUPPORT. THE GOALS
ALONGSIDE YOU THROUGH AND WE
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG THE
PANDEMIC LAST. WE CONTINUE TO
WORK AS PART OF TEAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO A DOCTOR WORK BUT
AS A SUPERVISOR I WILL ADD THAT
IT'S ALSO STRUGGLE TO KNOW HOW
TO SUPPORT A TEAM DOING ALREADY
CHALLENGING WORK. ASKING THEM
TO CONTINUE TO PUT THEMSELVES
AT RISK. THE LACK OF PHYSICAL
MEETINGS CAN ALSO IMPACT THE
TRUST WE HAVE ANOTHER
PROFESSIONALS ON THE TEAM. AS
SOME OF US HAVE NEVER MET IN
PERSON WITH OUR COLLEAGUES-
PARTY CFS AT SENTARA. I
RUTHLESSLY ABOUT CONCERN OF THE
IN. OF THE TAX DEVELOPMENT FOR
YOUTH WHO ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING. AND I AGREE WITH
PREVIOUS STATEMENTS ABOUT THE
NEED FOR FLEXIBLE TREATMENTS
THAT ARE BILLABLE AND ALSO SEE
THE NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS- ARE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF THIS
POPULATION IN THE CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES. A LOT OF TIMES
WE JUST CAN'T FIND THE
PROVIDERS- THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE WHO'S TALKING TODAY
AND WANTED TO HEAR ABOUT THE
CONCERNS ON THE GROUND. THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING ALL OF THAT. THANK YOU
AMBER- OUR NEXT SPEAKER FOR THE
FOURTH PANEL IS A MILLION
BARCO'S. A NON MINOR DEPENDENT-
BUT STEVEN MORALES WILL BE
READING WILL BE READING A
WRITTEN STATEMENT ON A MILLIONS
BEHALF. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. MY NAME
IS STEVEN MORALIS I'M A FORMER
PROSECUTOR AND THE PROGRAM
MANAGER OVER TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH PROGRAMS WITH THE STARING
AT SOMEBODY IN ACCOUNTS. I WAS
THE YOUNG ADULTS IN OUR PROGRAM
A MILLION MARKETS. MISS HARGIS
WAS UNABLE WAS UNABLE TO JOIN
THE CALL TODAY DUE TO PERSONAL
REASONS. BUT I WANTED TO SHARE
HOW COLD IT HAS IMPACTED THE
MILLION. AND HER LIFE AS THE
FORMER PROSECUTOR AND A NEW
MOTHER. FOR A BIT OF BACKGROUND
A MILLION ENTER PROGRAM ON
DECEMBER SIXTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SHE HAS BEEN A PART OF OUR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
FOR NON MINOR DEPENDENT. THE
STARTING OUR PROGRAM MILLION
HAS BEEN PRODUCTION AND HAS
WORKED ENCOURAGE JOBS AND ALSO
ATTENDED SCHOOL. EMILY IS A
GREAT MOTHER AND SPEAKS HIGHLY
OF HER DAUGHTER LAYLA IS CHEERS
ALL. OUR LIFE COACH HAS HAD THE
CHANCE TO OBSERVE THE MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS PARENTING ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS SHE'S
ATTENTION LOVING CARING AND
NURTURING. OUR ANALYSTS FATHER
CO PARENT AND HAVE A CIVIL
RELATIONSHIP TOGETHER. A
MILLION AS ONE THERE'S ALSO
CLOSER MAN'S GRANDPARENTS WHO
HELPED HER OUT- HYPERTENSION
THE TIME WITH HER DAUGHTERS.
I'M MILLION DAUGHTER GIVES HER
THE STRENGTH SHE NEEDS TO KEEP
PUSHING FOR. A MILLION HAS
ALWAYS MOTIVATED HAS ALWAYS
BEEN MOTIVATED TO PROVIDE A
BETTER LIFE FOR HER DAUGHTER
AND SHE HAS ALWAYS WANTED TO
GIVE HER WHAT SHE DID NOT HAVE
GROWING UP. ALL OF YOUR GOALS
AND ASPIRATIONS ARE GEARED
TOWARD BECOMING A BETTER
VERSION OF HERSELF. AND THE
MONTH AND THE BEST WHETHER SHE
CAN BE. DURING COLLEGE I
MILLION WAS SET TO EXIT OUR
PROGRAM ON OCTOBER TWELFTH.
BECAUSE ON THE DAY SHE TURNED
TWENTY ONE. ALTHOUGH SHE HAD
BEEN WORKING WITH HER LIFE
BECAUSE TO PREPARE TO AGNES.
SHE WAS ADVOCATING FOR AT LEAST
A THIRTY DAY EXTENSION. SHE HAD
JUST SECURED A NEW JOB AND WAS
IN PROCESS OF SAVING. TO GET A
PLACE FOR HER AND- HER TWO YEAR
OLD. PROBABLY IT HAD MESSED UP
ALL THE PLANS SHE HAD BEEN
WORKING ON EARLIER IN THE YEAR.
ALONG WITH YOUR LIFE SUCH
DENISE. AMELIE WORK DILIGENTLY
WITH ME AND MY TEAM ON
ADVOCATING FOR HER NEEDS.
HARGIS CALLS HERSELF HAVING
SOCIAL WORKER SHE CALLED THE
ABOUT HIS INNOCENCE AND HER
ATTORNEY. TRYING TO SEE HOW SHE
COULD STAY LONGER TO AVOID THE
INEVITABLE. FOR HER AND HER
DAUGHTER. WE ALL KNEW THE NOT
WE ALL KNEW THAT NINE NINE NINE
MINERS WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
ALLOWED TO STAY IN THE PROGRAM.
BUT THE ALL COUNTY LETTER HAD
YET TO BE DELIVERED OUTLINING
THIS EXPANSION. AMALIA HAS. I'M
REALLY WAS SET TO LEAVE WITH NO
PLACE TO GO AND HER ONLY OPTION
FIFTY EXTENSION WITHIN PROVIDED
WAS TO SLEEP IN HER CAR WITH
HER HER DAUGHTER. WHILE SHE
SAVED ENOUGH MONEY TO RENT A
ROOM. ESPERION ALONG WITH THE
COUNTY WORK TO FIND WAYS TO
SUPPORT A MILLION. THIS
INCLUDED ALLOWING HER TO STAY
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE IN HER
APARTMENT. WHILE WE WERE GOING
TO FINDING ALTERNATIVES.
THANKFULLY THE EXTENSION BECAME
AVAILABLE AND WE ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR
HER AND HER DAUGHTER. I'M
NEARLY EXPRESSED HER
FRUSTRATION ON HOW LONG IT TOOK
FOR THE ALL COUNTY LETTER TO
COME OUT AS WELL AS THE DELAY
EXPERIENCED AS THE COUNTY WORK
INTERPRET THE LAW. AND REVISED
BREAK INSTRUCTION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES REGARDING HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW. THE
INSURGENCY OPPONENT HAS
RESULTED IN LOST INCOME AND
JOBS FOR OUR YOUTH. AND GREATER
DIFFICULTY STAYING CONNECTED TO
SCHOOL MORE CHALLENGES RELATED
TO SECURING FUTURE HOUSING
ALONG WITH OVERALL ANXIETY
RELATED TO THEIR FUTURES. I
MILLION SHARED THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS THE ONLY THING THAT
HELPS HER MAINTAIN SAFETY AND
PROVIDES FOR A BETTER LIFE FOR
HER AND HER DAUGHTER. SHE ASKED
ME TO SHARE HOW IMPORTANT
PROGRAM HOW IMPORTANT PROGRAMS.
SUCH AS THE TRAVEL SOMEHOW PLUS
NOT MINOR DEPENDENT PROGRAMS
ARE SHE AND HAVING THE SUPPORT
OF PEOPLE AND PROGRAMS. THAT
WANT YOU TO SUCCEED. I HAVE
SEEN BY THEM SUPPORTING NEED TO
DEAL WITH MY PERSONAL MATTER
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TAX.
THANK YOU STEVE BANNON THANK
YOU MILLION FOR- SHARING YOUR
STORY WITH US TODAY AB. AND OUR
NEXT SPEAKER WE HAVE- SIMONE
DIRECTLY DIRECTOR OF HOUSING
AND HELP. WITH THE JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON- I WAS ASKED TO SHARE
FINDINGS RELATED TO CALL BUT
NINETEEN AT NEW REPORT WE
RELEASED SO I'D LIKE TO SCREEN
SHERRITT UP ALL RIGHT SHARE
COUPLE GLIDE SO THAT PEOPLE
AREN'T. HEARING MUCH OF NUMBER.
ALL RIGHT. YES IT IS. GREAT.
OKAY EVERYONE BEING THE SIDE
SHOW. I CAN SEE IT. WE SEE
GREAT THANK YOU. GREAT YEAH ALL
THE TECH THIRTY FIVE- WE
RELEASED WE DO AN ANNUAL REPORT
EACH YEAR BASED ON DEMOGRAPHIC
AND OUTCOME DATA OF YOU THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING IN OUR STATE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
FOR CURRENT FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
THE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PLACEMENT FOR NON MINOR
DEPENDENT OR HUGE PNB- AND I'M
AT THE BOX CARE PLACEMENT FOR
YOUTH AGES EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
ONE AND THEN IT ALSO WE TO.
INCLUDE THE REPORT INFORMATION
ABOUT A TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM CLASS WHICH IS A
PROGRAM CALLED SURE SHORT TEACH
PEOPLE FOR FORMER FOSTER
INFORMATION YOU AGE MAINLY
TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY FOUR I'M
GOING TO PROGRAM PROJECT
MENTIONED BY THE PREVIOUS PANEL
AFTER BOTH OF THESE ARE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE HOUSING AND
SUPPORT SERVICES- FOR THE FULL
REPORT- ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
ABLE TO FEED OR THE U. R. L.
THERE WERE YOU CAN DOWNLOAD IT
IF YOU CAN'T SEE YOU CAN GO TO.
J. B. A. Y. DOT ORG AND YOU'LL
FIND THE REPORT THERE TODAY AND
IT'S GOING TO PROVIDE VERY-
JUST VERY QUICKLY FOR ME
PERMISSION ABOUT FINDING WE ARE
HAVING THEIR RELATED. TO COAL
BUT NINETEEN. AND I. IF YOU CAN
BACKGROUND ON THE REPORT- WE
GET THIS INFORMATION THREE A
STATEWIDE SURVEY OF. AYE BUT
PART TRACK SYSTEM CULTURE ON
DATING AND THEN CALPERS TRAVEL
IN THE PROJECT- INTEREST. THIS
WE ASKED ABOUT THE IN THAT BE
NICE AND THAT WE- VERY
EFFECTIVELY EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT BOTH THE IMPACT ON
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT SH AND
WE ARE PROVIDERS HOW MANY USERS
WHO GRADUATED- HIGH SCHOOL. I
THE SPRING THIS YEAR SPRING OF
TWENTY TWENTY OPTED NOT TO
ENROLL IN COLLEGE FOOTBALL YOU
TOO COLD AT NINETEEN. SO THE
PERCENTAGE OF YOUTH THAT
GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
SPRING BUT OPTED NOT TO ATTEND
FALL. WE CAN TO COLLEGE
SECONDARY EDUCATION THE FAULT
EACH COMPANY NINETEEN FORTY
PERCENT. FOR CURRENT DOCTOR YOU
CAN TEACH KEVIN DE AND THEN 17%
FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH- CLASS.
WE ALSO ASK HOW MANY YOU WERE
ENROLLED IN POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION IN THE SPRING. THAT
OPTED NOT TO RE ENROLL IN THE
FALL DUE TO KROGER NINETEEN
BACK FOR YOUR 20% HER CURRENT
BACK TO YOU. YEAH P. AND CAN
PERCENT FORMER FOX NEWS. I NGH
PETE CLASS YOU CAN PEOPLE
SECOND TO- AREA THE KIND OF
GREATEST IMPACT THE WALL CALL
IF YOU ARE FOR YOU TO WORK
FINISHING HIGH SCHOOL THIS YEAR.
THE NEXT FLIGHT ABOUT- IN. AND
YOU KNOW THE IMPACT IS A LITTLE
MORE I PAPER NOW BEN BEN AT- A
LITTLE HARDER COULD THANK HER
IMPACT EDUCATE ALTHOUGH KNOW IT
GREAT. ON EMPLOYMENT IS PRETTY
CLEAR ON THE BASED ON YOUTH
EITHER LOCK THEIR JOB OR WHO
HAD A REDUCTION IN HOURS. YOU
CAN SEE- AND THAT ARE. YOU KNOW.
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ANY PROGRAM
KERN COME ACROSS TO YOU THEY
ARE NOT I BEEN IN. INCREDIBLY
PRODUCE THAT THERE. A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAY YOU KNOW. FIRST DOT
LAST IN FIRST OUT- SO BASICALLY
SEVENTY NINE PERCENT. OF THOSE
WHO WERE EMPLOYED AT THE ONSET
OF THE PANDEMIC- WERE IMPACTED-
EMPLOYMENT WISE. I'M LOOKING
46% POPPING UP IN MY HERE- WITH
THIRTY- WITH 46% HAVING LOST
THEIR JOBS AND 33% HAVING LOTS
HOURS. THE CURRENT BATCH YOU
CAN PERFORM ABOUT TWO YEARS-
60% WERE EMPLOYED AT THE AT 60%
OF WHO WERE EMPLOYED AT THE
ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC WERE
INTACT IT WITH 29% HAVING LOST
THEIR JOBS. 31% HAVING LOST OUR-
THE COACH THESE LAST TWO FIVE-
YOU KNOW WE REALLY- PROVIDING
DATA WE GATHERED FROM THE
SURVEY I THE- BLANKS HERE-
LOOKED AT DATA FROM THE PROJECT
AND TRACKING. DOWN AND WHAT WE
DID IS WE COMPARE IT MOMENT
KIND DATA UNEMPLOYMENT FROM
JUNE THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR
WITH THE JUNE THIRTIETH OF LAST
YEAR. YOU CAN SEE THAT HALF OF
CURRENT FOSTER YOUTH ON A PHD
MD OR EMPLOYED LAST YEAR BURKE
AT 41% THIS YEAR. AND I'M NOT
BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S AN 18% DROP
AFTER FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. I
MEAN SHE'S P. CLASS 69% WERE
EMPLOYED LAST YEAR VERSUS 53%
THIS YEAR I'M NOT A- 23% DROP-
BEFORE TH CAN. WE KNEW THAT-
AND THEN ACTUALLY GET THE BY
FOR THE SAKE FIND. WE KNEW THAT
BEFORE THE CAN DOWN THERE WERE
TWO- YOUNG PEOPLE AT THE- AFTER
CARE AND OUT OF HOME FOR. ON
AND ONE ONE OF. HELPING KNOW
WITH IN A HOUSING CRISIS AND
SO. JUST LOOKING AT DATA ON
HOMELESSNESS IN UNSTABLE
HOUSING- GENERALLY THAT WE LOOK
AFTER THE LAST FISCAL YEAR I
JUST WANT TO SHARE A COUPLE
FLIGHTS THERE- OF YOU TO ENTER
A QUEUE TO PNB THOUGHT THE
PROGRAM FOR CURRENT PROCTOR
YOU. OVER FISCAL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY CLOSE
TO ONE IN FOUR OR 23%
EXPERIENCE TOM LOOK AT WHILE IN
FOSTER CARE- PRIOR TO ENTERING
CHIEF PNP. AND 10% ACTUALLY
ENTERED THE PLACEMENT DIRECTLY
FROM. HOME WITH THE PRACTICAL
HOUSING. FORMER YOU THINK HE'S
LAST A FEW ENTER. ON TEACHING
OVER YEAR TWO THOUSAND I
TWENTY. FIVE ONE IN THREE OR
33% EXPERIENCED OKAY AFTER
EXITING FOSTER CARE PRIOR TO
ENTRY PHP CLASS. AND 15% UNDER
THE PROGRAM DIRECTLY- COME HOME
LOOK AT YOUR- TABLE HOUSING.
AND THEN THE LAST COUPLE I'M
SHARING IS HAPPY WITH PARENTING
WE'VE HEARD A LOT. FROM BOTH
EARLIER- TODAY ABOUT THE IMPACT
IT HAS ON PARENTS. OF YOUNG
CHILDREN PARTICULARLY. SO TO
GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF HOW MANY
CURRENT FAMILY THEY'RE LIVING
IN THE PROGRAM. AT EXIT FROM
THE PROGRAM- MORE THAN ONE IN
FIVE FEMALE DOCTOR YOUTH
ORCHESTRA YOU'LL MOTHER AND-
MORE THAN A THIRD AS A FEMALE
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH ARE COULD
STILL BE A MOTHER SH AND I.
LAUGHED WHEN HERE IN THESE
PROGRAMS A TOTAL OF SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN CHILDREN ARE WORTH
FIGHTING WITH A PARENT IN ONE
OF THESE PROGRAMS TO BE EITHER.
IT'S GOING TO BE SEVEN THAT'S
THE CHILDREN OF. THE UNIQUE
PROGRAM THROUGH OUR- AARON. I'M
AND I AND THEN IT YOU HAVE.
QUESTIONS OR BOB AT A LATER
DATE YOU'RE WELCOME TO REACH
OUT ME- OR IF YOU AND YOU KNOW
WHAT MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT'S IN THE REPORT HILL
STREET REACH OUT TO ME. AT THE
INFORMATION ON THE FLIGHT OUT
THE INFO ON WE HAVE SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REPORT
YOU KNOW ONE TAKE AWAY IS THAT.
YOU KNOW NOW IT'S JUST KIND OF
NOW IS NOT THE TIME SHE GETS
IMPACTED HOUSING FOR THE
POPULATION- WE KNOW THAT THE
STATE BUDGET IS VERY TIGHT. I
THINK ONE THING WE'VE KIND OF
LEARNED ABOUT- FROM THE
PANDEMIC IS THAT. FAMILY IS
VERY IMPORTANT KIND OF HAVING A
POD. HAVING FAMILY SUPPORT THE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND A LOT
OF YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE PROGRAM
DON'T DON'T HAVE THAT THE
COURT. AND RIGHT NOW I MEAN
THERE'S NEVER A GOOD TIME TO BE
HOMELESS BUT RIGHT NOW IS
ACTING INCREDIBLY SCARY TIME TO
BE HOMELESS. AND SO YOU CAN YOU
CAN BACK MEANT IN PROGRAM IS
CERTAINLY A PRIORITY THAT WE
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE-
CONTINUE TO TAKE UP- IN NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET. ONE THING IT
WOULD BE. REMOVING THE TRICK
PENSION. THE EIGHT DOLLAR TRADE.
HOW PRO- WHICH SUPPORTS OUR HAD
CANCELED AT THE- SEVERAL FORMER
DOCTOR. YOU- AT THE- TO PROVIDE.
AND. THANK YOU. THANK YOU- YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN AND FORTUNATE
TODAY TO HAVE CHOI BY SO MANY
INDIVIDUAL SHARING THEIR
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES WITH US-
THANK YOU- YEAH ONCE AGAIN TO
EMILY FOR SHARING YOUR STORY
AND STEVEN FOR SURE YOU KNOW
THAT. BEING ABLE TO READ IT
HERE TODAY. AT AS YOU ALL
MENTION AND WE ALL KNOW OUR-
JUST FOR EXAMPLE AND LIFE IS
TOUGH AND- IT'S A VERY VERY
CHALLENGING TIME. AND SEPARATE
SHEET THE TIME YOU'VE TAKEN ALL
TO BE- ON THIS CALL TO BE ABLE
TO TESTIFY PROVIDE INFORMATION
THAT WILL HELP US HELP- OUR
YOUTH AND OUR OUR PROVIDERS. I
WANT TO BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO- TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND IF TENER JONES FOR FREE.
WELL IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OKAY. B. YOU KNOW. I DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANYQUESTIONS AT
THIS AT THIS MOMENT I THINK
THERE'S- I WILL DEFINITELY TAKE
YOU UP ON ON ON THE OFFER TO
CONTACT YOU AND- I JUST THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF- OF NEED AND A
LOT TO DO AND- YOU KNOW THIS.
THIS IS JUST AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THAT WE IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD UPON THAT IT
DOESN'T END HERE DOESN'T END
TODAY DOESN'T- THE WORK HAD
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO CONTINUE. THANK YOU TO
ALL FOUR PANELS- HERE AT THIS
MOMENT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO A PUBLIC COMMENT. I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE THE PUBLIC
WANTING TO PARTICIPATE CALLING
NOW PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR-
WHAT PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE
ACCESS CODE OF. FOUR SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN ONE THREE FIVE. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE. CHAIR MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS- IT TO A ONE MINUTE IT
IS NOT MANDATORY THAT THE TERM
LIMIT THE LINK THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY BUT IT IS AN OPTION
IF SUCH LIMITS ARE APPROPRIATE
AND NECESSARY. NOW LET'S BEGIN
WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO ZERO THREE. THERE
WERE.
HI CAN YOU GUYS HEAR ME
YES THANK. I HAVE ARE. CENTRES
HERE TO SHARE. AND IT SAYS IT
IS EASIER TO FOOL PEOPLE THAN
TO CONVINCE THEM. AND YOU GUYS
HAVE BEEN FOOLED. AND IF YOU
DON'T SEE WHAT IS REALLY IN
FRONT OF YOUR EYES. NEITHER DO
YOU SEE IT CENTER MELISSA AND
IT IS VERY VERY CONCERNING. YOU
SAY THAT YOU ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE USED. AND TO GUIDE
THEM AND TO LET THEM HEAL AFTER
WHAT THEY WENT THROUGH. WHILE I
WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD IF YOU
DON'T MIND. OKAY OKAY OKAY COOL.
YOU'RE WELCOME. HE ALSO PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD
SURE MY NAME IS ON A CORD LOCK.
THAT HAS THE COVER YOUR NOSE
AND YOUR MOUTH WILL BE ABLE TO
GRIEVE TO WORRY ABOUT OF MICE
AND- REFUSED TO BELIEVE. MY
NOSE TO YES THANK YOU FOR
ASKING WHAT YOU'RE VERY
WELCOME. LET ME CUT TO THE
CHASE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY- THAT'S
THE POINT HERE. SO AS I JUST
SAID IT IS EASIER TO FOOL
PEOPLE. DAN CONVINCE THEM AND
YOU GUYS IN THIS ROOM ALL GOT
FOOLED. AND I SEE THAT IT IS
DIFFICULT TO SEE BETWEEN THE
LINES BETWEEN THE NUMBERS. BUT
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OKAY
THERE WAS- PANDEMIC IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE. IT WAS THE SAME
YEAR WHEN WHAT STOCK WHAT'S-
GOING ON THE LARGEST ROCK
FESTIVAL IN THE WORLD. IF YOU
GO AND CHECK HOW MANY PEOPLE
MAY LIVES TO BE LOST THEN.
COMPARING HOW MANY LIVES TO BE
LOST THIS YEAR. AND IF YOU JUST
ADD TWO AND TWO TOGETHER YOU
WILL EASILY FIGURE OUT THAT IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BUT I
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT MASKING.
WITHOUT THE VACCINES WHAT YOU
WANT TO PUSH ON US TODAY OR IN
THE VERY NEAR FUTURE. THERE
WERE MA'AM AS I APOLOGIZE
BERMAN ASK YOU TO PLEASE KEEP
YOUR MASK FULLY I AM COVERED BY
MOPPING YOUR AND NOW OFF I'M
NOT DOING IT ON PURPOSE TO
PLEASE STOP INTERRUPTING ME
OKAY. I'M I'M TRYING TO PROTECT
EVERYBODY'S WELL BEING AND I AM
TO SIX FEET AWAY FROM EVERYONE
SO. IF YOU FOLLOW WHAT YOU
STAND FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING
WILL SAVE EVERYONE HERE. BUT
BEFORE YOU CUT ME OFF. REPORTER
I AM IT SLIPS OFF I'M SORT OF
YOU CAN HOLD IT UP THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE. YES SO I GUESS YOU
REALLY DON'T WANT TO HEAR WHAT
I HAVE TO SAY BUT LET ME TELL
YOU ONE THING BEFORE I STEP OFF
FROM HERE AND THAT IS- EIGHTEEN
U. S. CODE PARAGRAPH. ONE ZERO
FOUR ZERO. MAYBE YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT IS BUT IN CASE IF YOU DON
ALL THAT IS FRAUD. IN REGARDS
OF A PANDEMIC WHICH IS BLOWN
OUT OF PROPORTION IT IS A
FEDERAL LAW. AND IT CAN BE
PUNISHED BY PRISON PRISON
SENTENCED MANY MANY MANY YEARS.
THERE ARE A MULTITUDE OF-
LAWSUITS GRAHAM I MEANT TO ASK
YOU TO PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO THE- WHAT WE'RE
SPEAKING WHAT'S ON THE AGENDA
TODAY AND ALSO PLEASE KEEP YOUR
MASK ON OTHERWISE I WILL LAST
SERGEANTS TO YEAH HAVE YOU
REMOVE TEXTING ALL THE KIDS IN
FOSTER CARE. RIGHT THE
FRAUDULENT. CAN YOU ALSO PLEASE
PUT YOUR MASK OR RETURN TO
COVER YOUR NOSE IN YOUR MOUTH
LET ME SEE I WILL TRY IT SAFETY
PROTOCOLS THAT WE'RE PLACING IN
AND EVERYBODY HAS TO BUY IT FOR
THEM FOR THE WELL BEING OF
EVERYBODY SO PLEASE DO THAT ARE
AMONG THEM. I WILL HAVE
SERGEANTS ESCORT YOU. IT IS ON
A MAIN. OKAY PLEASE CONTINUE
AND UP. TO WHAT WE HAVE ON THE
AGENDA TODAY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WHAT AND JUST LET ME TELL
YOU. THAT THE- THE CDC THE TOP
PERSONAL THE CDC SAID. THAT
THERE IS MORE THAT. FROM
SUICIDE. AND FROM A DRUG
OVERDOSE WHICH I THINK PRETTY
MUCH TIES IN WITH FOSTER CARE.
SO IF YOU BELIEVE HIM BECAUSE I
BELIEVE OR I THINK THAT YOU
BELIEVE HIM. AND IF YOU FOLLOW
HIS AGENDA OR HIS THOUGHT
PROCESS THAT THERE ARE MORE
DEATHS MORE SUICIDES. AND MORE
DRUG OVERDOSE BUT IN THE U. AND
IN THE FOSTER CARE THAN COVERT.
THEN YOU GUYS ARE DOING
SOMETHING WRONG. YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
YES YES THERE'S COMMENTS- BUT I
DO I WANT TO MAKE SURE I CAN BE
SEEN AND THAT I CAN BE HEARD-
THERE I AM BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
FREQUENT THIS BUILDING I'VE
BEEN IN THIS BUILDING PROBABLY
A HUNDRED TIMES IN THE LAST
YEAR BUT I HAVEN'T HAD THE
PLEASURE OF MEETING YOU-
SENATOR MELISSA SO MY NAME IS
SANDRA HAD STRUM AND I LIVEIN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BUT I DO HAVE
A QUICK QUESTION I'M NOT SURE
WHERE DR PAN WENT IS HE NOT ON
THIS COMMITTEE. BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T STAY LONG ENOUGH TO TALK
ABOUT THE VACCINE BUT I HAVEN'T
SEEN HIM SINCE SO THAT'S OF
CURIOSITY TO ME SO I JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THAT. MA'AM
I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO PLEASE
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO WHAT'S ON
THE AGENDA TODAY WITH DOCTOR
FOSTER. THE AGENDA IS HE NOT.
HE'S ON THE COMMITTEE WORKED
WITH SPEAKING TO THE TOPICS
THAT ARE. ON THE AGENDA AND
I'LL SPEAK TO THE TOPICS.
WELCOME TODAY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY OF FLATTENING THE CURVE.
IT IS EVIDENT BUT YOU HAVE
CONTINUED ON THIS PATH. TO
ENSURE RECEIPT OF CARES AND
OTHER GRANT FUNDING. THIS IS
CLEARLY ALL ABOUT MONEY. I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU THAT WE ARE
NOT INTERESTED IN KERR'S MONEY.
BECAUSE CARES MONEY IS BLOOD
MONEY. IT IS THE BLOOD MONEY OF
OUR SMALL BUSINESS IS DYING.
AND THE FORCED ISOLATION OF OUR
FOSTER CHILDREN. OUNCE GIVEN IN
THIS HEARING ABOUT THE
SUFFERING OF FOSTERCHILDREN
AND THEIR CAREGIVERS ARE
HEARTBREAKING. DOROTHY DANIELS
IS A TRUE HERO FOR BEING SUCH A
LOVING AND COMMITTED CARE GIVER
OF OVER A HUNDRED FOSTER
CHILDREN SIX CURRENTLY WELL YOU
LEGISLATORS SET UP THEIR
GREASING YOUR PALMS WITH BLOOD
MONEY. NO AMOUNT OF BUDGET
MONEY IS WORTH THE SACRIFICE.
HI HOW CAN YOU POSSIBLY BE OKAY
WITH THIS CASES ARE NOT
ILLNESSES. THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME IN HISTORY WE HAVE TESTED
HEALTHY INDIVIDUALS FOR TRACES
OF THE VIRUS AND USE THESE
TESTS. AS RATIONALE TO DECIMATE
OUR ECONOMY AND PREVENT PEOPLE
TO PREVENT FOSTER CHILDREN OF
ALL PEOPLE. FROM EXPERIENCING
LOVE AND JOY AND CONNECTION AND
FUN BASICALLY LIVING LIFE. IT
IS TIME TO END THIS FRAUDULENT
STATE OF EMERGENCY AND DEVE
FUND TESTING AND TRACING.
PLEASE ENTER INTO AN EXPERT
PANEL PROCESS TO DETERMINE THE
EFFICACY AND SCIENCE BOUNTY
ZERO SIX TO WHAT YOU ARE FACING
EVERYTHING OFF OF I'M SAYING.
CATCHER I'M STILL WEARING MY
MASK IS THERE A PROBLEM. CAN
YOU PLEASE TO STICK TO WHAT'S
ON THE TOPIC OF THE AGE I'M
TALKING ABOUT COLD BUT THIS IS
ABOUT COALPIT. WE ARE.
ISOLATING FOSTER CHILDREN. TO
THE POINT. WHERE THEY WANT TO
KILL THEMSELVES. WAS THIS ON
THE- WHAT DELUSIONAL STATE DO
YOU LIVE IN OKAY PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND CONTINUE YOUR
COMMENTS AND- WE HAVE A ONE
MINUTE. COMMENT AND SHARE YOU
COULD EXTEND. YOU DON'T LIKE
WHAT I'M SAYING. SO CAN YOU
CALL ME THE COURTESY OF LETTING
ME SPEAK I'VE BEEN HERE ALL DAY.
I CONTINUE. I'M CURIOUS HAVE
ANY OF YOUR EXPERT DOCTORS
REVIEW THE EFFECTS OF ISOLATION
I'M GUESSING THE ANSWER IS NO
AUDLEY COVERT RELATED RESOURCES
HAVE NOTHING TO SAY ABOUT HOW
TO IMPROVE THE IMMUNE SYSTEM
IT'S ALL ABOUT SANITIZING AND
THE MAGIC MASK SPEAKING OF
MASKS DID YOU KNOW THAT UP 293%
OF OUR COMMUNICATION IS
NONVERBAL AND YOU ARE REMOVING
THIS CRUCIAL ELEMENT BY
SUPPORTING MASK WEARING FIRST
OF ALL OKAY MA'AM AT THIS POINT
I'M JUST GOING TO CUT YOUR
HAIR- I ASKED YOU SEVERAL TIMES
VERY NICELY AND RESPECTFULLY I
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK- BUT- THIS WORK. ON THE
AGENDA TODAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FOSTER USE. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. GOOD THANK YOU.
ANY DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM. FORTY
TWO ZERO THREE. PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND
PROPER TO START. I MEAN FIFTEEN
PRITCHARD I'M JUST A PARENT.
CAN YOU SPEAK UP PLEASE PRIME
FIFTEEN FOR CHILDREN I'M A
PARENT. HOW MANY KIDS IN FOSTER
CARE HAVE ASTHMA OR AUTISM OR
SPECIAL NEEDS DYSLEXIA AND
EXPECTED. FOR THE SAME KIDS
THAT ARE EXACT AMENITIES
COVERING OUTLINED BY THE CITY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT WITH FACE
COVERINGS EXEMPTIONS- HOW MANY
OF THEM ARE GONNA BE DENIED.
BACK IN SCHOOL WHEN THE SCHOOL
TO OPEN. I HAVE TWO DAUGHTERS
THEY GO TO THE ONLY SCHOOL IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THAT STILL
OPEN RIGHT NOW. ONE OF MY
DAUGHTERS. SORRY ONE OF MY
DAUGHTERS TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL TOGETHER ONE GOT DENIED.
WHEN SHE'S EXACTLY MY MASS YOU
CAN'T DO THIS IS BURNING
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T READ ENOUGH
TO KNOW WHAT'S ON THE SCREEN.
WHY SHOULD BE DENIED ACCESS.
COULD WHEN SCHOOLS ARE OPEN
ENOUGH. TO FUEL FOSTER KIDS
EAGER TO START SCHOOL AND ONE
FOR ART FROM THE ACTUALLY
CANNOT WEAR ANY FACE COVERING
ARE GONNA GET IT TONIGHT AT THE
GATE LIKE MY DAUGHTER IS EVERY.
DAY THEIR EMPHASIS FASHION
DURING HIRING MODEL GEN IV
PEACH AT THE MEETING SPECIAL
LET IT TURN INTO A MEETING IDEA
TICKETS. AND SHE STILL DENIED.
MANY KIDS IN THE FOSTER CENTER
NOT HAVE THAT THE- MY DAUGHTER
CALLED ME DID WHY DON'T
REGARDLESS AND I DO. JUST
BECAUSE SHE CAN'T WEAR A MASK
BUT YOU CAN'T LEARN ON DISTANCE
LEARNING EITHER. SO I WON AN
AWARD FOR COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IS NOT FOLLOWING YOU
HOPE GUIDELINES WITH MASKING
EXEMPTIONS AND DISREGARDING AND
RAILROADED EVERY CHILD SPECIAL
NEEDS. AN I. P. IN THE STATE OF
VOTE IN COUNTY I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU KNOW THE COUNTIES OR DO
WHAT'S COUNT COUNTY. PUBLIC
HEALTH IS DOING. JUST EXACTLY
INTERNET APPROVED EXEMPTION SO
DO MATH. AND YOUR FORGIVEN FONG
CARE IT DOESN'T DISCRIMINATE
OVER RACE OR SITUATION OR
GENDER- MY DAUGHTER JUST LIKE
OUR KIDS IN FOSTER CARE OR MY
DAUGHTER AND KIDS IN FOSTER
CARE DESERVE THE SAME. CHANCE
AS EVERYONE ELSE TO ATTEND
SCHOOL DON'T DENY THEM JUST
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T WEAR A MASK.
VOTE THANK. THANK YOU. CENA
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO THREE- WE
WILL MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. I SEE NONE ARE WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO ASK A QUESTION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD MISFIRE
QUESTION ANYTIME EVERYTHING THE
ONE ZERO COMMAND. WE ARE USING
THE PHONE MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE SPEAK UP WE CANNOT HEAR
YOU AT THIS MOMENT. SORRY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. YOU MAY
WITHDRAW YOUR QUESTION AT
ANYTIME BY REPEATING THE ONE
ZERO COMMAND IF YOU ARE USING A
SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND- STATEMENT COMES FROM
THE LINE TWENTY FOUR LINE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE TWENTY FOUR IS YOUR PHONE
ON MUTE. BOTH NO RESPONSE WE
WILL MOVE TO ALIGN A NINETEEN
BY NINETEEN YOUR FINAL BUILD
OUT. HELLO MY NAME IS LAURA
RICHARDS AND I REPRESENT QUEEN
ANNE OF FAMILY SERVICES. THANK
YOU SENATORS AND YOUR STAFF FOR
HOLDING THIS CRITICAL HEARING.
QUEEN ANNE ANSWERED THOUSANDS
OF CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES
ANNUALLY TO OUR STATE WIDE
FOSTER CARE ADOPTION AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
RESIDENTIAL CARE SERVICES. AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE IMAGINE YOU
HAVE HEARDDATE IMPACTS OF CODE
THAT HAD BEEN FAR REACHING FOR
FOSTER YOUTH FAMILIES AND
STAFF. ARE FOSTER YOU'D COME TO
US ALREADY TRAUMATIZED AND IT'S
VULNERABLE POPULATION HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY KOPET.
PADLEY WE EXPERIENCED AN
APPLICATION BEHAVIORAL ISSUES.
WITH IDLE IDEATION AND RUNAWAYS
AND WE NEEDED TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
ENCOURAGEMENT AND CRISIS
INTERVENTION OUR RESIDENTIAL
CARE STAFF AND FOSTER PARENTS
FIND THEMSELVES NOW RESPONSIBLE
FOR SUPPORTING DISTANCE
LEARNING AND ARGUED THAT OFTEN
STRUGGLE. AND THEY OFTEN
STRUGGLE WITH LEARNING
DISABILITIES. DISTANCE LEARNING
IS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT AND
STRESSFUL FOR FOSTER YOUTH. IN
ADDITION FOR YOU TO
PARTICIPATING IN DISTANCE
LEARNING WE HAD SECURE THE
REQUIRED TECHNOLOGY. WE HAVE
MANY FOSTER PARENTS WISHING TO
GO ON HOLD DUE TO THE POTENTIAL
HEALTH RISKS WITH ACCEPTING
PLACEMENT. OR THE INABILITY TO
MANAGE THE DEMANDS OF DISTANCE
LEARNING AND COUPLED WITH THAT
IT IS MORE DIFFICULT TO RECRUIT
AND TRAIN NEW FOSTER PARENTS
DUE TO CONCERNS ABOUT COPAYS.
WE HAVE STAFF THAT HAVE NEEDED
TO GO ON LEAVE DUE TO
SUPPORTING THEIR OWN CHILDREN
WITH DISTANCE LEARNING OR DO
YOU TAKE THEIR PERSONAL HEALTH
CONCERNS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
NOTE OVER THE PAST THREE WEEKS
WE'VE SEEN MUCH LIKE WE'RE
SEEING HROUGHOUT THE STATE
NATIONWIDE IN INCREASING COBIT
COMPOSERS AND POSITIVE PIECES
IN BOTH OUR FOSTER HOMES AND
ONE DASH. THE NEED FOR MORE
SUPPORT THAT THEY CAN'T. OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS STAFF AND FOSTER
PARENTS ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN PROVIDING
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS. IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
ARE SOCIAL WORKERS AND STAFF
ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF FOSTER YOUTH
BUT THEY HAVE TO BALANCE THE
HEALTH RISKS TO THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. AND OUR
FAMILIES AND RENT RESIDENTIAL
STAFF NEED MORE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO DEAL WITH ALL OF THE
NEW EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS.
BECAUSE THE KIDS NEED TO LEARN.
AND INCREASED ONE ON ONE
SUPERVISION TO HELP THEM WITH
THEIR EDUCATION. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND COMMITMENT TO
ENSURE. ARTICLE FIFTEEN THAT
REMAINS INTACT AND WELL
SUPPORTED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATE UP HOW MANY PEOPLE DO
WE HAVE WAITING ON THE ON THE
LINE. WE HAVE THE SIX PEOPLE IN
Q. OKAY. AT PLEASE ENTER NINE
ONE PERSON IS ONLINE FORTY TWO
BY FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SUE EVAN I AM THE
CEO- HODEN FAMILY SAID THIS IS
BE PROVIDED FOSTER CARE AND
WITH TRADITIONAL HOUSING TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT SOMETHING
CHARACTER. I REALLY TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO LISTEN TO SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES WE ARE
FACING. A GAME WE ARE SEEING
LOCAL CHALLENGES AND- ALL FOR
HAVING TO CONSTANTLY BALANCE
KEEPING THEMSELVES SAFE AND
PROVIDING ENOUGH THE COURTS TO
ALL BE SURE HAVEN'T TO PREVENT
PLACEMENT CONSTRUCTION. IT IS
AN EXTREMELY CHALLENGING
ESPECIALLY WITH MANY OF OUR
TRUE COMPLETE SPECIAL NEEDS.
HAVING HUGE CHALLENGES TRYING
TO DO REMOTE LEARNING. WE ALSO
HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE SPACE
IMPATIENT CONSTRUCTION ALSO
WITHOUT TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
YOU SEE AN INCREASE. WITH
MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS. AND
CONCERN WITH ISOLATION. ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO- TO THAT I BEST AND
THEN THEY WOULDN'T BE A TO ADD
SUPPORT INDUSTRIES MANY OF THEM
WHAT. I WELL AS THE MULTIPLE
WITH TO GET ABOUT YOUR COOLING.
IT IS BEING VERY TIME NICOLE
WITH THE AN INCREASE IN THE OF
K. MANY. OF CAN IT'S ABOUT THAT
WE AT. IT CORE IT'S MORE
SUPPORT STAFF IN THE TO BE NEED
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS. AND
AGAIN WE THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH TO LISTEN TALK TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE FORTY SIX FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
JACKIE RETIRED- CALLING FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
WE REPRESENT. OVER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
AIRPORT- PRACTICALLY I WOULD
CHECK ALL FOSTER CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA ONE THIRD OF ALL THE
CONCERTS HOLDEN HOMES A 100% IN
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE.
AND SHORT TERM THERAPEUTIC.
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING THERE
THERE REALLY HAS BEEN SO MANY
TOPICS COVERED. AND CLEARLY
THERE ARE SO MANY CHALLENGES
FOR ALL OF US AND- SO MANY OF
THESE CALENDARS MIGHT BE SHORT
TERM- BUT THEIR EMERGENCIES
NOW. AND WE REALLY CAN'T WAIT
UNTIL MONTHS AND MONTHS GO BY
TO RESOLVE THEM IN PARTICULAR I
THINK I THINK THE MOST CRITICAL
ONE BAT. I THINK WE CAN ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE TODAY IS FOR THE
CHILDREN AND RESEARCH MEMORIES
IN PARTICULAR THAT ARE CARING
FOR CHILDREN WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING. AND THE LEVEL OF CARE
TOOL THAT ANGIE SCHWARTZ
POINTED OUT ONE DEVELOPED. THE
PHYSICALLY ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THE CHILDREN AND STAFF EXACTLY-
WHAT KIND OF SUPPORTS CAN BE
GIVEN TO RESEARCH FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN I DID NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT A- PANDEMIC AND THE
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS. BUT IT THE
NEW EFFECTIVELY AS IT STANDS
RIGHT NOW TO AT LEAST USE THE
TOOL APPROPRIATELY TO PROVIDE A
SUPPORT CONSERVATIVE AND IT'S
JUST BEING IGNORED SO THE TOOL
IS BEARING EVEN THOUGH IT MAY
BE A TEMPORARY TOOL- WE DO FEEL
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS THE-
HAVE THE ABILITY BUT ALSO HAVE
THE ETHICAL AND MORAL- I WOULD
SAY. HER BEST TO USE THE TOOL
AND THE WAY TO START PROVIDING
THE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WITH-WHAT THEY NEED- DURING RESPITE
INTERNET SYSTEMS EVERYTHING
THEY NEED TO GET THROUGH THIS
TEMPORARY SITUATION BECAUSE
IGNORING OUR- I'M THINKING IT
WILL. RESOLVE ITSELF IF WE JUST
WAIT FOR THE NINE MONTHS- WILL
LEAVE A LOT OF DAMAGE WITH THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
THERE'S REALLY NO NEED FOR THAT
SO I STRONGLY RECOMMEND. THAT
WE ADDRESS THAT. WITHIN THE
NEXT SIX TO EIGHT WEEKS AND NOT
LET IT WAIT UNTIL YOU KNOW
BUDGET TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE TWENTY ONE LINE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE TWENTY
ONE IS YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. HI
YES ARMEL I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THAT DIED IN THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION COMMITTEE IMPROPER
IN THAT REGION MY NAME IS ELENA
WELL A LITTLE BIT MONDAY AND I
AM A BORN UNITED STATES THAT IS
IN STATE OF CALIFORNIA COUNTY
PRESS AND CURRENTLY WE IN
AGREEMENT. I AM A MY AND DO SO
BECAUSE THE ACT NEEDED MENTION
I DID SHOOT SHOOT NOTHING BUT
TRUTH I HEARD A LOT OF MY
WRITTEN. I AM BIOLOGICAL MOTHER
TWO. MORE EIGHTEEN YEAR PART.
REALLY ON YOUR- MULLIN BLIND.
WELL TWENTY SIX NINETEEN
NINETY. AND GO THE LEGO BECAUSE-
THAT. THE OTHER WEEK. OR AT ONE
PINT PART OF THE PERSON IN
YOUR FAMILY PROFESSION NEED
HERE IN FRESNO CA. LIVING IN MY
PARENTS HOME WE LIVE WERE
LEARNING ON A DAILY. BASIS
ADAPT TO GET RID OF WORLD. GET
REAL GONNA DIE IN A CAR
ACCIDENT IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT WHEN SHE WAS FIVE MONTHS
OLD. ONE MONTH LATER I FOUND
OUT. DOCTORS HAD TOLD ME THAT
SHE WAS BORN BLIND AND THERE'S
NO CURE OUR AGAIN. I WOULD HOPE
LOS I WAS FROM A. I AM BUILDING
THE MOTHER ANYWAY THEN THAT I.
WITH MY MAN I. IT IS BUSINESS
TODAY DE TO THIS POINT IN MY
LIFE. BECAUSE. YES LIFE AND
DEATH FRESNO COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL. CRISIS PREVENT AND
TEAM THE CABINET CLICK CONTINUE
THE. YES I AM GOING TO TAKE IN
ABOUT. THREE THIRTY ONE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHAT THE
RUNDATA. FIVE SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN FRESNO COUNTY
THERE WERE SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE CASES FILED
ACCOUNTED FOR. IN A REPORT ANDH. S. O. NINE FIVE. QUARTER
FILING WITH BY MY- THERE WAS
ONLY TWO HUNDRED AND SEVEN.
ACCOUNTED. FOR THIS LEAVES AT
TO GO. CASES THAT I BELIEVE.
AVOID WHY DO I BELIEVE THIS
BECAUSE I FAMILY WERE DESK BY
MULTIPLE AGENCIES PARTNERED TO
PROVIDE A- BECAUSE MY LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL SCHOOL. REPORTED
THAT MY BOTTOM ABUSING OLDEST
WHO'S- WITH A SIXTEEN THE TIME.
HER SISTER GOT BLAIR MYSELF AND
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WERE
MISSING MY ANSWER BY. AND AS A
MOTHER I WAS TO PROTECT
GABRIELLE ALEC OF. BY THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT- I BOTHER THANK
THE LAST ANYMORE ABUSE.
MISTRIAL THE VEHICLE THAT. AT
SIX THIRTY TO FORTY EIGHT AND
SIXTEEN FORTY NINE THE TWO
CASES THAT ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE YOU'RE IN GOOD
THEM. NOW CAGE TURNING A
WRITTEN DOCUMENT WHICH IS
DEVELOPED. BASED UPON AND- OF
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH IS REQUIRED
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
INTERVENTION AND IN WHICH THE
TEAM HAS IDENTIFIED GOALS. AND
OBJECTIVES TO BE ACHIEVED.
THERE WAS A TO BE GUIDED AND
CASE MANAGEMENT. ACTIVITIES TO
BE PERFORMED. THE INTEGRATED
CORE PRACTICE ARE BASED ON THE
LEARNING FROM THE DELIVERY OF
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT INFORM
THE CASE KATIE A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT. ON FEBRUARY NINTH
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN FRESNO
COUNTY. THAT INTERVENTION THE
PROJECT SERVICES. MACHINE
BUILDINGS CATHIE NEED WIRE WITH
THE SOCIAL WORKER CORRECT THAT
WORKED OPTION PARTNERED THE
MEMORANDUM OF OFFICER. GONNA
USE THAT EMPLOY BY THE
CURRENTLY DEPARTMENT THE LED
CARE THAT I WAS IN THREAT HELLO
MATTHEW AGENCIES WITH THE. I
STARTED OUT IN YOU I JUST- ONE
TO OFFER TO IT'S YOU KNOW IT
SEEMS LIKE A BIT OF A CASE SO.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE MORE THAN TO
REACH OUT TO OUR HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE TEAM- YOU KNOW IF TO
WORK OR AROUND YOUR CASE TO GET
GATHER SOME MORE INFORMATION AT
THE MOMENT WE ARE TAKING
COMMENT. ON THE DIRE NEED
INFORMATION NEEDED FOR THE
MONEY THAT IS RECORDED BECAUSE
I'M NOW BEGINNING IN A FRESNO
SUPERIOR COURT I WOULD BE THE
FIFTH DISTRICT COURT OF
APPEALS. AT AT AND AT I HAVE A
FULL DISCLOSURE WITH THE-
UNREST AND REDACTED AND
REDACTED INFORMATION GRANTED TO
ME BY A JUVENILE COURT JUDGE
AND NO ONE HERE IN FRESNO
COUNTY. WILL HELP ME. NO ONE
HERE. WHAT WILL EVEN AT RISK TO
ME NOT BEING TAKEN OF GROUP.
THAT YOU'RE A YEAR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BOB ADMIN. NOBODY
RIGHT NOW IN TWENTY DO IS GO IT
ON RECORD SO THAT I CAN. GET
SOME KIND OF HELP. MY DAUGHTER
WAS BORN BLIND. RIGHT AWAY
WHICH EIGHTEEN SHE WAS TALKING
TO A FIFTY FIVE YEAR OLD MAN ON
THE SCHOOL COMPUTERS. THE F. B.
I. CAME IN. GRAYSON AND
INTERVENTION. I WOULDN'T DO
THEY MAY. ME AN IMMINENT THREAT
I'M MY DAUGHTER AWAY WHICH IS.
WITH THE GUY AND CAN. ABOUT AT
KNOW WE'RE NOT GONNA SHE SAID.
AS THEY SAID THAT BEHIND WHAT
WE'RE GOING GATE BOMB ALL I
KNOW MEMBERS I'D ENACT J. OR
THE DESIRE AN OF THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF YOUR- FINANCE CASE.
NOT ALL I'M ASKING FOR HERE
TODAY. THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU. I
ABSOLUTELY BUT- YOU KNOW THE
BEGIN OF THE MEETING THAT WE
STAYED AT THE WE WERE GOING TO
OR ON- TO IMPLEMENT LIMIT COMMA
TWO ONE MINUTE- WE I ENDED UP
ARE. TO US AND WE WANT OFFER
AND EXTEND SO AS MUCH AS WE CAN
TO ALL PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND- BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GIVE COURTESY TO THE
OTHER SPEAKERS AS WELL THAT ARE
WAITING ON THE ON THE- CALL SO
I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S BEEN
FIVE YEARS FIVE YEARS. THE
SOLANO PLEASE WRAP YOUR-
FINALIZED- COMMENTS WE WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT AND OF COURSE.
AS I STATED. WE WANT TO OFFER
AN EXTENDER SUPPORT YOU'RE MORE
THAN WELCOME TO REACH OUT TO
OUR SENATE HUMAN RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TEAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
TWENTY LINE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FACEBOOK SAYS JOHN
MOORLACH THROW TO CALLING WITH
CALIFORNIA LINE THE CARE GIVERS
AND WE REPRESENT THE BLADES
ASPHALT DURING KINSHIP
CAREGIVERS TO PROMOTE THE WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE. AND I WANT THAT SO AND
REITERATE- WHAT MANY AND- HAVE
TALKED ABOUT ABOUT THAT EXTREME
HARDSHIP THAT OUR CARE GIVERS
ARE FACING RIGHT NOW. AND
MEETING ALL OF THE NAMES- OF
CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE
INCLUDING PROVIDING ONE ON MINE
INSTRUCTION DURING DIFFERENT
LEARNING. UNTIL MULTIPLE
CHILDREN- MANY FAMILIES WHO
HAVE ALSO DONE THE PLYING AND
THE TOOLS AND RESOURCES NEEDED
FOR ONLINE LEARNING THAT WERE
NOT PROVIDED. BY SCHOOL. AND IN
DOING THAT WITHOUT ANY
ADDITIONAL. SUPPORT AT ALL.
THEY CARRIED ON AFTER FINDING
THAT READ OUR IS- EXCEPT. FOR
RIGHT AND LIMIT HE SAYS AND
MAYBE IT DIAPER AND ADDICT RE
CENTER ABOUT. THAT'S AS AND
CARE GIVER WHO ARE. THEY'RE NOT
PAID FOR THE CARE AND CHILDREN
AND THEY RISKY THAT REIMBURSED
TO COVER COSTS AND GET ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THE CHILDREN THAT
ARE NOT PAID FOR THEIR TIME.
AND WE REALLY NEED TO EDUCATION
AND TO ENGAGE WITH FAMILIES. IN
ORDER TO BRING. AT DIDN'T WITH-
SPECIAL ED. ME AND I EAT PEAS.
BACK ON CAMPUS FOR. AND TO
ADDRESS SPECIAL POPULATION
INCLUDING HOMELESS STUDENT
STUDENTS AND FOSTER CARE AND
STUDENT- TO BE BROUGHT BACK FOR
A PLACE. ON CAMPUS EVEN AT THAT
IN A GYMNASIUM OR A LUNCH ROOM
THAT IS SUPERVISED AND MYERS
DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO ADULT YOU
CAN AND ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
HELP THEM OUT AND NOTHING ELSE-
AND CONNECTIVITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A COMMENT
AND NOW TO LINE TWENTY FOUR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE US WITH THE TOLL NUMBER
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY. I
WITH THIS LINE TWENTY FOUR IS
THE ONLY ONE IN Q. THANK YOU.
YEAH I TWENTY FOUR MADAM MADAM
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO AND
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LINE OF JOB
AND FAMILY SERVICES MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE I FULLER MY COLLEAGUE
JACKI RETIRED YEARS ARE
REFERRED TRUMP MEMBERSHIP. BUT
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT OF THAT MEMBERSHIP-
WELL OVER HALF OF THE
NATIONALLY ACCREDITED SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS ARE PART OF THE
ALLIANCE WE REFER TO THOSE S.
T. R. CHEAT SHEET IN SHORTHAND.
YOUR EITHER GONNA FOR REFERRED
TO IF YOU CAME GIVERS- BUT
INSTEAD THEY- THEY ARE NOT THE
CONGREGATE CARE NOT TO HIS.
GROUP HOMES WHERE CHILDREN
LINGERED FOR YEARS. BOB THEY
ARE FAIR PEOPLE CONTENT
INTERVENTIONS HELPED. BEEN
RECOGNIZE AS THE CARE THAT
SUPPORT YOU COULD HIDE CLINICAL
NEEDS. AND AS THEY ARE REPEAT
AGAIN ATTENTION IN AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT OF THE CONTINUUM. AND
BECAUSE THEY'RE A BEEN SEVERAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE SYSTEM I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THEIR
BEHALF AND NOT TO REFER THEM SO
MUCH AS PROVIDERS WHICH SEEMS
TO BE A VERY COLD. I BUT ONCE
AGAIN A US THAT INSTEAD IS
BEING THERE ON THE GROUND WITH
THE CHILDREN TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
FOR THE TIME THAT THERE WAS JIM
DAY ARE IN FACT CARE GIVERS.
JUST TO A CENTRAL POINT THAT
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ONE IS ABOUT
THE STAFFING YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD FROM JUST ABOUT EVERY
SPEAKER WHEN IT COMES TO
SUPPORT FOR DISTANCE LEARNING.
THIS IS CERTAINLY TRUE WITH IN
THE S. T. R. T. P. WHERE STAFF
MAY BE INSUFFICIENT IN NUMBER
OR FRANKLY SOMETIMES NOT
FEELING THEMSELVES QUALIFIED TO
SUPPORT THAT DISTANCE LEARNING.
AND ANOTHER COMPONENT OF THEIR
DOUBTS EACH DST RT PETER
STRUGGLING WITH RETENTION.
THERE IS STAFF COMMITTED TO
THESE KIDS INTO THESE YOU BUT
FOR FEAR OF COLD. ARE NOT
REPORTER TO WORK THIS IS A VERY
REAL VERY IMMEDIATE ISSUE AND
SOMETHING THAT- WE WOULD VERY
MUCH LIKE YOU TO BE AWARE OF IT
IMPACTS THE COMMITMENT TO DST
RTP HALF TO SUPPORT THE USED.
IMPACT HEALTH SAFETY AND WELL
BEING AS WELL. THE SECOND IT'S
JUST THAT THERE HASN'T BEEN A
LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THE
CLINICAL SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO THE USE OF THE S.
R. T. P. BUT IN FACT THEY ARE
UNDER THREAT THOSE SERVICES ARE
UNDER STRESS. THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THAT THE USEFUL NOT
GET WHAT THEY NEED AND THAT IS
BECAUSE THE COUNTIES HAVE
WARRANTY STA RT PIECE OF SEVERE
CUTBACKS IN THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
CONTRACTS. WITHOUT THE CONCERN
WE HAVE IN THE THIRD OF THE
FINAL ONE ACTUALLY- TO EXTEND A
THANK YOU TO MADAM CHAIR. WE'VE
BEEN DEEPLY TROUBLED BY WHAT WE
ARE ALL SEEING IS AN INCREASE
IN SUICIDE POST COLD ED
EXACERBATED BY COPING. FACT
FULL COST TO USE THAT YOU KNOW
ARE EXTREMELY VULNERABLE SO
AGAIN WE'D LIKE TO THANK MADAM
CHAIR FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
TEARING THE BILL THAT
ESTABLISHED THE OFFICE OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION. THAT. WILL
ENABLE US TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF- CAL. IN BRINGING
THAT BILL HELLO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO WAY ELSE SEEMS PLEASE
CONTINUE I MODERATED STIFF YOU
CAN JUST PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
WANT TO JUST TO MAKE SURE HAVE
HEARD FOR ALL MEMBERS OF THE-
SURE. AGAIN A ONE. IF YOU'D IF
YOU'RE A COP. IN ONE. IF
ELECTED SHERIFF. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE COMING UP AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU HAVING HEARD ALL
PUBLIC TESTIMONY I WANT TO
BRING IT BACK AND ASK OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF THERE ARE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ON. CONVENTION CENTER
JONES. THANK YOU MA'AM SURE I
JUST WANT A- ALSO HAD MY-
THANKS TO OUR FOR YOU
CONDUCTING THIS HEARING I WANT
TO THANK THE WITNESSES THAT
CAME TO THE CAPITOL TODAY IT'S-
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES IS
NOT EASY TO GET INTO THE
CAPITAL. OF THESE DAYS SO IT IS
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THE EFFORT AND- COMING
HERE AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
CHAIRWOMAN OF MYSELF- HEARD. IF
NOT ALL OF YOUR COMMENTS AT
LEAST TO THE- MESSAGE BEHIND
THOSE COMMENTS AND WE TAKE THEM
VERY SERIOUSLY. AND I LEARNED A
LOT TODAY- I ALWAYS KIND OF HAD
A- I THOUGHT THE YOU KNOW SOME
OF THESE CHALLENGES WHAT WERE
WERE COMING UP BUT I I'D NEVER
HAD ANY YOU KNOW DIRECT.
TESTIMONY YOUR STATISTICS TO
BACK THAT UP AND SO I'M
THANKFUL TO SAY THAT WE ARE
RECEIVING THAT AND I'M
HOPEFULLY HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A MESSAGE
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON-
THE IMPACTS OF THESE LOCKDOWNS
IN- AND HAVE A GOOD
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
AND I LOOK I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AS YOU KNOW IN
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS AND
MONTHS- I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR JOINING US TODAY I KNOW I
HAVE BEEN- INCREDIBLY
INCREDIBLY MOVED. ABOUT THE
TESTIMONY WE HAVE HEARD- I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORK WITH WORKING
WITH OUR VICE CHAIR WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF WITH THE
BOMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- TO
REALLY COME UP AND YOU KNOW
MEET THE CHALLENGES THAT THAT
TO A WORLD FACING BUT
PARTICULARLY OUR FOSTER YOUTH
AND CHILDREN. THANK YOU TO ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CALLED
IN TODAY TO PARTICIPATE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES- COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL HERE-
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION-
AND YOU KNOW WHAT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- FOR. WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY AND THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE MEETING AS A
DRUG.